LEGISLATIVE SESSION. WE'RE GOING
TO GET STARTED IN 30S. IF WE
COULD HAVE ALL SENATORS TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE YOUR SEATS. WE HAVE
A VERY SPECIAL INTRODUCTION HERE
IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS. AND WE
HAVE BEEN TOLD A SPECIAL MUSIC
ACT WILL BE MAKING AN APPEARANCE
IN JUST ABOUT 30S. WE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE, WE'RE GOING TO BE
HONORING ONE OF OUR OWN HERE
TODAY. AND THAT'S OUR ASSISTANT
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE. CAN WE
PLEASE GIVE IT UP LOUD AND PROUD
FOR THE ONE, THE ONLY BERNIE
MCNULTY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THE
SENATE. BERNIE. BERNIE WANTS TO
HEAD OFF ON THE CRAZY TRAIN.
LET'S GO TO THE MUSIC, EVERYBODY.
HEY WOO! CRAZY WOO! BUT THAT'S
HOW IT GOES. LET ME HEAR YOU
SING IT. LET'S GO. PEOPLE CAN I
HEAR IT LOUD AND PROUD? LET'S
GIVE IT UP FOR BERNIE MCNULTY.
EVERYONE IT'S NOT TOO LATE.
SENATE WILL CONVENE IN 30S.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE NEW TO
THE SENATE, THIS IS HOW WE START
EVERY SESSION. WE WELCOME YOU
TO. MR. SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? ALLEN.
OVERALL, GILL. ARCHULETA. ASHBY
ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKESBURG
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. CORTEZ
DALLY. DODD. EGGMAN DURAZO.
EGGMAN. GLAZER GONZALEZ. GROVE.
HURTADO JONES. LAIRD. LIMÓN
MCGUIRE. MENJIVAR. MINH NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. SATO.
SKINNER. SMALL CUEVAS. STERN.
UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER. WILK THANK
YOU, MR. SECRETARY. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS. BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE. WE'RE
GOING TO BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR AMAZING
CHAPLAIN. WE ARE SO GRATEFUL
THAT SISTER MICHELLE IS HERE,
AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO ALL PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. SISTER MICHELLE.
WELL, DANCE. I DON'T HAVE A GOOD
PRAYER AFTER THAT FOR BERNIE. IF
I KNEW I WOULD HAVE, BUT MAYBE
THIS ONE WILL DO. LET US PRAY IN
GRATITUDE FOR THE BLESSINGS OF
THIS SESSION, AND FOR EACH ONE
OF US, AND ESPECIALLY BERNIE.
AND WE PRAY, IN THE WORDS OF
RABINDRANATH TAGORE. LOVING GOD,
YOU HAVE MADE US KNOWN TO
FRIENDS WHOM WE KNEW NOT. YOU
HAVE GIVEN US SEATS AND HOMES,
NOT OUR OWN. YOU HAVE BROUGHT
THE DISTANT NEAR AND MADE A
BROTHER SISTER OF THE STRANGER.
WE ARE UNEASY AT HEART WHEN WE
HAVE TO LEAVE OUR ACCUSTOMED OUR
UNACCUSTOMED, OUR ACCUSTOMED
SHELTER. SORRY. WE FORGET THAT
THERE ABIDES THE OLD AND THE
NEW. AND THAT THERE ALSO YOU
ABIDE THROUGH BIRTH AND DEATH IN
THIS WORLD OR IN OTHERS.
WHEREVER YOU LEAD US, YOU LINK
OUR HEARTS WITH BANDS OF JOY TO
THE UNFAMILIAR AND THE FAMILIAR.
WHEN ONE KNOWS YOU, THEN ALIEN
THERE IS NONE, THEN NO DOOR IS
SHUT. OH GRANT US OUR PRAYER
THAT WE MAY NEVER LOSE THE BLISS
OF THE TOUCH OF THE ONE IN THE
PLAY. OF THE MANY. AND UNTIL WE
MEET AGAIN. MAY THE LORD BLESS
US AND KEEP US. MAY GOD LET HER
FACE SHINE UPON US. AND MAY GOD
LOOK UPON US KINDLY AND GIVE US
PEACE. AMEN THANK YOU, SISTER
MICHELLE. MEMBERS, PLEASE JOIN
US IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE ARE JOINED BY SPECIAL
GUEST HERE TODAY OF COURSE,
CALIFORNIANS FROM EVERY CORNER
OF THIS GREAT STATE. WE ALSO
WANT TO BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
FORMER PRO TEM AND CURRENT
SACRAMENTO MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG IS HERE TODAY. MY
GOODNESS. CAN WE PLEASE GIVE PRO
TEM STEINBERG A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE? WE ARE ALSO GRATEFUL
THAT BERNIE SPOUSE AMY IS HERE
TODAY. AND CAN WE PLEASE GIVE
HER A ROUND OF APPLAUSE?
SENATORS, YOU HAVE REALLY DONE
INCREDIBLE WORK THIS WEEK. AND
AS YOU KNOW, PURSUANT PURSUANT
TO THE CONSTITUTION, TODAY IS
THE LAST DAY FOR EACH HOUSE TO
PASS BILLS AT 12 MIDNIGHT THIS
EVENING. THIS WEEK WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH HUNDREDS OF
BILLS. YOUR WORK HAS BEEN A
TESTAMENT, A TESTAMENT TO THE
DEDICATION AND PURPOSE THAT YOU
BRING TO THIS JOB EACH AND EVERY
DAY. TODAY IS GOING TO BE A DAY
WHERE WE NEED TO BE PATIENT. WE
ASK FOR SOME FLEXIBILITY, AND
WE'RE GOING TO GET THE JOB DONE.
BEING FOCUSED ON SEVERAL
MEASURES THAT WILL BE IN FRONT
OF US. WE WANT TO GIVE FOLKS A
HEADS UP. THERE WILL BE RECESS
TIMES AND MOMENTS OF WAITING,
AND IN BETWEEN WE'LL PLAY A
COUPLE OTHER TUNES AND HAVE
BERNIE DO A LITTLE BIT OF A
DANCE. WITH THAT SAID, WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY 4545 ASSEMBLY
BILLS IN FRONT OF US TODAY, AND
APPROXIMATELY 60 SENATE BILLS TO
BE ABLE TO DISPENSE WITH BETWEEN
NOW AND THE MIDNIGHT HOUR. SO IN
THE FAMOUS FOR WORDS, LET'S GET
TO WORK. AND LET'S BE HONEST,
THE SENATE'S WORK, THE SENATE'S
WORK WOULDN'T HAPPEN WITHOUT THE
ALWAYS GET IT DONE. BERNIE
MCNULTY THIS MORNING. THIS
AFTERNOON WE'RE GOING TO HONOR
BERNIE. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
HER. AND WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR AMAZING
SERVICE. I'M GOING TO TRY TO GET
THROUGH THIS WITHOUT GETTING
BLUBBERY. ALL RIGHT. SUCK IT UP,
BUTTERCUP, IS WHAT SHE JUST
SAID. OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HOT YOU KNOW, BERNIE IS ONE OF A
KIND. SHE IS TOUGH AS NAILS. SHE
IS SMART, INNOVATIVE, AND ONE OF
THE BEST PROBLEM SOLVERS. I
THINK THAT WE HAVE EVER MET.
SHE'S THE TYPE OF PERSON THAT
YOU WANT BY YOUR SIDE IN THE
TOUGHEST MOMENTS OF YOUR LIFE.
WHETHER IT'S PERSONAL OR
PROFESSIONAL. SHE LIVES HER LIFE
ALWAYS BY GOING THE EXTRA MILE.
YOU KNOW, THE CAPITOL MORNING
REPORT ONCE DID AN ARTICLE ABOUT
BERNIE, AND IN THAT ARTICLE IT
MENTIONED THE BLOOD THROWING
INCIDENT HERE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR AND HOW QUICKLY AND
SMOOTHLY THE SENATE RECOVERED TO
FINISH THAT END OF SESSION. THE
ARTICLE RECOUNTED HOW AMAZING IT
WAS THAT THINGS WENT SO
SEAMLESSLY WHEN SENATORS AND
STAFF HAD TO RETREAT TO ROOM
4203. THAT NIGHT, WE HAD
EVERYTHING READY TO GO. WITHIN
45 MINUTES. WE EVEN HAD EXTRA
PENCILS AND PENS FOR EVERY
MEMBER OF THE SENATE. BERNIE
THOUGHT OF EVERYTHING. NOW NO
ONE, NO ONE SHOULD BE AMAZED
BECAUSE THERE WAS WORK TO DO AND
CHIEF ASSISTANT SECRETARY
BERNADETTE MCNULTY WAS ON THE
JOB. WHENEVER THE SENATE HAS
WORK TO DO, YOU CAN COUNT ON
BERNIE TO GET THE JOB DONE. AND
NO MATTER WHO YOU ARE, BERNIE IS
ALWAYS GOING TO BE THERE FOR
YOU. SHE'S ALWAYS GOING TO GO
THE EXTRA MILE, AND SHE'S ALWAYS
GOING TO PUT PEOPLE FIRST.
BERNIE SERVED THIS NATION FOR 28
YEARS IN THE US AIR FORCE
RESERVES, AND SHE HAS SERVED THE
SENATE AND THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR 27 YEARS, THE
LAST 15 YEARS AS ASSISTANT
SECRETARY. AND CANDIDLY, WE ARE
ALL BETTER OFF FOR. WE'RE ALL
BETTER OFF FOR HAVING WORKED
WITH OR WORKED WITH HER. IF I
COULD BE CANDID, WE ACTUALLY
WORK FOR BERNIE. THIS STATE IS
STRONGER BECAUSE OF HER
LEADERSHIP AS IT COMES TIME FOR
BERNIE TO FINISH HER WORK AND
TURN THE PAGE ON. JUST AN
AMAZING CAREER OF PUBLIC
SERVICE. WE'D LIKE TO OFFER THIS
FINAL COMMENT. BERNIE IT HAS
BEEN AN HONOR OF A LIFETIME FOR
ALL OF US TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH YOU, AND I KNOW THAT IT MAY
NOT BE PERMISSIBLE UNDER THE
RULES OF THE OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE, BUT WE WANT TO LET
YOU KNOW WE LOVE YOU, BERNIE.
YOU ARE TRULY THE BEST. CAN WE
PLEASE GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
TO THE ONE, THE ONLY? BERNADETTE
MCNULTY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE, ESTEEMED STAFF. AND TO
THE RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA, WE
HAVE A FEW FOLKS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO SAY SOME WORDS. WE
WOULD NOW LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
LEADER JONES ON THE FLOOR. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND HONOR TO THANK
BERNIE FOR HER SERVICE TO THIS
AUGUST BODY, TO OUR STATE AND TO
OUR COUNTRY, MANY OF YOU KNOW
THAT I COME FROM A NAVY AND
MARINE TOWN, BUT WHAT YOU MAY
NOT KNOW IS I HAVE A PARTICULAR
AFFINITY TO THE US AIR FORCE. MY
GRANDFATHER SERVED DURING
VIETNAM. I'M SORRY. MY DAD
SERVED DURING VIETNAM. MY
GRANDFATHER RETIRED FROM THE US
AIR FORCE IN 1965 AND WAS A POW
FOR TWO YEARS DURING WORLD WAR
TWO. SO THE US AIR FORCE HAS A
PARTICULAR, CLOSENESS IN MY
HEART. AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
HELPED IMMEDIATELY ME TAKE A
FONDNESS TO BERNIE. EVEN BEFORE
MEETING HER. AND BEING WARNED
ABOUT NOT TO CROSS BERNIE. I
DIDN'T CARE BECAUSE WE HAD THE
AIR FORCE THING, AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY.
NOW, I KNOW BERNIE WOULD RATHER
US NOT DO ALL OF THIS TODAY, AND
SHE WOULD RATHER US KEEP IT
BRIEF. BUT I HAVE A 30 MINUTE
SPEECH BECAUSE I WENT BACK AND
GOT HER ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
RECORDS, HER HIGH SCHOOL
YEARBOOK, AND EVEN SOME OF HER
US AIR FORCE RECORDS THAT I'D
LIKE TO SPEND THE NEXT 30
MINUTES TALKING ABOUT HOW GREAT
BERNIE IS, IS AND WAS AND BUT I,
I VALUE MY LIFE. SO I'VE CUT IT
BACK DOWN TO ABOUT THREE
MINUTES. IS THAT OKAY? BERNIE,
OF COURSE, DESERVES EVERY MOMENT
OF RECOGNITION THAT WE'RE GOING
TO GIVE HER TODAY. EVEN EVEN IF
IT IS AGAINST HER OBJECTION. I
WANT BERNIE IN THIS BODY TO KNOW
THAT ON BEHALF OF THE REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS AND THE STAFF YOU HAVE
WORKED WITH OVER THE DECADES, WE
SINCERELY THANK YOU. WE
APPRECIATE YOU. WE HONOR YOU.
YOU ARE OFTEN PUT IN A SPOT TO
UMPIRE CALLING BALLS AND STRIKES
IN A ROWDY EXTRA INNINGS GAME.
AND I CAN SAY HONESTLY, FROM MY
SERVICE HERE IN THE SENATE AS A
MEMBER AND NOW AS LEADER, YOU'VE
ALWAYS BEEN FAIR. YOU'VE ALWAYS
BEEN CLEAR. YOU'VE NEVER LEFT
ANY AMBIGUITY, AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. WELL, NEITHER SIDE WILL
ALWAYS AGREE WITH THE CALL. WE
KNOW YOU MAKE THE CALLS AS YOU
SEE THEM IN THE FAIREST WAY
POSSIBLE, ALWAYS LOOKING TO
MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY OF THE
SENATE. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR WILLINGNESS, IN THE BUSIEST
OF TIMES, TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS OF ANYONE,
EVEN WHEN I COME UP TO YOU IN
THE MIDDLE OF YOU WRITING
SOMETHING DOWN, YOU'VE NOT
BARKED AT ME YET, AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. I WOULD HAVE
THOSE QUESTIONS COULD COME FROM
STAFFERS. GREEN KNOW IT ALL
LEGISLATORS GRUMPY SENIOR STAFF,
AND EVEN SOME LONGTIME SENATORS
LIKE MYSELF. THAT SHOULD KNOW
BETTER THAN TO INTERRUPT YOU.
YOU HAVE ALWAYS HANDLED THOSE
QUESTIONS WITH PATIENCE AND
PROFESSIONALISM. WHEN I TOOK
OVER AS LEADER, I'M PRIVILEGED
IN MY SERVICE AS LEADER THAT I
HAVE THREE PREVIOUS LEADERS IN
MY CAUCUS, AND ONE OF THE VERY
FIRST THINGS THEY ALL TOLD ME
WAS WHATEVER YOU DO, DO NOT
UPSET BERNIE. DO NOT GET IN
BERNIE'S WAY. DO NOT TRY TO
BREAK THE RULES. DO NOT STRETCH
THE RULES. DO NOT. AND I TOOK
ALL THOSE WARNINGS TO HAND, AND
I HAVE NEVER. AND I THINK ALL OF
THOSE WARNINGS WERE A LITTLE BIT
OVER PUBLICIZED, TO TELL YOU THE
TRUTH. I WANT A PARTICULAR POINT
OUT, HOW YOU'VE BUILT UP A SOLID
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
POLICY DIRECTOR, GREG MÀ, OVER
THE LAST 18 YEARS, AND THAT HAS
HELPED THE HOUSE FUNCTION WELL
AND EFFICIENTLY FOR ALL OF US
INVOLVED. WE CAN ALWAYS COUNT ON
YOU TO KNOW THE ANSWER. AND TO
BE FAIR. AND AS I SAID EARLIER,
WE ALL COULD GO ON AND ON ABOUT
YOUR PROFESSIONALISM BALANCED
WITH YOUR WELL-PLACED SNARK AS
BERNIE MIGHT SAY, LET'S MOVE IT
ALONG AND SUCK IT UP, BUTTERCUP.
I LIKE THAT SHE'S HAD TO SAY
THAT TO ME A COUPLE OF TIMES,
TOO. BERNIE, THANK YOU FROM THE
BOTTOM OF OUR HEART, ALL THE
REPUBLICANS AND ALL OF OUR STAFF
AND EVERYBODY THAT SERVES WITH
US. WE APPRECIATE YOU. WE LOVE
YOU. GOOD LUCK. GODSPEED. GOD'S
BLESSINGS. THANK YOU.
PETER JONES, THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU. WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE MADAM PRO
TEM EMERITUS TONY ATKINS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRO TEM. YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR SOME COMMON
THEMES HERE, WHICH MEANS IT ALL
MUST BE TRUE. BUT ISN'T IT
AMAZING HOW THE PEOPLE WHO
DESERVE THE RECOGNITION THE MOST
HATE IT THE MOST, BERNIE, WE'RE
SORRY. AND IN THE WORDS OF
YOUNGER PEOPLE, SORRY, NOT
SORRY. WHILE EVERY DAY THE
SENATE IS IN SESSION IS
IMPORTANT, EVERY DAY IS THERE
ARE A FEW DAYS THAT ARE REALLY
KIND OF SUPERCHARGED. HOUSE OF
ORIGIN DEADLINE. BUDGET
DEADLINE. LAST DAY OF SESSION.
WELL, HERE WE GO. IT IS ON THOSE
DAYS WHEN, AS PRO TEM AND AS A
SENATOR THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATED, CHIEF ASSISTANT
SECRETARY BERNADETTE MCNULTY, MY
MENTOR AND FRIEND, CHRIS KEHOE
SAID TO ME UPON MY FIRST DAY IN
THE SENATE, TRUST BERNIE. SHE
KNOWS EVERYTHING. AND AS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED, HER TIME. SHE
STARTED IN 1997 AS AN INTERN
WITH THE CHIEF CLERK AND HAS
RISEN THROUGH THE RANKS TO HER
CURRENT ROLE AS CHIEF ASSISTANT
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE. AS THE
RTE POINTED OUT 27 YEARS, YOU
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT SHE SERVED
FOR 28 YEARS IN THE AIR FORCE
RESERVES AND TO MY SEVEN
INCREDIBLE VETERAN COLLEAGUES,
WHAT AN INCREDIBLE SALUTE YOU
GAVE HER. THIS MORNING.
WONDERFUL BUT BERNIE KEPT US
MOVING DURING THE PANDEMIC
THROUGH THE CONSTRUCTION, WHICH
IS THANKFULLY QUIET TODAY AND ON
MANY, MANY LATE NIGHT DEADLINES
ON THE DAYS THAT WERE BUSIEST
WITH THE MOST AT STAKE, I WAS
ACTUALLY ABLE TO BE CALM, MOSTLY
BECAUSE BERNIE WAS AT THE HELM
AND THAT THAT MEANT EVERYTHING
TO ME, AND I KNEW IT WAS GOING
TO BE OKAY. OKAY, IT'S NO SECRET
THAT I'M A PRETTY BIG DOLLY FAN,
AS IS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD. I ALSO AM A PRETTY
BIG BERNIE FAN. IT MAKES SENSE.
DOLLY HAS AWARDS FOR BEING THE
BEST AND SO DOES BERNIE. DOLLY
TREATS EVERYONE THE SAME. AS THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER SAID WITH
FAIRNESS, KINDNESS, AND RESPECT,
AS DOES BERNIE. FOR BERNIE,
EVERYTHING IS ABOUT THE TEAM AND
SHE TREATS EVERYONE LIKE A
MEMBER OF THE TEAM, WHICH IS THE
OTHER REASON I THINK SHE
PROBABLY HATES THIS A LOT. SHE
GIVES IT TO THE TEAM. DOLLY
WEARS REALLY BIG WIGS AND A LOT
OF RHINESTONES. WELL BERNIE,
RETIREMENT IS A GREAT TIME TO
START. AMY. I'M GOING TO I'M
GOING TO LEAVE THAT IN YOUR
CAPABLE HANDS, I THINK A
RHINESTONE HAT AND SOME BOOTS,
AT ANY RATE, I CAN GO HAPPEN.
WELL, WE'LL SEE, WE'LL SEE.
RETIREMENT MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S LIVES.
AND I KNOW THAT THIS BODY IS.
SORRY TO SEE YOU GO, BUT WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
THAT YOU GET TO GO TO THE NEXT
PHASE AND TO DO SOME INCREDIBLE
THINGS AND SPEND SOME TIME WITH
YOUR SPOUSE AND FAMILY. AMY
RETIRED. I THINK IT WAS A YEAR
OR SO AGO, AND WE GOT TO STAND
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND
RECOGNIZE HER INCREDIBLE SERVICE.
TODAY, WE RECOGNIZE YOUR
INCREDIBLE SERVICE TO MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF DECADES. I KNOW THAT
NO ONE CAN COMPREHEND THE IMPACT
THAT YOU HAVE HAD ON THE LIVES
OF CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO COUNTRY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THIS
STATE.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO THE
SECRETARY OF SENATE, ERICA
CONTRERAS. THEN WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO GO BACK TO MADAM PRO TEM
EMERITUS SOME VERY SPECIAL
GIFTS. MADAM SECRETARY, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU.
BERNIE OH, GOD. INTERVENING
FIRST, I WANT TO SAY THAT I HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH THIS
PRESENTATION. THIS WAS THEM, ALL
OF THEM. AND I TOLD THEM, DON'T
DO IT. SHE HAS ABOUT SIX MORE
MONTHS LEFT. SHE'S GOING TO BE
MAD. AND OF COURSE, THEY DID NOT
LISTEN TO ME. ARE WE SURPRISED?
NO SECONDLY, I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I'M SO GLAD THEY DIDN'T
LISTEN. BECAUSE YOU DESERVE THIS
RECOGNITION AND SO MUCH MORE.
YOU KNOW, I'M JUST SO GRATEFUL
THAT I HAVE THE HONOR AND THE
PRIVILEGE TO BE ABLE TO BE THE
ONE TO SAY THANK YOU, BERNIE, ON
BEHALF OF OUR SENATE DESK TEAM,
WHO IS HERE ON THE FLOOR TODAY
AND THOSE WORKING BEHIND THE
SCENES AND ENGROSSING AND
ENROLLING SENATE-TV SENATE FLOOR
ANALYSIS, ALL THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY STAFF, FELLOWS, INTERNS
WHO YOU HAVE MANAGED, TRAINED,
SCOLDED, COUNSELED AFTER MISSING
DEADLINES, ESPECIALLY AFTER THIS
WEEK, MENTORED, GUIDED AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY LIFTED. WE SAY THANK
YOU. YOU ARRIVED AT THE CAPITOL,
A TRANSPLANT FROM NEW YORK WITH
UNIQUE MILITARY EXPERIENCE. YOU
WERE A YOUNG WOMAN LOOKING FOR A
NEW HOME, A STRONG, SMART WOMAN
WITH INCREDIBLE WORK ETHIC,
DISCIPLINE AND A CURIOSITY FOR
YOUR GOVERNMENT. WHEN YOU
DECIDED TO COME WORK FOR THE
SENATE, YOU GAVE ALL OF US A
GIFT NOT JUST BECAUSE OF YOUR
PUBLIC SERVICE, BUT THROUGH YOUR
DISPLAYS OF INTEGRITY, KINDNESS,
PATIENCE, HUMOR AND RESPECT AND
LOVE FOR THE SENATE. YOU HAVE
OPENLY SHARED YOUR KNOWLEDGE AND
WISDOM WITH SO MANY OF US WHO
GREW UP IN THIS BUILDING.
SOMETIMES INTIMIDATED BY THE
PEOPLE, THE PROCESS AND THE
RULES. BUT THROUGH YOUR
INVESTMENT IN OUR STAFF, YOU
HAVE LEFT YOUR MARK AND A
LASTING LEGACY. PERSONALLY, I AM
GRATEFUL FOR THE DIRECT SUPPORT
YOU HAVE PROVIDED ME, INCLUDING
DURING SOME VERY DIFFICULT
MOMENTS OF CRISIS. I COULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO CARRY THIS
BODY WITHOUT YOUR BRILLIANCE AND
YOUR BACKING. WHEN I BECAME
SECRETARY, YOU OWED ME NOTHING
AND YET YOU GAVE ME YOUR
LOYALTY, YOUR HARD WORK AND YOUR
BEST ADVICE. I AM PROUD OF YOU,
MY FRIEND, AND ALL YOU HAVE
ACHIEVED IN YOUR PERSONAL LIFE
AND YOUR AMAZING PROFESSIONAL
CAREER. CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU
AND AMY. CONGRATULATIONS,
BERNIE, I LOVE YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THE SENATE
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT BERNIE MCNULTY WITH SOME
SPECIAL RECOGNITIONS. FIRST AND
FOREMOST, WE HAVE A BEAUTIFUL
PHOTO OF THE CAPITOL THAT IS
SIGNED BY EVERY MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. AND WE
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THIS
AUGUST BODY FOR CELEBRATING
TODAY. AS BERNIE MCNULTY DAY IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. WE
HAVE THE CERTIFICATE TO PROVE
IT. CAN WE PLEASE GIVE A ROUND
OF APPLAUSE FOR BERNIE MCNULTY?
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE PHOTOS IN
JUST A MOMENT, BUT WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO ASK BERNIE TO PLEASE
COME FORWARD FOR ONE LAST
RECOGNITION. SO BERNIE IS A
BASEBALL FAN AND SHE LOVES THE
YANKEES. AND SHE IS PRETTY DANG
EXCITED THAT WE WILL FORGIVE HER
FOR THAT, BUT WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU. WE ARE PROVIDING HER
WITH AN OUR LADY OF GUADALUPE
CANDLE WITH HER FACE ON IT THAT
SHE WILL BE ABLE TO LIGHT FOR
THE YANKEES THIS YEAR. SO WE ARE
GOING TO PRESENT THAT WITH YOU.
WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
MAJORITY LEADER FOR PROVIDING
THIS. AND LOOK AT THAT PHOTO.
EVERYBODY MY GOODNESS. WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THAT RIGHT THERE
FOR A MOMENT. HOT SHE JUST SWORE
ALL RIGHT, WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
BERNIE MCNULTY IS THE GREATEST
OF ALL TIME, WHICH IS WHY TODAY
IS BERNIE MCNULTY DAY IN THE
SENATE. AND WE HAVE ALSO
PROVIDED BERNIE WITH AN OFFICIAL
SASH THAT SAYS GOAT OF THE
SENATE. CAN WE PLEASE GIVE HER A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE? YOU HAVE TO
WEAR IT ONCE. HERE YOU GO.
THIS IS A WELL-OILED MACHINE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, LOOK AT
THIS. WE'RE GOING TO PUT ON THE
GOAT. NOW, THE LAST ITEM IS,
SENATOR ASHBY AND MAYOR
STEINBERG HAS BEEN BUSY. BUSY
TRYING TO GET THE OAKLAND A'S TO
COME TO SACRAMENTO. AND HERE'S
THE GOOD NEWS. THE OAKLAND A'S
ARE PLAYING IN SACRAMENTO. SO WE
HAVE FOUR TICKETS, FOUR TICKETS
DIRECTLY BEHIND HOME PLATE. WE
ARE CALLING BERNIE'S BASEBALL
RETIREMENT EXTRAVAGANZA. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN, LET'S GO YANKEES.
WE ARE PROUD AS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE TO DO A FAMILY FOUR
PACK. CAN I GET A LET'S GO
BERNIE? I SAID, CAN I GET A
LET'S GO, BERNIE, ONE MORE TIME.
CAN I GET A LET'S GO, BERNIE,
ONE MORE ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR
THE ONE, THE ONLY BERNADETTE
MCNULTY.
WE WANT TO INVITE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE TO JOIN THE PHOTOGRAPH.
RIGHT, RIGHT. YEAH.
THERE WE GO. THAT'S RIGHT. HEY.
AND NOW WE GO. HERE WE GO. WE
HAVE. RIGHT HERE. WE HAVE.
CHIRLA. THIS IS. MAN. HOLD ON,
HOLD ON, HOLD ON. READY TWO.
THREE. RIGHT. ONE MORE. THREE.
ONE. YOU ARE 30S 33.
30. NOT BAD. AT THE DESK. STAFF,
PLEASE COME UP FORWARD THE DESK
STAFF. COME ON. FORWARD. COME
ON. FORWARD. COME ON, COME ON.
YEAH YEAH.
RIGHT OKAY. YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE
OVER. ALL RIGHT. NICE JOB. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. VERY NICE. NICE.
WELL DESERVED.
SO NOW. WHO.
ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS AS THE
PRESIDING OFFICER, I'M GOING TO
CALL THAT UNAUTHORIZED CEREMONY
OUT OF ORDER. AND WE WILL BEGIN
AGAIN. ALL RIGHT.
CONGRATULATIONS IT'S GOING TO BE
HARD TO TOP THAT TODAY, BUT WE
HAVE A FEW SPICY BILLS THAT WILL
MAKE AN EFFORT. MEMBERS, IF YOU
COULD RETURN TO YOUR DESKS. SO
WE COULD BEGIN OUR FORMAL PART
OF OUR OUR WORK TODAY, WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR. THERE ARE NONE.
FURTHER MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL ALSO BE DEEMED
READ. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW NEXT TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING FILE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2032.
MEMBERS, WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN
AGAIN OUR SESSION. WE'D LIKE TO
INVITE MEMBERS TO COME BACK TO
THEIR DESKS. PLEASE MEMBERS,
PLEASE COME BACK TO YOUR DESKS.
MEMBERS, WE ARE GOING TO ASK
THAT YOU REMAIN HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS FOR THE DURATION OF THE
DAY. IF YOU HAVE A REASON TO
MOVE TO GO TO THE ASSEMBLY AS
ONE EXAMPLE OR OTHER URGENT
MATTER TO, PLEASE CHECK WITH THE
MAJORITY LEADER BEFORE YOU LEAVE
THE CHAMBERS. IF FOR SOME REASON
YOU'VE LEFT THE CHAMBERS AND
HAVEN'T DONE THAT, WE WILL NOT
HOLD A ROLL OPEN FOR YOU. SO
KEEP THAT IN MIND AND PLEASE
WORK WITH THE MAJORITY LEADER IN
ADVANCE ON ON TIMES IN WHICH YOU
THINK YOU MAY HAVE TO LEAVE THE
FLOOR. OKAY, I'M GOING TO TRY TO
GIVE YOU A HEADS UP ON BILLS
THAT ARE COMING UP BECAUSE WE
ARE GOING TO JUMP AROUND A
LITTLE BIT. SO LOOKING AHEAD
TODAY, THESE ARE THE FIVE ITEMS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO. WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
36. WE MIGHT EVEN GET A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL THAT WE CAN
UTILIZE THERE. WE'LL SEE. WE'RE
GOING TO GO FROM THERE TO FILE
ITEM 4041 4344 AND 45. SO THAT'S
THE LINEUP THAT WE WILL BEGIN
WITH SEEING. NO MICROPHONES UP.
WE WILL START WITH FILE ITEM 36.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2745.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2745 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHES. AN ACT RELATING TO PEST.
SENATOR JOLLY GOOD AFTERNOON,
MR. PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS, I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB 2745 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS. THIS BILL WAS DRAFTED TO
PROTECT ALL AGRICULTURE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING
THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO IMPLEMENT
SUSTAINABLE, INTEGRATIVE,
REGENERATIVE OR ORGANIC
PRACTICES FROM THOSE WHO
NEGLIGENTLY, NEGLIGENTLY
THREATEN THEIR LIVELIHOOD. THIS
BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE A COUNTY
COMMISSIONER TO LEVY A CIVIL
PENALTY AGAINST A PERSON WHO
MAINTAINS A PREMISE, PLANT, OR
CONVEYANCE THAT IS INFESTED WITH
A PEST THAT IS DETERMINED TO BE
A PUBLIC NUISANCE. THE PENALTY
UNDER THIS BILL WOULD BE UP TO
$500 PER ACRE TO BE IN
VIOLATION. IF THAT PERSON TAKES
ANY GOOD FAITH ACTIONS TO BEGIN
TO RECTIFY THE PROBLEM WITHIN 15
DAYS OF RECEIVING THE NOTICE,
THE CIVIL PENALTY IS DROPPED.
GOOD FAITH ACTION IS LEFT
UNDEFINED TO ALLOW THE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY FOR FARMERS WHEN
SOLVING THESE PROBLEMS. RECENT
LAW AMENDMENTS TAKEN BY THE
AUTHOR CAME AT THE REQUEST OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE, AND ADDRESS A
CONFLICT WITH EXISTING
REGULATIONS AS WELL AS THE AS
BARRIERS TO ENFORCEABILITY.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT
STAFF, THE RECENTLY REMOVED
SECTION WOULD CONFUSE THE
EXISTING AUTHORITY AND THE
PROCESS FOR DEFINING PEST RATHER
THAN PROTECT WELL-INTENTIONED
FARMERS FROM UNNECESSARY ACTIONS
IN ADDITION, IT ALSO NOTED WAS
ALSO NOTED BY THE DEPARTMENT
THAT THE REMOVAL SECTION SEEMS
TO BE TRYING TO SOLVE A PROBLEM
THAT DOES NOT EXIST AND DOES NOT
ACTUALLY HAVE REAL WORLD
IMPACTS. THE AUTHOR OF THE
MEASURE HAS ALSO SUBMITTED A
LETTER OF THE LEGISLATURE INTENT
TO THE JOURNAL, WHICH CLARIFIES
THE UNDER. UNDER THIS MEASURE,
FARMERS WILL CONTINUE TO BE ABLE
TO RUN THEIR OPERATIONS AND
ADDRESS PEST INFESTATIONS IN THE
WAY THEY SEE FIT. AB 2745 HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND TO THIS
DATE, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DALY. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLEY AYE. DODD
DURAZO. EGGMAN DODD. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. LEMON
MCGUIRE. NO MIN. NEWMAN NGUYEN.
AYE. MILO AYE. JACOBO. AYE
PADILLA. PORTANTINO AYE. BROTH.
AYE RUBIO. AYE. SATO AYE.
SKINNER NO. SMALL CUEVAS. STERN
UMBERG. WAHAB NÓ. WIENER AYE.
WILK WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE. I GO
THROUGH THE ROLL. ONE MORE TIME.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN, I DON'T
KNOW, BLAKE. SPEAR BARRASSO.
EGGMAN GONZALEZ. JONES AYE.
LAIRD LIMON. MCGUIRE MEN. NEWMAN
PADILLA. SMALL. CUEVAS STERN.
UMBERG ON A VOTE OF 23 TO 4, THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 40. Þ. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 37 MEMBERS, THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 922. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 922
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS. AN ACT
RELATED AND NUTRITION ASSISTANCE.
SENATOR WAHAB IS THE FLOOR
MANAGER OF THAT MEASURE. SENATOR
WAHAB. THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS, I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 922, WHICH ENCOURAGES
INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITY BASED
RESTAURANTS WHILE FEEDING OUR
UNHOUSED PERSONS AND CREATING
PATHWAYS TO NEEDED SOCIAL
SERVICES. ALAMEDA SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTED AN 18 MONTH, $131
MILLION PROGRAM USING AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACT FUNDS. THE
PROGRAM PROVIDED 5 MILLION
PREPARED MEALS FROM LOCAL
RESTAURANTS ONCE FUNDED. AB 922
WILL CONTINUE THIS PROGRAM THAT
CREATES PROSPERITY FOR LOCAL
ECONOMIES AND TAKE ACTION IN
EXTREME HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
THROUGH AB 922. WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO DRIVE DOLLARS TO THE
MORE THAN 130 LOCAL RESTAURANTS
THAT PROVIDED MEALS, 47% OF
THOSE RESTAURANTS WERE OWNED BY
BLACK, INDIGENOUS AND OTHER
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND OR WOMEN BY
PASSING AB 922, YOU WILL
SIMULTANEOUSLY FEED THOSE IN
NEED AND SUPPORT ECONOMIC
STABILITY AND CREATE A MODEL
PROGRAM FOR THE STATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR WAHAB, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON A OVERALL TÌM
NÓ ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER. BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DELI.
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HURTADO I
JONES. NØ. LAIRD I LOWMAN I
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MAN I NEWMAN
I NGUYEN. NØ. NILO NO COBO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO. NO SKINNER I SMALL
CUEVAS I STERN, I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK KNOW PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SHAKESPEARE
DAWLEY, NØ GROVE. MCGUIRE OKOBO.
NO ON A VOTE OF 29 TO 8, THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 40. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
1836. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1836 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN. AN ACT
RELATING TO INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY. SENATOR ASHBY. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 1836 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN. AB
1836 WILL REQUIRE AN ESTATES
CONSENT TO CREATE A CONVINCING
DIGITAL REPLICA OF A DECEASED
PERFORMER IN CASES NOT COVERED
BY THE FIRST AMENDMENT. UNDER
CURRENT LAW, IMAGES AND VIDEOS
OF DECEASED PERFORMERS CAN BE
USED WITHOUT CONSENT IN A BROAD
RANGE OF CREATIVE WORKS, WITHOUT
THEIR FAMILY HAVING ANY INPUT OR
RECEIVING COMPENSATION. THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW THE FAMILIES AND
ESTATES OF DECEASED ARTISTS THE
RIGHT TO PROTECT THE LIKENESS
AND ART OF THEIR LOVED ONES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR ASHBY.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY SENATOR WANT TO BE HEARD ON
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON A BILL.
ARCHULETTA HI, ASHBY. HI HI,
ATKINS. HI, BECKER. HI. HI,
BLAKE. SPEER. HI, BRADFORD. HI,
CABALLERO. HI CORTEZ. HI. DAILY
AT 43 NØ DODD. HI DURAZZO. AYE,
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD AYE. LEMON
AYE. MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN.
AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO
AYE. OKOBO PADILLA. HI.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO SKINNER. AYE. A
SMALL CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO MCGUIRE.
OKOBO.
SEYARTO AYES 32. NOES FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 48. MEMBERS 48, THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 3138. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3138
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON AND
ACT RELATING TO VEHICLES.
SENATOR CORTESE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB 3138 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYWOMAN WILSON. THIS BILL
MODIFIES THE EXISTING
ALTERNATIVE DIGITAL LICENSE
PLATE PROGRAM TO ALLOW DRIVERS
TO CHOOSE IF THEY WOULD LIKE THE
DIGITAL LICENSE PLATE TO INCLUDE
GPS. AGAIN, THAT'S AN OPT IN.
CURRENT LAW ALREADY ALLOWS
CONSUMERS TO CHOOSE TO PURCHASE
A DIGITAL LICENSE PLATE, SO THIS
JUST MODIFIES THE OPT IN ON THE
GPS. BUT THE BILL ALSO PUTS IN
PLACE PRIVACY STANDARDS FOR THE
GPS PLATES THAT FAR EXCEED
PROTECTIONS IN CURRENT LAW. FOR
OTHER COMPARABLE GPS EQUIPPED
DEVICES. WHILE GPS, LIKE OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES, HAS THE ABILITY TO
BE ABUSED. THE APPROPRIATE
POLICY RESPONSE IS TO PUT
GUARDRAILS IN PLACE, JUST LIKE
WE'VE DONE IN THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL, THIS
BILL SOLVES A PROBLEM THAT
PROBABLY DOESN'T EXIST. AND THE
SIMPLE QUESTION, WHAT'S WRONG
WITH OUR EXISTING LICENSE
PLATES? SO WHAT'S THE BENEFIT OF
A DIGITAL LICENSE PLATE IN
CALIFORNIA, NOT REALLY CLEAR.
OTHER THAN CUSTOMIZATION. ONE OF
THE VERY CLEAR PROHIBITIONS IN
THE USE OF THIS TECHNOLOGY WAS
TO NOT ALLOW FOR CERTAIN PARTS
OF LICENSE PLATES TO BE
CUSTOMIZED. AND YET, THIS
COMPANY, OVER TIME, HAS
CONTINUALLY, CONTINUALLY ALLOWED
USERS TO CUSTOMIZE THEIR PLATES
IN WAYS THAT I THINK WE'D ALL
FIND OFFENSIVE, IN WHICH THE DMV
AND CHP FIND PROBLEMATIC, AND
THAT INCLUDES THAT BOTTOM OF THE
PLATE WHERE WE ALL SEE DMV
CA.GOV THIS TECHNOLOGY ALLOWS
YOU TO REINSERT SOMETHING OF
YOUR CHOICE THERE. AND ALTHOUGH
THE COMPANY HAS BEEN WARNED
MULTIPLE TIMES, THE TECHNOLOGY
STILL EXISTS TO DO THAT. THEY
HAVE ALSO BEEN WARNED IN MANY
WAYS THAT THAT THERE ARE
PROBLEMS RELATED TO THE LOCATION
REPORTING OF THE DEVICES. THOSE
PROBLEMS HAVE NOT ONLY BEEN NOT
SOLVED IN CALIFORNIA, THEY
RECENTLY LOST THEIR RIGHT TO
DISTRIBUTE THESE PLATES IN THE
STATE OF MICHIGAN FOR PRECISELY
THESE REASONS. AND THERE SHOULD
BE REAL CONCERN ON THE PART OF
THIS BODY ABOUT THE PRIVACY AND
THE PROTECTIONS AFFORDED TO
USERS OF THESE PLATES.
SPECIFICALLY, WHAT IF YOU ARE
INVOLVED IN A RELATIONSHIP AND
YOU'RE THE SUBJECT OF DOMESTIC
ABUSE, THE VERY LICENSE PLATE ON
YOUR CAR COULD BE USED BY THE
ABUSER TO TRACK YOU DOWN. IN
JANUARY 2023, RESEARCH REVEALED
THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO HACK INTO
THIS CUSTOMER'S. THIS COMPANY'S
SYSTEMS AND GAIN FULL
ADMINISTRATIVE CONTROL WITH THE
ABILITY TO ACCESS LOCATIONS OF
EACH AND EVERY REVIVER PLATE AND
EVEN THE ABILITY TO CHANGE WHAT
WAS DISPLAYED ON THE LICENSE
PLATE ITSELF, ACCORDING TO A DMV
REPORT. A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO,
THE CHP DETERMINED THAT THE
PLATES DID NOT ADEQUATELY MEET
CHP VISIBILITY, REFLECTIVITY,
AND ILLUMINATION REQUIREMENTS.
AND AGAIN, IN MICHIGAN, THEY'VE
LOST THE CONTRACT FOR THE
VIOLATIONS THAT I'VE DISCUSSED.
AND SO THIS IS NOT A SOLUTION
THAT WE NEED TO ENDORSE. NOR
DOES THIS LEGISLATION BENEFIT
ANYTHING OTHER THAN A SINGLE
COMPANY. I URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR NEWMAN, SENATOR
JONES. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB 3138 AND
IN RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE
PREVIOUS POINTS THIS AUGUST,
BODY OFTEN PASSES LEGISLATION
THAT HURTS OR HELPS A SINGLE
COMPANY. I DON'T FIND THAT
ARGUMENT TO BE RELEVANT IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE, BUT TO THE
POINT OF THE BILL ITSELF AND THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP
ON PRIVACY AND TRACKING AND GPS
AND ALL OF THAT, THERE'S THE
BOTTOM LINE IS IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
THIS IS AN OPT IN SERVICE. THIS
IS AN OPT IN DEVICE. YOU HAVE TO
PAY TO USE THIS DEVICE AND HAVE
IT PUT ON YOUR CAR. NOW THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S IN THIS CAR IS
ACTUALLY VERY INTERESTING TO ME,
AND I WAS INTERESTED IN WHEN I
BOUGHT A NEW VEHICLE, A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO OF OPTING IN TO
THIS SERVICE AND THIS DEVICE.
BUT GUESS WHAT? IT COSTS A LOT
OF MONEY, SO I WASN'T THAT
INTERESTED. AFTER I REALIZED HOW
MUCH IT COST, I THINK THAT THE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED UP IN
THE PREVIOUS PRESENTATION IN
OPPOSITION CAN BE TOTALLY ARGUED
AWAY BY KNOWING THAT FOR
SOMEBODY TO PUT THIS ON THEIR
CAR, THEY HAVE TO CHOOSE TO HAVE
IT ON. THEY HAVE TO OPT INTO THE
SERVICE AND THEY HAVE TO PAY TO
GET IT. I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
3138. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR JONES, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION, MEMBERS, ANY
FURTHER DEBATE? SEEING NONE.
SENATOR CORTEZ, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, I
CERTAINLY RESPECT THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM FULLERTON
AROUND THE NEED FOR PLATES IN
GENERAL. AND OF COURSE, PRIVACY
CONCERNS, THE LAW ALREADY ALLOWS
THE LICENSE PLATES THEMSELVES.
THE DIGITAL PLATES. THE ONLY
QUESTION THIS BILL WAS TRYING TO
ADDRESS IS HOW TO HANDLE THE GPS
PIECE OF IT. IT'S BEEN WORKED
OVER VERY THOROUGHLY BY
COMMITTEES IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE AND THE DMV ITSELF
HAS REASSURED US THAT THEY ARE
NOT CONTENT BASED ISSUES. AND
IT'S CERTAINLY, AS ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES JUST STATED, AN OPT
IN. SO I'D RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE I'LL BE HAVING CITY
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN A GILL A ARCHULETA A ASHBY
I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER,
BRADFORD CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLEY I DODD I DURAZZO. EGGMAN
GLASER. GONZALEZ I GROVE. OTERO.
JONES I LAIRD I LIMÓN I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR MIN I NEWMAN. NØ NGUYEN
I MILO I TURBO I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO NÓ
CIERTO I SKINNER A SMALL CUEVAS
STERN UMBERG I WAHAB. WIENER
WILK NØ. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. BLAKE
SPEER. BRADFORD I DURAZO EGGMAN.
GLASER GROVE. OTERO NO. MCGUIRE.
I MENJIVAR. NO SMALL. CUEVAS
STERN. WAHAB. NO WIENER. NO ON A
VOTE OF 26 TO 7, THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 43.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2107.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2107 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHINN. AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALING ARTS. SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS
WILL BE MY LAST BILL ON
PRESENTING ON THE FLOOR. AND
IT'S A BILL OF GREAT WEIGHT. SO
I'M VERY HONORED TO BE DOING
THIS. AB 2107 ALLOWS
PATHOLOGISTS TO REVIEW DIGITAL
DATA, RESULTS AND IMAGES FROM A
REMOTE LOCATION IN ORDER TO
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY OF
DIAGNOSIS. WITH THIS
AUTHORIZATION, PATHOLOGISTS WILL
BE LIMITED TO VIEWING THESE
MATERIALS IN A PHYSICAL LICENSED
LABORATORY. EVEN THOUGH NO
LABORATORY EQUIPMENT IS NEEDED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR WILK.
ANY DISCUSSION, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ON A BILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY. AYE. DODD AYE. DARAZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. I AM IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE. AYE
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
SEYARTO. AYE SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE. ON A VOTE
OF 40 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WILK, FOR
YOUR SERVICE AS YOU PRESENT YOUR
LAST BILL TO THE SENATE. WE'RE
MOVING NEXT TO FILE ITEM 44.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2729.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2729 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOE
PATTERSON, AN ACT RELATING TO
LAND USE. SENATOR WIENER I THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2729 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOE PATTERSON.
ASSEMBLY. ASSEMBLY. MEMBER
PATTERSON AND I HAVE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY ALL YEAR ON OUR
COMPLEMENTARY PIECES OF
LEGISLATION THAT USED TO
OVERLAP. WE'VE MADE THEM
COMPLEMENTARY AROUND HOUSING IN
RESPONSE TO THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS, PRIMARY OPPOSITION
HAS GONE NEUTRAL. THE BILL
EXTENDS ENTITLEMENTS AND PERMITS
ON HOUSING PROJECTS THAT WERE
APPROVED BEFORE JANUARY 1ST OF
THIS YEAR, BUT EXPIRE BEFORE THE
END OF NEXT YEAR, AND TOLLS
THOSE APPROVALS DURING ANY
CYCLE. CHALLENGES. WE'RE IN A
VERY HIGH INTEREST RATE
ENVIRONMENT RIGHT NOW, AND THERE
ARE APPROVED PROJECTS THAT ARE
FROZEN BECAUSE OF THOSE HIGH
INTEREST RATES. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE PERMITS WILL
CONTINUE SO THAT AS INTEREST
RATES, I PRAY, COME DOWN, THE
PROJECTS CAN GET BUILT. THIS IS
A GOOD BILL. IT DESERVES YOUR
SUPPORT. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR WIENER, ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON BY BILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DAWLEY AYE. DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO. I. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN NEWMAN. AYE. WAYNE AYE.
NILO AYE. OKUBO. AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER AYES.
MOORLACH. RIVAS. EYES TURN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. NÓ WIENER.
AYE. WILK AYE. HURTADO. I DON'T
KNOW, PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. JONES AYE. MCGUIRE MEN.
AYE. PORTANTINO. A VOTE OF 36 TO
2. THE MEASURE PASSES. YOU'RE
NEXT GOING TO FILE ITEM 45. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2803.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2803 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VALENCIA. AN ACT RELATING TO THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF 1974.
SENATOR MENGIBAR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AB 2803 RESTRICTS THE
USE OF CAMPAIGN FUNDS FOR LEGAL
DEFENSE WHEN CANDIDATES AND
ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE CONVICTED
OF PUBLIC CRIME OR FRAUD. IF A
CANDIDATE OR ELECTED OFFICIAL
WHO USES CAMPAIGN FUNDS IN
DEFENSE OF THESE CHARGES IS
FOUND GUILTY AND IS CONVICTED,
THEY MUST REIMBURSE THE CAMPAIGN
ACCOUNT ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION. THIS IS
A 27 VOTE BILL. IT IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NO OBJECTION. AYES 39. NØ ZERO.
THE ON THE URGENCY AND ON THE
MEASURE. CRLA. IT'S A PR. EXCUSE
ME. NOT ON THE URGENCY. ON THE
MEASURE ITSELF. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 47. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1893.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1893 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS. AN ACT RELATING TO LAND
USE. SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1893 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS.
AB 1893 MODERNIZES THE BUILDER'S
REMEDY THAT ASPECT OF STATUTE TO
PROVIDE CLARITY AND GUARDRAILS
TO EXISTING LAW. BUILDER'S
REMEDY IS APPLIED WHEN A
LOCALITY'S HOUSING ELEMENT HAS
NOT BEEN CERTIFIED BY HCD.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE CURRENT LAW
IS UNCLEAR. SOME INTERPRET IT TO
SAY THAT BUILDER'S REMEDY ALLOWS
DEVELOPERS TO BUILD ANYTHING
THEY WANT ANYWHERE. SOME
INTERPRET IT TO THAT IT PROVIDES
NO BENEFIT TO DEVELOPERS AT ALL,
WHICH CAN'T BOTH CAN'T BE TRUE.
CORRECT? WHAT AB 1893 DOES IS
ENSURE THAT BUILDER'S REMEDY IS
A REAL TOOL, BUT IT SETS
GUARDRAILS ON THE SIZE AND
LOCATION OF THE HOUSING PROJECTS
THAT CAN BE BUILT UNDER
BUILDER'S REMEDY. SO THE GOAL IS
NOT TO PENALIZE THE RESIDENTS IN
CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT IGNORE
STATE HOUSING LAW, BUT RATHER TO
MOTIVATE OUR JURISDICTIONS TO
FOLLOW THE LAW AND TO GET THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENTS CERTIFIED, AND
TO NOT JUST GIVE DEVELOPERS ANY
PASS, BUT RATHER TO CLARIFY
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS THEIR RIGHT
UNDER BUILDER'S REMEDY. AND WITH
THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR SKINNER.
SENATOR DURAZZO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I SHARE THE GOAL OF
GETTING MORE CALIFORNIANS INTO
HOMES THEY CAN AFFORD. AT THE
HEART OF THIS BILL IS A GOOD
CONCEPT. UNFORTUNATELY, I CAN'T
SUPPORT THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT
FORM, WHICH CAME BEFORE MY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. THE BILL'S
NEW DEFINITION OF DISAPPROVE
WILL LIMIT COMMUNITY INPUT AND
THE ABILITY TO ADDRESS CRITICAL
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES. WE
ALREADY HAVE MANY REQUIREMENTS
ON LOCAL AGENCIES TO APPROVE
PROJECTS QUICKLY. THE LAW IS
ALREADY CLEAR THAT LOCAL
AGENCIES NEED TO MEET TIMEFRAMES
FOR APPROVAL OF PROJECTS, AND
CAN'T HOLD MORE THAN FIVE
HEARINGS IN AN APPLICATION, THE
LEGISLATURE WORKED HARD OVER TWO
YEARS TO MAKE SURE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE QUICKLY
APPROVING CEQA DOCUMENTS AND
EXEMPTIONS FOR HOUSING PROJECTS
THAT FURTHER OUR STATE GOALS AND
DON'T HAVE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS.
I'M NOT COMFORTABLE WITH THE WAY
THE BILL OVERRIDES LOCAL
OBJECTIVE STANDARDS, WHICH CAN
INCLUDE MITIGATION MEASURES FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE, FLOOD HAZARDS,
TRANSPORTATION IMPACTS AND OTHER
IMPACTS FROM DEVELOPMENT. IN
MANY CASES, WE IN THIS BUILDING
HAVE TOLD LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
WORK HARD ON ADDRESSING THOSE
ISSUES. THIS BILL WOULD PREVENT
LOCAL AGENCIES FROM IMPOSING
THOSE REQUIREMENTS IF IT WOULD
CHANGE THE PROJECT THAT THE
DEVELOPER PROPOSED. FINALLY,
THIS BILL LOWERS AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS TO QUALIFY FOR THE
BUILDER'S REMEDY AND SETS A
CONCERNING PRECEDENT FOR
OVERRIDING LOCAL AFFORDABLE
HOUSING REQUIREMENTS. OUR
GREATEST NEED IN THIS STATE IS
HOUSING FOR THE LOWEST INCOME
INDIVIDUALS, AND THE BUILDER'S
REMEDY WAS WRITTEN SO THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COULD GET
BUILT EVEN IF THE LOCAL ZONING
DIDN'T ALLOW IT. UNFORTUNATELY,
THIS BILL SHIFTS THAT FOCUS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DURAZZO. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION,
MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE. SENATOR SKINNER,
YOU MAY CLOSE, I WOULD REMIND
MEMBERS THAT BUILDER'S REMEDY IS
ALREADY IN CURRENT STATUTE. AND
THIS ADDS CLARIFICATION,
INCLUDING THINGS LIKE HEIGHT
LIMITS, I THINK THE BILL STRIKES
THE RIGHT BALANCE. IT'S
SUPPORTED BY A DIVERSE COALITION
OF SOLUTIONS ORIENTED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT REPRESENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS,
MARKET RATE HOUSING DEVELOPERS,
AND HOUSING ADVOCATES. AND WITH
THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. ALL
DEBATE HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO, GILL. ARCHULETA ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. AYE.
DODD AYE. DARAZO. NO EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
AYE OR DATO? AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. AYE. OKOBO
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH.
BY RUBIO. SEYARTO SKINNER. A
SMALL CUEVAS. STERN. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB WIENER. AYE. WILK. NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA
BECKER. BRADFORD. AYE GLAZER.
AYE. AYE MCGUIRE. NGUYEN OKOBO.
PORTANTINO NO. RUBIO. AYE. SATO.
NO SMALL. CUEVAS STERN. WAHAB.
ON A VOTE OF 26 IN FAVOR. FOUR
AGAINST. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 52. ITEM
52. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2716.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2716 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRYANT AND ACT RELATING TO OIL
AND GAS. SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SENATORS, PLEASE GIVE
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS YOUR
ATTENTION. PLEASE SENATOR, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2716 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN, A BILL
THAT WILL HOLD LOW PRODUCING OIL
WELLS IN THE BALDWIN HILLS
INGLEWOOD OIL FIELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR HARM TO SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES. THE INGLEWOOD OIL
FIELD IS THE LARGEST URBAN OIL
FIELD IN THE COUNTRY, AND THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES, CITY OF
LOS ANGELES AND CULVER CITY HAVE
ALL INITIATED EFFORTS TO STOP
THE HARMS COMING FROM IT. THE
OPERATORS OF THE FIELD
THEMSELVES HAVE INDICATED A
DESIRE TO SHIFT AWAY FROM
MARGINAL PRODUCTION TO MAKE
BETTER USE OF THEIR LAND. THE
DISTRICT BILL IS THE APPROPRIATE
MEASURE TO HELP BEGIN THE
TRANSITION. IT WAS WRITTEN BY
THE FRONT LINE COMMUNITIES THAT
WE REPRESENT, AND IT IS EXACTLY
THE KIND OF PEOPLE CENTERED
POLICY WORK THAT RESIDENTS OF
SOUTH LA DESERVE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ALVARADO. GILL. NO ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS, I BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER I BRADFORD. CABALLERO I
CORTEZ. I DALLEY. NÓ. DODD
DURAZO I EGGMAN. GLASER I
GONZALEZ I. GROVE NO. HURTADO.
NO. JONES. I LAIRD I LIMON I
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NO. NILO NO COBO. NO
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO. SEYARTO NO SKINNER I
SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I
WAHAB, I WIENER. I WILK I JONES
I TO NO. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER I
BRADFORD I DODD. EGGMAN I
MCGUIRE. NEWMAN RUBIO I. ON A
VOTE OF 28 TO 9, THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 58. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 1042. FILE ITEM
58. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1042 BY SOME
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN AN ACT
RELATING TO AGRICULTURE. SENATOR
ALLEN, THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I'M HAPPY TO
PRESENT AB 1042 TODAY ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR BAUER-KAHAN.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA TREATED
SEEDS. THEIR LABELS IDENTIFY THE
PESTICIDE TREATMENT USED. THEY
DON'T INCLUDE THE CONCENTRATION
AMOUNT OF EACH TREATMENT. THIS
MAKES A SIMPLE LABEL CHANGE
REQUIRING TREATED LABEL LABELS
FOR SEEDS TO ADDITIONALLY
INCLUDE THE AMOUNT OF PESTICIDE
APPLIED TO THE SEEDS. THIS IS
ABOUT INCREASING TRANSPARENCY.
IT WILL HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT OF THESE
PESTICIDES ON HUMAN HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT. I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS BILL,
THAT SHE'S TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION, CREATE A
SELL THROUGH POLICY FOR SEEDS
PACKAGED BEFORE 2027, AND ONLY
APPLY TO THE BILL TO SEEDS
PLANTED IN CALIFORNIA. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. MEMBERS. ANYONE WANT TO BE
HEARD ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
SENATOR WANT TO BE HEARD ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NO MICROPHONES
UP. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I GILL NO. ARCHULETA
I ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I
BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY NÓ
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE NO DOTTO I
JONES NO. LAIRD I LEMON. I
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN
I NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO COBO. NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO, I SATO. NO. SKINNER I
SMALL. CUEVAS STERN I UMBERG.
WAHAB. SMALL. CUEVAS I UMBERG.
WAHAB WIENER. WAHAB I WIENER I
WILK. I. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MCGUIRE. ON A VOTE OF
31 TO 8, THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 59.
SENATOR JONES IS THE FLOOR
MANAGER. AB 3134. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 3134
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S SHIN. AN ACT
RELATING TO PROPERTY TAXATION.
SENATOR JONES, SENATOR JONES,
THIS IS YOUR ITEM FOR ME. SURE
SENATOR WILK HAS PRESENTED HIS
FINAL BILL. I'M RETIRED. SENATOR
JONES, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING ON TOP OF
THINGS THIS MORNING. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 3134, WHICH EXPEDITES
THE PAYMENT OF PROPERTY TAX AND
ASSESSMENT REFUNDS TO TAXPAYERS.
EXISTING LAW AUTHORIZES COUNTIES
TO PROACTIVELY ISSUE A PROPERTY
TAX REFUND WITHOUT A TAXPAYER
FILING. IF A CLAIM IN THE AMOUNT
OWED IS LESS THAN $5,000. THIS
MEASURE INCREASES THAT CAP TO
$10,000. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB 3134 MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS, THIS ITEM?
ALL RIGHT. WE DO HAVE A MEMBER
OFF THE FLOOR. SO WE'RE ONLY
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE RULE
ONCE AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO PUT
THIS MEASURE ON CALL SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN I
GILL I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLEY I DODD. I TERRAZZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE I OTERO I JONES I LAIRD I
LOWMAN I MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN.
NEWMAN NGUYEN I NILO I TURBO I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO. SATO I SKINNER. SMALL.
CUEVAS STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB. I
WIENER I WILK. I SEN. JONES
MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP, ITEM 60.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 863.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. PHªN.
ASSEMBLY BILL 863 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY. AN ACT
RELATING TO RECYCLING. SENATOR
LAIRD, I THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. PRESIDENT. THIS BILL IS
ABOUT EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY ON CARPETS. SINCE
JULY 2011, CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
HAVE PAID A CARPET STEWARDSHIP
ASSESSMENT FEE WHEN PURCHASING
THE CARPET SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT FUNDS A STATEWIDE PROGRAM
CALLED CARE CAL RECYCLE,
DETERMINED IN CARE'S ANNUAL
REPORTS THAT THEY WEREN'T
COMPLIANT FROM 2014 TO 2017.
AGAIN, IN 2019, 2021 AND 2022
AND 2021. CARE AGREED TO PAY 1.1
MILLION IN PENALTIES FOR THEIR
FAILURE TO MEET THE PROGRAM
GOALS FOR FOUR YEARS. CLEARLY,
THIS PROGRAM NEEDS TO BE
REFORMED. RECYCLERS AND
COLLECTORS HAVE LEFT THE STATE
OR GONE OUT OF BUSINESS DUE TO A
LACK OF FEEDSTOCK. WHILE CARPET
IS STILL BEING LANDFILLED. THIS
BILL WILL RESULT IN MEANINGFUL
REFORM OF THE PROGRAM THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS WITH SINCE 2021. IN
HER EFFORTS TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS BILL, THE
AUTHOR HAS SCALED BACK THE
PROVISION SIGNIFICANTLY AND
THOSE AMENDMENTS HAVE REMOVED
THE OPPOSITION FROM THE
RESILIENT FLOORING, SYNTHETIC
TURF AND CUSHION INTERESTS.
SHE'S WORKED HARD TO GET THIS
BILL ON A MORE MODERATE PLACE,
IS COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR LAIRD, IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? MEMBERS SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON. RODA-GIL NO. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALI. NO DODD. AYE. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO AYE.
JONES. NO LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MAGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO
COBO. NO. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
ROTH BY RUBIO. SATO. NO SKINNER.
A SMALL CUEVAS. STERN UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB WIENER. WILK NO.
SENATOR LAIRD MOVES A CALL. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 61. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1113. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1113 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. AN ACT
RELATING TO PUPIL DATA. SENATOR
LEÓN. THANK YOU, COLLEAGUE AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1113. THE BILL DIRECTS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DEFINE AND COLLECT
ENROLLMENT AND PARTICIPATION
DATA ON STUDENTS PARTAKING IN
AFTERSCHOOL PROGRAMS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THIS BILL HAS SUPPORT SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES AND IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, EYES 39. NO.
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 62, THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2250. SECRETARY,
PLEASE. VÌ. SENATOR WIENER, IS
HE HERE ON THE FLOOR? HE IS.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2250 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WEBER. AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH. SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
I RISE TO PRESENT AB 2250 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
TO REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS TO INCLUDE COVERAGE FOR
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
SCREENINGS AND ACCESS TO
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS. SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH IS
COMMONLY DEFINED AS A CONDITIONS
IN WHICH PEOPLE ARE BORN, GROW,
WORK, LIVE, AND AGE IN WHICH A
WIDER SET OF FORCES AND SYSTEMS
SHAPES THE CONDITIONS OF DAILY
LIFE AND AFFECTS HEALTH,
FUNCTIONING AND QUALITY OF LIFE.
OUTCOMES AND RISKS. THIS
ENCOMPASSES. THIS IMPACTS ABOUT
80% OF YOUR HEALTH RISKS, HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND UNFORTUNATELY, YOUR
LIFE EXPECTANCY. IT'S HORRIFIC
THAT IN 2024, YOUR ZIP CODE
DETERMINES YOUR LIFE EXPECTANCY.
THESE SCREENINGS ARE ESSENTIAL
IN HELPING PEOPLE STAY AS
HEALTHY AS POSSIBLE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR WIENER,
DOES ANY SENATOR WANT TO BE
HEARD ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. AYE. AYE BLAKESBURG.
AYE. BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ DALLY. NÓ. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ GROVE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN MILO. NO TROBO. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO SATO. NO. SKINNER SMALL.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE. WE DO HAVE A FULL
HOUSE. WE'LL GO THROUGH THE ROLL
ONE MORE TIME. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CORTEZ.
AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE MCGUIRE.
NGUYEN OKOBO. RUBIO. AYE
SKINNER. AYE. AYES 32 NOES FOR
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM 6063. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 2263 WITH THE FLOOR
MANAGER, SENATOR WIENER
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2263 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES. SENATOR
WIENER AYE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2263 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN, THIS
BILL CREATES A GUARANTEED INCOME
STUDY AND FUNDING ACT
COORDINATING COUNCIL AND TASKED
WITH CONDUCTING A COMPREHENSIVE
STUDY ON THE NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FUNDING
MECHANISMS FOR A STATEWIDE
GUARANTEED INCOME PROGRAM TO
ALLEVIATE POVERTY AND PROMOTE
ECONOMIC EMPOWERMENT IN
CALIFORNIA. GUARANTEED INCOME
PROGRAMS OFFER A BEACON OF HOPE
FOR THE 5 MILLION CALIFORNIANS
LIVING IN POVERTY. GUARANTEED
INCOME NOT ONLY ALLEVIATES
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP, BUT INFUSES
DIGNITY INTO THE LIVES OF THOSE
FACING ECONOMIC ADVERSITY AND
GRAPPLING WITH SYSTEMIC
INEQUALITIES. EARLY DATA FROM
GUARANTEED INCOME PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA IS PROMISING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE. GILL.
NO. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
NØ. DODD DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
NO. NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. AYE. WAYNE. NO. NILO NO.
JOBO. NO PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. NO. SKINNER. AYE AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE WILK. NO WE HAVE A MEMBER
OFF THE FLOOR, SO SEN WIENER
MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 64. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2460. SENATOR UMBERG IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
THE BILL. ASSEMBLY BILL 2460 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TODD. AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS. SENATOR UMBERG,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES.
AB 2460 CLARIFIES THAT AN
ASSOCIATION, THE MEMBERSHIP
ITSELF, MAY RECONVENE AN
ELECTION MEETING USING A REDUCED
QUORUM, NOT LEAVING IT SIMPLY TO
THE BOARD. I URGE AND I VOTE
MEMBERS. DOES ANY SENATOR WANT
TO BE HEARD ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
SENATOR WANT TO BE HEARD? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO AYE. TROBOK
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SATO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. SENATOR UMBERG MOVES TO
CALL. NEXT UP IS ITEM 65. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2629.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2629 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HAYNIE. AN ACT RELATING TO
FIREARMS. SENATOR PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE FEDERALLY
PROHIBITED FROM OBTAINING OR
POSSESSING FIREARMS, THEY
CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO DO SO
BECAUSE NEITHER THE CAL, DOJ NOR
THE FEDERAL AUTHORITIES ARE
INFORMED OF THE MENTAL
INCOMPETENCY OF THOSE FINDINGS.
SO THIS BILL SEEKS TO CREATE
MORE COMMUNICATION TO CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLE SO WE CAN COMMUNICATE
WHEN SOMEONE SHOULD NOT HAVE A
GUN AND THEREFORE THEY NOT HAVE
A GUN. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
PORTANTINO, DOES ANY SENATOR
WANT TO BE HEARD ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
RODA-GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY AYE. DODD TERRAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN
AYE. NILO AYE. BOGUE AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO.
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE. WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE,
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLL ONE LAST TIME, AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLL.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD EGGMAN.
MCGUIRE.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. I DON'T KNOW.
SENATOR PORTENTINO MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 66. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2851. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2851
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA AND
AQUILINA. AIR POLLUTION.
MEMBERS, PLEASE GIVE SENATOR
LAIRD YOUR ATTENTION. SENATOR
LAIRD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. ASSEMBLY BILL 2051
FOCUSES ON ELIMINATING TOXIC
EMISSIONS FROM METAL SHREDDING
FACILITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. METAL SHREDDING
FACILITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOCATED IN
OUR MOST VULNERABLE AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
ALREADY ARE SUFFERING FROM HIGH
AMOUNTS OF POLLUTION EXPOSURE.
THIS BILL WILL BRING TOGETHER
LOCAL AIR MANAGEMENT DISTRICTS,
THE OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH HAZARD ASSESSMENT AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCE
CONTROL TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
FACILITY WIDE FENCE LINE AIR
MONITORING AT METAL SHREDDING
FACILITIES. AT THE TIME OF THE
ANALYSIS, THERE WAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. BRAUTIGAM. NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
NO. DODD DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN
NO. NILO NO. COBO NO. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SATO. NO. SKINNER A
SMALL CREVICE. AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. AYE. WILK. AYE. WE HAVE A
FULL HOUSE, SO WE'LL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ONE LAST TIME.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DODD AYE. GROVE MCGUIRE. ON A
VOTE OF 31 TO 7, THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 67.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2095.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2095 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC NOTICE. SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. AB 2095 CHANGES THE
LEGAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
PUBLICATION OF LEGAL NOTICES TO
REQUIRE THAT THE NOTICE BE
PUBLISHED IN PRINT ON THE
NEWSPAPER'S WEBSITE AND ON A
STATEWIDE WEBSITE MAINTAINED BY
THE CLEARINGHOUSE FOR NOTICES BY
CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPERS. I URGE
AND I VOTE MEMBERS. THIS HAS
SUPPORT SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES
AND IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS. AYE'S 39. NÓ ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NOW TO FILE ITEM 68,
ASSEMBLY BILL 1843. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1843
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ. AN
ACT RELATING TO PRIVATE
EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR. CIERTO.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
AB 1843 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ. THIS BILL
WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE AND
EXPAND THE MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO OUR
EMS WORKERS IN PRIVATE AMBULANCE
COMPANIES WITH 18. WITH AB 1843,
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS WILL HAVE
THE RESOURCES AND SUPPORT THEY
NEED TO ADDRESS THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS AND RECOVER SO THEY
CAN CONTINUE PROVIDING
CALIFORNIANS WITH THE EMERGENCY
CARE THAT THEY NEED AND DESERVE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTION. AYE'S 39. NØ ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO ITEM
71 FOR MANAGER'S. WAHAB, THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 1831. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1831
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. AN
ACT RELATING TO CRIMES. SENATOR
WAHAB. THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN, I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 1831, WHICH WOULD
MODERNIZE OUR LAWS TO ENSURE
THAT AI GENERATED SEXUALLY
EXPLICIT IMAGES OF CHILDREN ARE
ILLEGAL TO POSSESS, DISTRIBUTE,
AND CREATE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR WAHAB, IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. OH, SORRY. WE HAVE SOMEONE
OFF THE FLOOR. ALL RIGHT. ALL
DEBATE HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
OBERNOLTE. GÒM. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. SHAKESPEARE. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZO. I EGGMAN, I
GLAESER, I GONZALEZ. I GROVE I
URDAHL, I JONES, I LAIRD I LIMON
I MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. I MEAN, I
NEWMAN. I NGUYEN I NILO I CHIRLA
EBCLC I PODIUM I PORTANTINO. I
ROTH I RUBIO. SEYARTO I SKINNER.
I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN. UMBERG I
WAHAB. I WIENER I WILK I PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE. RUBIO. I STERN I. ON A
VOTE OF 39 TO 0, THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 78. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 180. SENATOR
WIENER IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 180
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. AN
ACT RELATING TO THE STATE BUDGET
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFOR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. BUDGET BILL.
SENATOR WIENER, I THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, AB 180 IS
A BUDGET BILL JUNIOR AMENDING
THE BUDGET ACT. IT MAKES
AMENDMENTS TO THE 2024 BUDGET
ACT AND RELATES TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SENATE BILL
1137 FROM 2022 BY THE MAJORITY
LEADER, WHICH ESTABLISHES HEALTH
PROTECTION ZONES AND ADDITIONAL
MONITORING AND LEAK DETECTION
PLANS FOR OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS. THE BILL
APPROPRIATES $9.9 MILLION FROM
THE OIL, GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUND TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION, 2.3
$2.32 MILLION FROM THE SAME FUND
TO THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. THESE ADJUSTMENTS ARE
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
BUDGET ACT OF 2024. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE
ALVARADO. GILL. NØ. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY NÓ. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. GROVE NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD.
AYE LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NIELLO. NO COBO.
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN UMBERG. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK NO. SEN. WIENER MOVES
A CALL. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 79. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 218. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. THE ASSEMBLY BILL
218 BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET.
AN ACT RELATING TO OIL AND GAS
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
WIENER. AYE, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. THIS BILL INCLUDES.
EXCUSE ME AB 218 IS THE
RESOURCES TRAILER BILL. IT
INCLUDES STATUTORY CHANGES
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT A 2022
MEASURE, SENATE BILL 1137, BY
THE MAJORITY LEADER, WHICH
ESTABLISHED HEALTH PROTECTION
HEALTH PROTECTION ZONES AS WELL
AS ADDITIONAL MONITORING AND
LEAK DETECTION PLANS FOR OIL AND
GAS OPERATIONS. SOON AFTER SB
1137 WAS CHAPTERED AN INITIATIVE
WAS PLACED ON THE NOVEMBER 2024
BALLOT PROPOSING TO REPEAL THE
BILL. THAT BALLOT MEASURE WAS
WITHDRAWN THIS PAST JUNE. AS A
RESULT, IMPLEMENTATION OF MUCH
OF THE BILL HAS BEEN IN LIMBO
FOR APPROXIMATELY 18 MONTHS DUE
TO THE REFERENDUM AND
WITHDRAWAL. SEVERAL DEADLINES IN
THE ORIGINAL BILL NEED TO BE
EXTENDED TO ENSURE PROPER
IMPLEMENTATION, SUCH AS OPERATOR
FACILITY AND WELLHEAD
COMPLIANCE, AND LEAK DETECTION
AND RESPONSE PLANS. THE BILL
APPROPRIATES $2.65 MILLION FROM
THE OIL, GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUND FOR THE 2024
2025 FISCAL YEAR TO THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TO
SUPPORT WATER QUALITY COMPONENTS
RELATED TO SB 1137 MEMBERS. I
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. TÂM NØ. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ
AYE. DEL NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
JONES. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO
JOBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
SEYARTO. NO. SKINNER AYE. A
SMALL CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG WAHAB. AYE. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. NO SEN. WIENER MOVES
A CALL.
FILE ITEM 81 IS UP WITH SENATOR
GLAZER READY TO PRESENT.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1205 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR GLAZER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN, THIS IS A
MEASURE MEMBERS THAT YOU HAVE
SEEN A NUMBER OF TIMES BEFORE.
BACK IN 2016. YOU, WITH YOUR
SUPPORT, A PROGRAM WAS CREATED
TO SUPPORT STUDENTS TRYING TO
FINISH THEIR UNIVERSITY
EDUCATION AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY IN FOUR YEARS,
IF THEY'RE A FRESHMAN AND A TWO
YEARS IF THEY ARE A TRANSFER.
THAT PROGRAM IS SET TO EXPIRE
AND SUNSET. THIS BILL IS THE
EXTENSION OF THAT PROGRAM. IN
ADDITION TO EXTENDING THE SUNSET
OR EXTENDING THE PROGRAM, IT
ALSO HAS SOME REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND CHANGES THE NAME
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE TO
FINISH IN FOUR MEMBERS. WHEN WE
ENACTED THAT BILL THAT CREATED
THIS PROGRAM IN 2016, THE FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION RATE AT THE
STATE UNIVERSITIES WAS 19%.
THAT'S IT. 19%. THE STUDENTS
ENTERING AS FRESHMEN GRADUATED
TODAY THAT THAT FOUR YEAR RATE
IS 38%, A DOUBLING IN EIGHT
YEARS. THAT MEANS STUDENTS
COMPLETING THEIR DEGREE WITH
LESS DEBT AND PROVIDING THE
GREATEST OPPORTUNITIES THAT THAT
UNIVERSITY EDUCATION CAN GIVE TO
THEM. FOR THEMSELVES AND FOR OUR
ECONOMY. SO IT'S BEEN A VERY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM. I'M GLAD
THAT WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXTEND IT AND TO CONTINUE THE
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE WITH THE
GREAT WORK OF THE UNIVERSITY
PRESIDENTS AND FACULTY AND STAFF
AT THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. AND
WITH THAT, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. I VOTE TODAY SENATOR
MEMBER WISH TO BE HEARD ON THIS
ITEM. I SEE NO MICS UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN Ã ALVARADO. GILL.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY AYE.
DODD DURAZO. AYE EGGMAN. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO VÌ. JONES AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LEMON AYE. MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE NILO. AYE.
CHOBOQ AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE
MOORLACH. CHÁVEZ. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO, GILL. AYE EGGMAN. AYE
MCGUIRE. AYES 39. NO. ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
ITEM 46. IS SENATOR MENGIBAR ON
THE FLOOR, PLEASE. COULD ASK HER
TO RETURN TO HER DESK. SENATOR
MENGIBAR. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR MENGIBAR HAS BEEN FOUND.
LET'S MOVE TO FILE ITEM 46. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2041.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2041 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA. AN ACT RELATING TO THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF 1974 AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
MENGIBAR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. AB
2041 RAISES THE $5,000 LIFETIME
CAP ON SECURITY EXPENSES USING
CAMPAIGN FUNDS, WHICH HAS NOT
BEEN ADJUSTED FOR 30 YEARS, AND
NOW IS WISHING TO INCREASE TO A
$10,000 LIFETIME CAP. AB 2041
REMOVES THE REQUIREMENT FOR A
VERIFIED THREAT BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO REIMBURSE THE
SECURITY EXPENSE. INSTEAD, IT
WOULD HAVE THE CANDIDATE OR
ELECTED OFFICIAL CONFIRM UNDER
PERJURY. THERE IS A SECURITY
THREAT. THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE HAS
WORKED EXTENSIVELY ON THIS
LANGUAGE, WITH FPPC, THE
CANDIDATE SECURITY. CANDIDATE
SECURITY IS A NONPARTIZAN ISSUE
AND HAS PREVIOUSLY RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, THEREFORE
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR NO VOTE
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION. ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE. THIS IS A
TWO THIRDS VOTE THAT MEMBERS AN
URGENCY SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN A GIL ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ
AYE. DALI AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO
SO WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT. WE'RE
GOING TO DO THAT NEXT. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE
AYE. GROVE NO. ADATO AYE. JONES
NO. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. WAYNE MILO. OKOBO
AYE. PERDUE AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO. NO
SKINNER. A SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO.
MEMBERS. WE HAVE ALL. AYE. HOLD
ON. PLEASE. WE HAVE ALL THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE BACK ON THE
FLOOR. SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLL ONE MORE TIME.
MEMBERS, PLEASE. YOUR ATTENTION
PLEASE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO
GILL. AYE BRADFORD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE MCGUIRE. NGUYEN MILO. NO.
OKAY 33 FIVE. ON THE URGENCY. 33
FIVE. THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 80. MEMBERS, THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 98 FOUR, MANAGED
BY SENATOR LIMÓN. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 98 BY
STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN
CARRILLO. AN ACT RELATING TO
LAND USE. SENATOR LIMÓN, THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MEMBERS. TODAY I
RISE PRESENTING AB 98 ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CARRILLO AND
REYES. AB 98 REPRESENTS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD,
ADDRESSING A PRECIOUS PRESSING
ISSUE THAT CONTINUES TO IMPACT
CALIFORNIA LAND USE DECISIONS
AND THAT NEGATIVELY IMPACTS
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES, OUR
STATE AND OUR WORLD ECONOMY IS
INCREASINGLY RELYING ON
MOVEMENT, STORAGE AND DELIVERY
OF GOODS. ALTHOUGH THERE ARE
MANY BENEFITS THAT COME WITH
THIS, THERE ARE ALSO ACUTE SOME
ACUTE COSTS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED.
SOME COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATES
ARE BECOMING CONCENTRATED BY THE
DEVELOPMENT THAT THE FUELS THAT
FUELS THIS INDUSTRY, CAUSING
THEM TO BE HUBS FOR WAREHOUSING
AND THE OFTEN DIESEL TRUCKS THAT
COME WITH THEM. AREAS LIKE THE
INLAND EMPIRE CONTAIN WELL OVER
1,000,000,000FT² OF WAREHOUSING,
MAKING IT HOME TO 4000 DISTINCT
WAREHOUSES. AND 600,000 600,000
TRUCK TRIPS A DAY. THIS IS WHY,
FOR NEARLY A DECADE, THE
LEGISLATURE HAS GRAPPLED WITH
HOW TO PROTECT IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES FROM THE RISK THAT
HEAVY DUTY DIESEL TRUCKS PRESENT.
FREIGHT AND ITS IMPACT ON PUBLIC
HEALTH AND COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE MATTER AND IS AN ISSUE
STATEWIDE. AB 98 ADDRESSES THESE
IMPACTS WHILE ENACTING A NUMBER
OF KEY POLICY CHANGES. FIRST, AB
98 PUTS IN PLACE MANDATORY
SETBACKS OF 300 TO 500FT BETWEEN
WAREHOUSES AND SENSITIVE
RECEPTORS SUCH AS HOMES, SCHOOLS
AND HOSPITALS. THESE SETBACKS
VARY BASED ON. THE SIZE OF THE
WAREHOUSE AND THE ZONING OF THE
AREA. NEXT, THIS LEGISLATION
PUTS IN PLACE 21ST CENTURY
BUILDING STANDARDS FOR NEW
WAREHOUSES SUCH AS PROHIBITING
HEAVY DUTY DIESEL TRUCKS FROM
BEING ADJACENT TO SENSITIVE
RECEPTOR PROPERTY LINES AND
PROPERTY LINE BUFFERS OF 50 TO
100FT. AB 98 REQUIRES A TWO FOR
ONE REPLACEMENT FOR HOMES
DEMOLISHED IN ORDER TO MAKE ROOM
FOR MORE LOGISTICS, DEVELOPMENT,
AND 12 MONTHS PAYMENT TO
DISPLACED RENTERS. AB 98 ALSO
PUTS IN PLACE A MANDATORY UPDATE
OF TRUCK ROUTES STATEWIDE TO
ENSURE TRUCKS DO NOT ROUTE
THEMSELVES THROUGH RESIDENTIAL
STREETS IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AB
98 INCLUDES AN INTERIM REPORT IN
2028 THAT ALLOWS FOR US TO TRACK
OUR PROGRESS IN REDUCING
EMISSIONS DUE TO THESE SETBACKS
AND EVALUATE OUR NEXT STEPS. THE
LEGISLATION BEFORE YOU IS A
COMPROMISE, AND LIKE MOST
COMPROMISES, THERE ARE GROUPS
THAT WILL SAY THAT THIS BILL
GOES TOO FAR AND THERE ARE
GROUPS THAT SAY THIS BILL DOES
NOTHING. I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
A SIGN OF A COMPROMISE, AND I
TRUST THAT THE AUTHORS,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARRILLO, A CITY
PLANNER FOR OVER 20 YEARS AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES, ONE OF OUR
LEGISLATURE'S STRONGEST
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE CHAMPIONS,
HAVE DELIVERED A BILL THAT
STRIKES THE NEED FOR A
COMPROMISE. I KNOW THAT THEY ARE
COMMITTED TO SEEING LEGISLATION
NOT JUST AS WE PASS IT, BUT ALSO
THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION
PROCESS AS WELL. MORE
IMPORTANTLY, I BELIEVE THIS
LEGISLATION IS NOT ONLY
RIGHTEOUS IN ITS INTENT, BUT IT
IS CRITICAL IN ADDRESSING A
GROWING ISSUE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR LEHMAN. I HAVE
MICROPHONES UP FROM SENATOR
OCHOA, BOGH AND SENATOR DOLLY
FIRST TURN TO AND SENATOR
DURAZZO. WE'LL FIRST TURN TO
SENATOR OCHOA, BOGH. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE INLAND
EMPIRE, I RISE TO EXPRESS GREAT
CONCERN WITH THIS LAST MINUTE
LEGISLATION. THE ISSUE IS OF
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE TO OUR
REGION AS ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING AREAS IN THE COUNTRY,
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY IS THE LARGEST
COUNTY IN THE STATE. AND WHEREAS
THE AREAS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
STILL HAS A LOT OF OPEN LAND, IT
NEEDS TO KEEP PACE WITH THE
DEMAND FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. OTHERWISE, OUR
RESIDENTS WILL CONTINUE TO
COMMUTE FOR HOURS TO OTHER
REGIONS FOR WORK WHICH, MIND
YOU, ONLY RESULTS IN INCREASED
EMISSIONS. MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE RECOGNIZED
CONCERNS REGARDING OUR REGION'S
AIR QUALITY AND ADOPTED POLICIES
TO HELP BALANCE THE IMPACTS OF
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES NEEDS. THOSE
POLICIES SHOULD BE DEVELOPED BY
OUR COMMUNITIES, AT THE VERY
LEAST, WITH THEIR INPUT. I ASK
THE AUTHORS TO HOLD THIS BILL TO
ENSURE THAT ALL STAKEHOLDERS ARE
AT THE TABLE SO WE CAN HAVE A
TRUE COLLABORATION ON A
COMPREHENSIVE POLICY THAT WILL
BENEFIT ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES,
RATHER THAN A GUT AND AMEND AT
THE VERY LAST MINUTE IN WHICH I
HAVE TO EXPRESS GREAT CONCERNS
BECAUSE MANY OF OUR OWN
STAKEHOLDERS WITHIN THE INLAND
EMPIRE HAD NO IDEA THAT THIS
BILL WAS MOVING FORWARD, OR EVEN
VOTED, OR BEING DISCUSSED. THAT
IS NOT TRUE REPRESENTATION. AND
ONE LAST POINT I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE IS THAT MANY PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT HOW MANY WAREHOUSES ARE IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE, AND OF
COURSE, ONE, BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
A LOT OF OPEN LAND. AND NUMBER
TWO, BECAUSE THE I-10 CORRIDOR
HAS ALWAYS BEEN A MAJOR CORRIDOR
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FROM
OTHER STATES OF THE COUNTRY OR
IN THE COUNTRY, COMING IN
THROUGH THE AREA TO DELIVER MANY
OF THE GOODS THAT OUR STATE
UTILIZES. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR. I HAVE ON THE
SPEAKER LIST SENATOR DOLLY,
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR DURAZZO,
CABALLERO, WIENER AND EGGMAN. SO
I SEE YOUR MICROPHONES. LET'S
TURN NEXT TO SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. I TOO RISE IN
OPPOSITION. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I ACTUALLY SAT IN THE
COMMITTEE, AND IT WAS ONE OF THE
MOST BIZARRE COMMITTEES I'VE
SEEN IN THE 12 YEARS I'VE BEEN
HERE. FIRST OF ALL, THE SENATOR
FROM HAYWARD ASKED WHO WAS AT
THE TABLE, AND THEY SAID, OH,
THE LOCAL GROUPS. AND THERE WAS
THE SOCIAL JUSTICE PEOPLE AND
THE LABOR. AND THEN THEY SAID
SPECIFICALLY WHO AND NEITHER OF
THE AUTHORS COULD SAY EXACTLY
WHO WAS AT THE TABLE. THAT'S A
FACT. I WAS THERE. THEY COULDN'T
ANSWER THE QUESTION. THIS BILL
HAS BEEN COOKED UP AT THE END
AND LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
THIS IS NOT JUST THE INLAND
EMPIRE. THIS IS THE WHOLE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. NOW, THOSE IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE HAVE SOME, I
BELIEVE, SOME SIGNIFICANT ISSUES
THAT MAY NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
BUT WE HAVE A PORT IN OAKLAND
THAT BRINGS FREIGHT AND STOCKTON
THAT THE I-80 TO THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY. AND SO THIS IS THIS IS
JUST I THINK, MORE THAN
ANYTHING, IT WAS IT WAS NOT THE
PEOPLE WEREN'T AT THE TABLE.
THIS WAS COOKED UP IN THE BACK
ROOMS OF THE ASSEMBLY AND SMOKE
FILLED ROOMS. AND IT WAS NOT
DONE RIGHT. NOT IN THE, IN THE
TRANSPARENCY OF PEOPLE AT THE
TABLE BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T
ANSWER WHO WAS AT THE TABLE. SO
THIS BILL NEEDS A LOT MORE WORK.
THIS IS A STATEWIDE BILL, AND
IT'S GOING TO IMPACT A RICE
FARMER IN YUBA WHO IS GOING TO
EXPAND 10,000FT. AND HE HAS A
DAY SCHOOL NEXT, NEXT DOOR TO
IT. HE'S GOING TO BE IMPACTED.
THIS IS NOT JUST THE INLAND
EMPIRE, WHICH WHAT HAS BEEN THE
FOCUS OF THIS BILL. THIS IS A
STATEWIDE BILL. IT'S GOING TO
IMPACT A LOT OF THE STATE. AND
FOR THOSE REASONS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR DURAZO. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MR. PRESIDENT, I
SERVE AS CHAIR OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE, WHERE WE
HEARD THIS BILL. THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES NEW GUARDRAILS TO
PROTECT FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED BY WAREHOUSE
DEVELOPMENT. IT ESTABLISHES
SETBACKS AND OTHER MINIMUM
STANDARDS FOR NEW AND EXPANDED
WAREHOUSES. YES, ACROSS THE
STATE, BECAUSE WE NEED STATE
STANDARDS WITH HIGHER STANDARDS
FOR THE MOST IMPACTED REGION.
THE INLAND EMPIRE. IT ENSURES 2
TO 1 REPLACEMENT OF ANY
DEMOLISHED HOUSING AT AN
AFFORDABLE LEVEL, WHICH IS
CRITICAL TO THOSE COMMUNITIES.
IT REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ENSURE THEY HAVE TRUCK ROUTES AT
DIRECT TRAFFIC, AWAY FROM HOMES
AND SCHOOLS. STATE STANDARDS ARE
CRITICAL TO MAKE SURE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AREN'T APPROVING
THESE WAREHOUSES WITH ALMOST NO
PROTECTIONS AT ALL FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. ON THE OTHER HAND,
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN STILL
REQUIRE LARGER SETBACKS AND MORE
MITIGATION MEASURES, INCLUDING
CEQA MITIGATIONS, OR DENY THESE
DEVELOPMENTS ALTOGETHER. NOTHING
TAKES THAT AWAY FROM THEM. BUT I
ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES AND
CARRILLO FOR BEING WILLING TO
SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
TO CLARIFY THAT THE HOUSING
PROTECTIONS IN THE BILL ARE
INTENDED TO EXPAND ON THE HARD
FOUGHT PROTECTIONS FOR TENANTS.
THIS IS A THIS IS DIFFICULT FOR
SOME, BUT I WANT TO THANK THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN ORGANIZING
AND FIGHTING FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES FOR YEARS. THIS IS
NOT A NEW ISSUE. THE SPECIFIC
ISSUES THAT ARE RAISED IN THIS
BILL HAVE BEEN DEBATED AND
DEBATED YEAR AFTER YEAR, AND
WE'VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO REACH ANY
KIND OF AN AGREEMENT. AND THIS
IS ONE, ONE SPECIAL OPPORTUNITY.
SO I WANT TO THANK THE
ACTIVISTS, THOSE FIGHTING FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND THE
AUTHORS, THE ACTIVISTS BEING
BOTH WORKING PEOPLE INSIDE OF
THOSE WAREHOUSES WHO FACE
TERRIBLE WAGES AND WORKING
CONDITIONS AND YET THE
CONSTRUCTION JOBS OF THOSE
WAREHOUSES, MANY TIMES ARE GOOD
JOBS. I WANT TO THANK THE CBOS,
THE RESIDENTS, THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT MANY OF US HAVE
STOOD WITH AND THEN THERE ARE
OTHERS WHO OPPOSE THIS BECAUSE
IT'S FINALLY GETTING TO US.
WE'RE FINALLY GETTING TO THE
POINT OF STATE STATEWIDE
STANDARDS. THEY DON'T WANT ANY
STANDARDS IN EVERY CAMPAIGN WE
HAVE, WE COME ACROSS THESE
MOMENTS OF SOME VERY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS IN THIS CASE POOR
COMMUNITIES, POOR COMMUNITIES,
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO
HISTORICALLY HAVE GOTTEN THE
SHAFT THE ARE INVOLVED IN THIS,
AND THEY NEED SOME JUSTICE IN
THIS CASE, THE AIR OUR
COMMUNITIES BREATHE, THE
ILLNESSES OUR CHILDREN SUFFER,
THE POVERTY OF NOT KNOWING IF
THEY CAN PAY FOR A ROOF OVER
THEIR HEAD. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE FAILED, PROMISING ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WHILE GIVING AWAY
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS IN TAX
BREAKS THROUGHOUT OUR LIVES.
MANY OF US HAVE FOUGHT HARD FOR
WHAT WE THOUGHT WAS THE BEST
ALONG EVERY STEP OF THE WAY. WE
ALWAYS HAVE WANTED TO GET
BETTER, KNOWING THAT WE DESERVED
MUCH, MUCH MORE. SO OUR CHOICE
IS DO WE KEEP ON PUSHING FOR
MORE AND FAIR AND DECENT LIVING
CONDITIONS FOR OUR COMMUNITIES,
OR DO WE GIVE UP? TODAY I ASK US
TO EMBRACE THIS BIG STEP
FORWARD, NOT GIVE UP. KEEP
FIGHTING FOR MORE. I, FOR ONE,
ALONG WITH MANY OF YOU, WILL
STAND SIDE BY SIDE WITH THESE
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. SENATOR
DURAZZO. NEXT UP, I HAVE SENATOR
CABALLERO, FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
EGGMAN BECKER, MENGIBAR AND
GROVE. SENATOR CABALLERO, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT,
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW
WORDS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL, I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORS FOR
THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK, AS MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM LA SAID, THIS
IS NOT A NEW ISSUE. 2 OR 3 YEARS
AGO, A BILL VERY SIMILAR TO
THIS, TAKING A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT, APPROACH TO HOW TO
REGULATE THE, THE SPACE AROUND
WAREHOUSES WAS PRESENTED BY ONE
OF THE AUTHORS, AND THE BILL
CAME TO GOVERN FINANCE, AND WE
HAD A HEARING WHERE WE INVITED
THE, THE, THE COMMUNITY TO COME
AND HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH US
ABOUT WHY THE BILL WAS
IMPORTANT. ULTIMATELY, I ASKED
THE BILL TO BE HELD, AND I, I
TALKED WITH THE AUTHOR AND ASKED
HER TO DO SOME MORE WORK ON IT.
THERE WERE TOO MANY THINGS THAT
NEEDED TO BE TAKEN CARE OF IN
ORDER FOR US TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE PROTECTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CONTROL, BUT WE ALSO,
CREATING AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO BE SAFE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. WHEN WE START
BUILDING THESE KINDS OF
FACILITIES AND SHE WENT OUT AND
SHE DID EXACTLY WHAT SHE SAID
SHE WAS GOING TO DO. WE HAD A
ROBUST DISCUSSION IN OUR
COMMITTEE, AND, AND I JUST THINK
IT'S, IT'S REALLY REMARKABLE
THAT SHE WAS ABLE TO GET TO A
PLACE WHERE NOT EVERYBODY IS
HAPPY. AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LIST, THE LIST HAS, IT'S NOT ONE
SIDE OR THE OTHER. IT'S BOTH
SIDES THAT ARE A LITTLE BIT
UNHAPPY. AND THE VALUE OF THAT
IS, YOU KNOW, THAT IT'S BEEN
NEGOTIATED PRETTY INTENSELY. AND
I UNDERSTAND NOT EVERYBODY WAS
AT THE TABLE. AND SOMETIMES
THAT'S THAT'S HARD TO DO. WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'RE GIVING ENOUGH LOCAL
CONTROL TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO
THAT THEY CAN MAKE SOME CHOICES
FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES, AND YOU
GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
WORKERS THAT ARE GOING TO WORK
INSIDE THE BUILDING, AND THE
WORKERS THAT ARE GOING TO LIVE
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD TO ALSO HAVE
PEACE OF MIND THAT, THAT THE
ENVIRONMENT WILL BE AS CLEAN AS
POSSIBLE GIVEN THESE KINDS OF
FACILITIES. SO AS WE MOVE, AS WE
MOVE TO A SOCIETY WHERE PEOPLE
DON'T SHOP IN A STORE ANYMORE,
BUT THEY BUY ONLINE, THESE
FACILITIES ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO PROLIFERATE. AND, AND SO
WE'VE BROUGHT IT ON OURSELVES,
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
PROTECTING ALL ELEMENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY AS WE DO THIS KIND OF
DEVELOPMENT. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR EGGMAN,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS,
UNFORTUNATELY, TODAY I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL, LOCALLY,
MY COMMUNITY HAS BEEN WORKING
FOR A WHILE NOW TO COME UP WITH
OUR OUR OWN, OUR OWN ORDINANCE
AROUND THIS. AND AS FAR AS WE
CAN SEE, THIS LOOKS LIKE IT
SUPERSEDES WHATEVER WE MAY COME
UP WITH. AND IF MY
ENVIRONMENTALS AND MY LOCAL
COMMUNITY ARE AGAINST THIS, THEN
I THINK SOMETHING'S WRONG WITH
LOOKING AT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL,
AS PEOPLE KNOW, I REPRESENT THE
STOCKTON AREA WHERE WE HAVE THE
99, THE FIVE, THE 205, THE 80,
AND THE PORT OF STOCKTON, AS
WELL AS A RAIL SYSTEM THAT SENDS
THINGS ALL OVER THE WAY THIS
BILL IS WRITTEN. IT ALSO
INCLUDES SOME SMALL
MANUFACTURING. WE VOTED IN THIS
THIS CHAMBER A COUPLE OF DAYS
AGO TO MAKE SURE NOBODY DOES
PAPER. WE ONLY HAVE PLASTIC.
WELL, I GOT INTERNATIONAL PAPER
IN MY DISTRICT MAKING THESE
PAPER BAGS AND AN ORDINANCE LIKE
THIS IS GOING TO IMPACT THEM.
THOSE ARE GOOD JOBS. THOSE ARE
JOBS OFF THE HIGHWAY. SO I
BELIEVE THAT AS WE CONTINUE AS
AS THE SENATOR FROM MERCED SAID,
WE ARE NOW A SOCIETY WHO LIKES
TO SHOP ONLINE AND WE WANT OUR
THINGS. WE WANT THEM NOW, I'M
NOT SAYING THAT THESE WAREHOUSES
SHOULD BE THE END ALL, BE ALL
FOR PEOPLE, BUT IT IS A PART OF
OUR SOCIETY AND OUR GOODS
MOVEMENT. AND AGAIN, AS FAR AS I
CAN SEE, THIS DOES NOT JUST
IMPACT WAREHOUSES, BUT ALSO
SMALL MANUFACTURING. THE PORT OF
STOCKTON, THE LARGEST INLAND
PORT IN THE WESTERN HEMISPHERE,
IS IN MY DISTRICT. AND WHEN THE
PORT OF STOCKTON BECAME PUBLIC,
NEXT TO IT WAS A NAVY STATION,
ROUGH AND READY ISLAND, STOCKTON
COMMUNITY WAS ABLE TO ACQUIRE
ALL OF THAT. AND THAT HAS BEEN
OUR MAIN FOCUS FOR DEVELOPMENT
FOR WAREHOUSES, FOR EVERYTHING.
HAVING RIGHT THERE ON THE PORT
WHERE THE SHIPS COME IN, THE
TRAIN GOES OUT. THIS BILL WILL
IMPACT MY ENTIRE REGION. AS FAR
AS JOBS, JOB CREATION AND
MOVEMENT GOODS. THIS BILL AT THE
END OF THE SESSION RUSHED RIGHT
THROUGH WITH NOBODY ALLOWED TO
GIVE ANY INPUT. I THINK IS NOT
THE WAY TO GO ABOUT GOOD
LEGISLATION. AND I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR NO VOTE AND COME BACK NEXT
YEAR AND TRY TO INCLUDE AND
INCLUDE ALL THE ONES THAT ARE
ALREADY IN PROCESS AROUND THE
STATE, AND NOT JUST PUT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL AT THE END OF
SESSION ON THE LAST DAY. THANK
YOU SENATOR EGGMAN. SENATOR
BECKER, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I WANT TO ADDRESS TWO
ISSUES, THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ISSUE, NUMBER ONE, BUT
ALSO, I WANT TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF MANUFACTURING, IT GETS
TO SOME OF THE POINTS THAT WERE
JUST BROUGHT UP, WE, YOU KNOW,
IN MY DISTRICT, FIRST OF ALL, WE
HAVE A LOT OF MANUFACTURERS.
WE'VE GOT A LONG LIST OF
MANUFACTURERS, AND EXPANDING 20%
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME. THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENS IS TECHNOLOGY. YOU
START SMALL AND YOU EXPAND AND
THESE MANUFACTURERS ARE MAKING
CHOICES. ALL THE TIME ABOUT
WHERE TO THESE COMPANIES ARE
MAKING CHOICES ABOUT WHERE TO
MANUFACTURE. AND, IN MOST CASES
NOW THEY'RE DECIDING NOT TO
MANUFACTURE IN CALIFORNIA. AND I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
WE WANT TO ADDRESS, AS A BODY
AND I WANT TO ADDRESS IS HOW DO
WE BRING MANUFACTURING BACK? HOW
DO WE KEEP MANUFACTURING HERE?
AND SO ANYTHING THAT MAKES IT
MORE COMPLICATED FOR THEM,
WHETHER IT BE DESIGN STANDARDS,
ALL THESE THINGS, WHEN, WHEN
THEY WERE NOT THE INTENT OF THE
BILL IS OF GREAT CONCERN FOR ME.
SO, I'VE SPOKEN TO THE AUTHORS
AND THEY'VE COMMITTED TO ME TO
WORKING ON MANUFACTURING,
BECAUSE THEY WERE AGAIN, NOT THE
INTENT OF THIS. BILL. AND I
TRUST THAT, THAT COMMITMENT, SO
THAT WAS IMPORTANT TO ME. AND I
WANTED TO BRING THAT UP BECAUSE
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION.
SECONDLY, ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE FRONT, I'M CERTAINLY
CONCERNED THAT SO MANY
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS ARE
ARE OPPOSED. BUT I DO I
CERTAINLY KNOW THE HEART OF THE
AUTHOR, ESPECIALLY, THE ONE OF
THE AUTHORS WHO I THINK CAN USE
THE NAMES. I CAN NEVER FORGET
WHEN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. BUT,
I'LL JUST SAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES, WHO HAS BEEN, YOU KNOW,
WORKING ON THIS FOR MANY YEARS.
AND I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
ABOUT THE WINS IN THIS. AND OF
COURSE, THE LOCALS CAN ALWAYS
DECIDE TO MAKE MORE, MORE
STRINGENT REGULATIONS. SO THOSE
ARE TWO CONCERNS. BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THEM. AND THANKS FOR
HEARING ME OUT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR BECKER. I HAVE
SENATORS MENGIBAR GROVE, WIENER
AND ASHBY, SENATOR MENGIBAR.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE WITH
HEARTBURN BECAUSE I HAVE A LOT
OF RESPECT FOR BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS, AND I SPOKE TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES ON THIS,
AND I GREATLY, GREATLY RESPECT
THEM. BUT I SHARE A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS THAT THE SENATOR FROM
STOCKTON, YUCAIPA AND OTHERS
HAVE SHARED. THIS AND MAYBE IT'S
WITH TWO YEARS IN HERE, THE
FRUSTRATION OF THESE BIG KIND OF
TOPICS GETTING SHOVED DOWN OUR
THROATS IN THE LAST MINUTE
WITHOUT GOING THROUGH A TRUE
PROCESS TO REALLY HAVE EVERY
INDIVIDUAL THAT IS GOING TO BE
IMPACTED BY THIS AT THE TABLE.
AND I KNOW THAT WASN'T THE
INTENT OF THE AUTHORS HERE, AND
I, I GET THAT THAT'S IN FRONT OF
US. BUT THIS YOU KNOW, THERE'S A
SENATOR THAT MENTIONED THIS IS
TO PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THIS WILL NOT
PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THESE SETBACKS
DON'T EVEN MEET THE CARB'S
MINIMUM, 1000FT RECOMMENDATION.
THIS IS A 300 TO 500FT SETBACK
FROM THE LOADING DOCK. IMAGINE
IF THEY HAVE AN ENTIRE PARKING
LOT THAT IS 300FT. THERE'S GOING
TO BE ABSOLUTELY NO SETBACK. AND
IN MY DISTRICT, WAREHOUSING AND
MANUFACTURING IS BLOOMING, WHICH
I'M REALLY EXCITED FOR BECAUSE
OF THE JOBS THAT'S BRINGING TO
MY DISTRICT. BUT THINK ABOUT THE
EVEN MORE CONGESTION THAT THAT'S
GOING TO CAUSE WITHOUT ADEQUATE
STATE DIRECTION. AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
NEXT YEAR CAN COME BACK AND
ACTUALLY REALLY WORK AND GO
THROUGH THE ENTIRE PROCESS TO
GET SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
HAVE EVERYBODY FEEL LIKE IT IS A
COMPROMISE. BUT WHEN WE'RE NOT,
ONE SINGLE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
IS FOR THIS LEGISLATION. WE NEED
TO BE WARY. AND WITH THAT, I'M
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL. NEXT UP,
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I TOO, RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO VÆ 98, WHICH IS A
RUSHED BILL THAT'S EXTREMELY
HARMFUL TO JOBS, FARMING AND
REDEVELOPMENT EFFORTS IN MY
DISTRICT, IT REMOVES ALL LOCAL
CONTROL AND ZONING ISSUES AND
CREATES AGGRESSIVE MITIGATIONS,
WHICH WAS MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUES THE LAST MINUTE
GUTTING, AMEND HAS ZERO INPUT
FROM THE PUBLIC, WHICH THEY
MENTIONED AS WELL, AND THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE LAND USE,
LAND USE, DECISIONS ARE LOCAL
DECISIONS. IT UNFAIRLY TARGETS
THE INLAND EMPIRE. BUT I ALSO
THINK IT UNFAIRLY TARGETS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY, SPECIFICALLY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON WITH THE
PORTS AND THEN ALSO WITH US,
WHERE WE HAVE LARGE LAND. THAT'S
ONE OF THE VALUES THAT WE HAVE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS WE HAVE
LAND. AND TO, TO NEGATIVELY
IMPACT US AGAIN ON THESE ISSUES
IS JUST COMPLETELY UNFAIR. THE
BILL WAS INTENDED TO ADDRESS
WAREHOUSES AND URBAN AREAS.
HOWEVER, AS DRAFTED, THE BILL
APPLIES TO AGRICULTURAL AND
PROCESSING FACILITIES. SO IF YOU
HAVE AN AGRICULTURAL FARM AND
YOU HAVE A WAREHOUSE ON IT, AND
YOU WANT TO DO WHERE YOU PARK
YOUR TRACTORS OR YOUR PRODUCT OR
YOUR ALMONDS OR WHATEVER THE
CASE MAY BE, AND YOU WANT TO
EXPAND IT, YOU'LL BE BOUND BY
THIS LEGISLATION AND IT JUST
DOESN'T FARE WELL TO THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES. THIS
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH, YOU
KNOW, UNDERMINES LOCAL CONTROL.
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO REMIND
YOU GUYS, WITHOUT BEING
SARCASTIC AND JUST BEING REAL
GENUINE, THAT TWO DAYS AGO YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL
IS GOOD. LIKE YOU HAVE TO HAVE
LOCAL CONTROL AND THEY CAN SHUT
DOWN OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION. AND
IT'S ALL ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL.
AND THEN NOW YOU MAKE THE
ARGUMENT THAT VEHICLE LAND USE
AND VEHICLE TRAFFIC CAN'T BE
ENTRUSTED TO LOCAL CONTROL. AND
SO I GUESS IT JUST DEPENDS ON
THE WEATHER OR THE SUBJECT
MATTER. BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS,
IS THAT THIS IS A RUSHED AND
FLAWED PIECE OF LEGISLATION. I
REALLY DO WISH I WOULD HAVE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON COMING
BACK WITH ME NEXT YEAR TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. IF
IT DOES COME BACK UP, BECAUSE
SHE REALLY UNDERSTANDS IT AND
GETS IT FROM A PERSPECTIVE OF
REPRESENTING HER DISTRICT WITH
THE PORT OF STOCKTON THERE, AND
SHE HAS AGAIN, NO OFFENSE,
MA'AM, BUT THE THIRD LARGEST
FOOD PRODUCING COUNTY IN THE
WORLD, AND I OBVIOUSLY HAVE THE
FIRST. AND SO I BUT I DON'T HAVE
A PORT, BUT I THINK IT
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS BOTH OF OUR
DISTRICTS AND, YOU KNOW, JUST TO
BE FAIR, I KNOW THAT, YOU KNOW,
MY COLLEAGUE, MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES AND SAN
FRANCISCO, YOU REPRESENT LARGE
AMOUNTS OF PEOPLE AND WE
REPRESENT LARGE AMOUNTS OF RURAL
AREA. BUT WE SHOULD HAVE I WISH
THERE WAS SOME KIND OF RULE.
THAT NEGATIVE POLICY THAT COMES
OUT OF THIS BUILDING CAN'T
NEGATIVELY IMPACT ANOTHER
PERSON'S DISTRICT, AND THIS BILL
DOES THAT AND IT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
NO VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
GROVE. SENATOR WIENER, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 98. I ACTUALLY AND
I WANT TO FIRST, THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF TALK TODAY ABOUT HOW AS
IF THIS BILL JUST SORT OF LANDED
FROM OUTER SPACE AND PLOPPED IN
OUR LAP A FEW DAYS AGO, AND NOW
WE'RE VOTING ON IT. THERE HAS
BEEN THERE HAVE BEEN YEARS AND
YEARS OF WORK ON THIS ISSUE. I
ENTERED THE LEGISLATURE IN
DECEMBER 2016, ON THE SAME DAY
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES
ENTERED THE LEGISLATURE. IN
DECEMBER 2016. SHE HAS BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE EVER SINCE
THEN. OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE,
SENATOR CONNIE LEYVA, SPENT
YEARS AND YEARS WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE. THIS HAS BEEN A KNOWN
ISSUE, AND BILL, AFTER BILL HAS
BEEN INTRODUCED ON THIS, AND THE
SAD REALITY IS NOT SAD. IT'S
JUST THE NATURE OF POLITICS IS
THAT THE FOLKS, THE WAREHOUSE
INDUSTRY AND THE INDUSTRY FOLKS
DO NOT WANT TO SEE ANY
LIMITATIONS OR ANY MEANINGFUL
LIMITATIONS ON WAREHOUSES. AND
THERE ARE FOLKS ON THE OTHER
SIDE WHO WANT TO SEE INCREDIBLY
STRICT, MUCH STRICTER, FAR
STRICTER RESTRICTIONS THAN ARE
IN THIS BILL. AND SO BILL AFTER
BILL WOULD JUST DIE. AND SO NOW
WE HAVE BEFORE US A BILL. IS IT
PERFECT? NO, NO BILL OF THIS
COMPLEXITY IS GOING TO BE
PERFECT, BUT DOES IT STRIKE A
REASONABLE BALANCE TO SAY, YES,
WE NEED LOGISTICS. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO JUST SHUT IT DOWN. BUT
PEOPLE LIVE IN THESE COMMUNITIES
TOO. AND THIS IS IMPACTING THEM
IN PROFOUND WAYS. ANOTHER ASPECT
OF THIS BILL THAT I THINK IS
REALLY WORTHY IS THAT WHEN
HOUSING IS REMOVED, IT HAS TO BE
REPLACED. 2 TO 1. I THINK THAT
IS ALSO A GOOD THING. SO I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. I WILL BE
VOTING FOR IT AND I URGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. SENATOR
ASHBY, FOLLOWED BY SENATOR MILO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB 98, THOUGH I HOLD BOTH
AUTHORS, ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
CARILLO AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES, IN VERY HIGH ESTEEM AND I
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE WORKED HARD
ON THIS ISSUE AND ARE EXPERTS IN
THE AREA. BUT SOMETIMES A
SOLUTION FOR ONE AREA DOESN'T
FIT EVERY AREA IN CALIFORNIA. I
WAS A LOCAL ELECTED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO FOR OVER A DECADE,
AND IT HAS ONLY BEEN A COUPLE OF
YEARS SINCE WE SUFFERED AN
ABSOLUTE SHORTAGE OF WAREHOUSE
SPACE. WAREHOUSE SPACE HERE
MEANS INNOVATION, JOBS. ALSO, WE
HAVE A LOT OF AREAS IN
SACRAMENTO WHERE WAREHOUSES ARE
CLOSE TO HOMES. WE DO IT
INTENTIONALLY. WE WORKED HARD TO
CREATE CORRIDORS FOR HEALTH
CARE, WHERE WE DO INNOVATIVE
WORK TO TRY TO PUSH FORWARD
SOLUTIONS FOR HEALTH CARE, FOR
FINDING CURES TO DISEASES, FOR
MANUFACTURING THINGS RIGHT HERE
IN THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, FOR KEEPING THEM
CLOSE TO WHERE THEY'RE BEING
USED AND SOLD BY PATIENTS AND BY
DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS. WE'VE
WORKED HARD ON THESE GOALS. I'VE
HEARD FROM MY CITIES AND MY
COUNTY. ALL HAVE TAKEN OFFICIAL
POSITIONS IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL. IN FACT, SOME OF MY
COUNCIL MEMBERS AND MAYORS HAVE
TESTIFIED IN THE LAST 24 HOURS
AT HEARINGS TO SAY HOW WORRIED
AND CONCERNED THEY ARE ABOUT
THIS BILL'S IMPLEMENTATION IN
THIS REGION. I APPLAUD THIS
WORK, AND I KNOW IT'S HARD TO
FIND A BALANCE, AND OFTENTIMES
IN THIS CHAMBER AND IN MANY
OTHER CHAMBERS WHERE WE MAKE
LAWS, IF NOBODY'S HAPPY, THAT
MEANS YOU'VE FOUND A MIDDLE
GROUND. BUT THERE ARE ALSO TIMES
WHERE WHEN NOBODY'S HAPPY, IT
MEANS WE NEED TO KEEP WORKING ON
IT, BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T SOLVED
FOR THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
ORIGINALLY SET OUT TO CURE. I
BELIEVE THAT THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS BILL IN MY DISTRICT AND
AROUND MY DISTRICT WILL CREATE A
MAGNITUDE OF ISSUES, AND I
BELIEVE IT IS AN ISSUE THAT WE
SHOULD EMPOWER OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BE A STRONGER
PART OF. I URGE A NO VOTE. NEXT
UP, I HAVE SENATOR NILO,
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR CIERTO.
SENATOR NILO, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS THIS IS WHAT
WE DO. AND I'M NOT SPEAKING TO
THE LAST MINUTE, RUSHED ASPECT
OF THIS PROPOSITION. WHAT I'M
SPEAKING TO IS THE ONE SIZE FITS
ALL. YESTERDAY I SPOKE ABOUT
EARTHQUAKE STANDARDS FOR
HOSPITALS. I COULD COME UP WITH
MANY MORE EXAMPLES. A ONE RATHER
PERVERSE DEFINITION OF POLITICS
IS LOOKING FOR PROBLEMS. FINDING
THEM EVERYWHERE AND APPLYING ALL
THE WRONG SOLUTIONS. NOW THAT'S
NOT EXACTLY WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE. WE'RE NOT NECESSARILY
LOOKING FOR PROBLEMS, BUT WE SEE
A PROBLEM IN A PARTICULAR AREA
AND WE SOLVE THAT PROBLEM FOR
THAT PARTICULAR AREA, AND WE
APPLY IT TO THE WHOLE STATE,
WHETHER IT APPLIES OR NOT. AND I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THERE IS
STRONG EVIDENCE THAT THIS BILL,
THIS PROPOSAL, THE DETAILS HERE
DO NOT EQUALLY APPLY TO EVERY
AREA OF THE STATE. I'VE HEARD
COMMENTS ABOUT ALLOWING FOR
LOCAL CONTROL, BUT I ALSO HEARD
THE COMMENT THAT WE ARE APPLYING
SOME REASONABLE STANDARDS WHERE
MOST PRESUMABLY LOCALS, WANT NO
STANDARDS AT ALL, AND THE
SPECIFIC STATEMENT THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE FAILED. NOW,
MAYBE THAT'S WHY THEY WERE
EXCLUDED FROM THE DISCUSSIONS
AND WITH REGARD TO MY
COLLEAGUES, MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO IS COMMENT ABOUT A
BALANCED APPROACH. HOW IN THE
HECK CAN YOU HAVE A BALANCED
APPROACH WHEN YOU COMPLETELY
ELIMINATE ONE OF THE MAJOR
STAKEHOLDERS THAT'S AFFECTED BY
THE POLICY? I WOULD URGE Ó AND
ALSO WITH REGARD TO THE COMMENT
ABOUT MY COLLEAGUE FROM MENLO
PARK WHO SAYS THAT HE HAS THE
ASSURANCE BY THE AUTHOR THAT
THEY WILL WORK TO ALLOW FOR
MANUFACTURING. WELL, I JUST ADD
THAT IF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
EXCLUDED FROM THIS, WHAT'S THE
GUARANTEE THAT THAT'S GOING TO
BE REVISITED? NO ASSURANCE AT
ALL. ONE SPECIFIC THING THAT I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT, THAT PROBABLY
A LOT OF PEOPLE MIGHT NOT BE
AWARE OF, PARTICULARLY WITH
REGARD TO EFFECT ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, THE EVERY
JURISDICTION IN CALIFORNIA HAS
TO REDO THEIR CIRCULATION PLAN.
EVERY ONE. IT'S MANDATED BY THIS
BILL, EVERY JURISDICTION WITH A
GENERAL PLAN HAS TO REDO THEIR
CIRCULATION PLAN. THAT IS
ESTIMATED TO COST TENS OF OR
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
NOW, THAT'S A THAT'S A
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE, RIGHT? NØ
I FOUND A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T
REALIZE THAT IF A MANDATE CAN BE
FUNDED BY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT,
BY IMPOSING FEES, IT'S NOT A
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE THAT IS THE
CASE HERE. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO REDO THEIR
CIRCULATION PLAN AT THE COST OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF PROCESS,
AND THEY'RE NOT EVEN GOING TO BE
ABLE TO APPLY FOR A MANDATE
REIMBURSEMENT. NOW, FORGET ABOUT
THE FACT THAT, REIMBURSABLE
MANDATES ARE LARGELY IGNORED BY
THE STATE, BUT NONETHELESS, IT
IS NOT EVEN ELIGIBLE. I URGE A
NO VOTE. I URGE THAT WE STOP
LOOKING AT ONE AREA, SOLVING A
PROBLEM IN ONE AREA, APPLYING IT
TO THE ENTIRE STATE, WHETHER IT
APPLIES ELSEWHERE OR NOT. I URGE
A NO VOTE. I URGE A DIFFERENCE
IN OUR PRACTICES. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR CIERTO, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MEMBERS, I RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
IT'S ALREADY BEEN STATED ABOUT
THE LOCAL JURISDICTION VERSUS
THE STATE HAVING INTERVENTION,
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MATTER, IT
HURT MY HEART TO HEAR SOMEBODY
DESCRIBE THAT. THE OUR OUR
ANALYZED THAT SOMEHOW OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS IN THESE
AFFECTED CITIES HAVE FAILED
THEIR CITIES, I KNOW THOSE
FOLKS. I'VE SERVED WITH THEM
SINCE THE 90S, THEY HAVE WORKED
HARD TO TRY TO CREATE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN SOME OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE WAS
NONE. AND THOSE ARE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE ALWAYS STRUGGLED
BECAUSE OF THEIR LOCATION. ONE
OF THOSE COMMUNITIES WAS ABLE TO
TAP INTO THE INTEREST IN HAVING
THESE WAREHOUSES. AND THEY'RE
NOT JUST WAREHOUSES, FOLKS. THIS
IS WHERE OUR FOOD COMES FROM.
THIS IS WHERE OUR VEHICLES COME
FROM. THIS IS WHERE OUR HARDWARE
COMES FROM. WHEN YOU'RE TRYING
TO FIX THINGS AT HOME. THIS IS
WHERE ALL OF THOSE TYPE OF
THINGS THAT WE USE ON A DAY TO
DAY BASIS COME FROM, AND THE
REASON THEY'RE OUT THERE IS SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO HAVE THEM
IN SHIPPING CONTAINERS OFFSHORE
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ANY ROOM
FOR THEM IN OUR REGION. AND THIS
IS THE REGION I COME FROM. I
REPRESENT A LARGE SWATH OF THIS
AREA THAT IS BEING, THAT IS IN
QUESTION HERE. AND YES, THERE
ARE A LOT AND AS STATED EARLIER,
THE REASON IS BECAUSE WE HAVE
FREEWAYS THAT GO SOUTH, NORTH
AND HAVE ACCESS TO THE ENTIRE
WESTERN UNITED STATES. SO WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET PRODUCT TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE SITTING ON THEIR
COMPUTERS AND ARE EXPECTING AT
MORE AND MORE TO HAVE THEIR
PRODUCT BY THE NEXT DAY OR THE
DAY AFTER, THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
RESPONDING. WE'RE CREATING THAT
DEMAND, AND THEY ARE SIMPLY
RESPONDING TO IT. I WANT TO TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE CORRIDORS
WHERE THEY ARE BUILDING THESE,
THE 215 CORRIDOR USED TO BE A
TWO LANE FREEWAY OR TWO LANES ON
EACH SIDE FREEWAY. AND ALONGSIDE
THE FREEWAYS WAS SOME NOT VERY
PROLIFIC DEVELOPMENT, AND THAT'S
WHERE THESE ARE GOING IN.
THEY'RE GOING INTO THE AREAS
THAT WEREN'T DEVELOPED AND THE
HOUSING THAT THEY ARE REPLACING
WHEN THEY BUY THOSE PROPERTIES
FROM THOSE PROPERTY OWNERS IS
HOUSING THAT, ACCORDING TO OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE EFFORTS,
WE DON'T WANT THERE BECAUSE IT'S
RIGHT NEXT TO THE FREEWAY. WHEN
THESE WAREHOUSES CAME IN, THE
215 FREEWAY GOT EXPANDED TO
THREE LANES, AND IT HAS SEVERAL
OVERPASSES AND INTERCHANGES THAT
IT DIDN'T HAVE BEFORE. AND SOME
OF THE ARTERIALS THROUGH THOSE
VERY IMPACTED COMMUNITIES THAT
WERE ALREADY IMPACTED ARE NOW
IMPROVED. A GREAT DEAL, WHICH IS
HELPING THE CIRCULATION AND
MEANS A LOT MORE. WE NEED MORE
INVESTMENT OUT THERE AND IN OUR
CIRCULATION, BUT THAT ALSO
ENABLES US TO PUT NEIGHBORHOODS
AND BUILD NEIGHBORHOODS IN AREAS
WHERE NEIGHBORHOODS SHOULD BE
BUILT. SO THERE IS A LOT OF, YOU
KNOW, THERE'S BEEN A LOT SAID
ABOUT THAT, THAT ISSUE IN
PARTICULAR, BUT THERE'S ALSO
BEEN A LOT SAID ABOUT THE AIR
QUALITY OUT THERE. I GREW UP IN
POMONA, WALNUT VALLEY, AND THIS
THIS WHOLE REGION, THAT WHOLE
FOOTHILL CORRIDOR. IF YOU LOOK
IT UP, THE REASON WE HAVE BAD
AIR QUALITY OUT THERE AND HAVE
SINCE THE 1960S AND 70S LONG
BEFORE WAREHOUSES CAME IN, IS
BECAUSE OF THE PREVAILING WINDS,
WHICH MEANS THE ONSHORE WINDS
COME IN FROM THE LA AREA AND
BLOW ALL THE SMOG INTO OUR
BASIN. AND IT'S TRAPPED BY THE
HILLS AND IT'S CAPTURED BY AN
INVERSION LAYER. THAT'S WHY IT'S
SMOGGY OUT THERE, ALWAYS HAS
BEEN. AND YES, IT'S TERRIBLE.
THE BEST DAYS FOR US HAVE WERE
SANTA ANA WIND DAYS, BECAUSE IT
WOULD BLOW ALL THE STUFF OUT
OVER THE OCEAN. SO THIS ISN'T
THE REASON THAT THERE'S BAD AIR
OUT THERE, AND IN FACT, IT CAN
HELP US HAVE BETTER AIR OUT
THERE BECAUSE THE PEOPLE THAT
WORK CLOSER TO THEIR HOMES DON'T
HAVE TO COMMUTE BECAUSE IT WAS
PREVAILING WINDS. AND THE SECOND
REASON WAS COMMUTER TRAFFIC. AS
WE EXPAND OUR HOUSING OUT INTO
OUR REGION, WE NEED JOBS OUT
THERE. WE NEED THE JOBS FROM THE
WAREHOUSES. WE NEED THE JOBS
FROM THE DEVELOPMENT, THE
COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENT THAT GOES
OUT THERE AND THE MANUFACTURING.
BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET THOSE
IF WE INTERVENE IN OUR LOCAL
AGENCIES EFFORTS, WHETHER IT'S A
COUNTY OR A CITY, TO BE ABLE TO
MITIGATE THE ISSUES THAT THEIR
CONSTITUENTS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT.
A ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
DOES NOT WORK. THE LAST THING I
WANT TO ONCE AGAIN MENTION IS,
YES, I WAS AT THAT HEARING ALSO
AND WHAT HAPPENS UP IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF OR OVER ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF OUR HILLS IS MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT HAPPENS IN
OUR REGION. AND IF WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE AN HONEST DISCUSSION AND
CONSIDER ALL OF THESE IMPACTS,
INCLUDING THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS
OF THESE REGIONS, IT'S IMPORTANT
TO HAVE THE INPUT FROM THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE GROUND. IF
YOU DON'T THINK THEIR PLANNERS
ARE BEING RESPONSIBLE, MAYBE YOU
SHOULD HAVE THOSE PLANNERS AT
THE TABLE TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
BUT I CAN GUARANTEE YOU, NONE OF
THE PLANNERS ON OUR SIDE OF THE
HILL WERE WERE CONSULTED ABOUT
THIS EFFORT THIS YEAR. FOLKS,
LOCAL CONTROL IS IMPORTANT. THEY
KNOW WHAT THEIR ECONOMICS ARE.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEIR STREET
CIRCULATION NEEDS TO BE. THEY
KNOW WHAT IMPROVEMENTS NEED TO
BE MADE. THEY KNOW WHAT
LANDSCAPE NEEDS TO BE PUT IN.
AND I CAN TELL YOU FROM
EXPERIENCE, WATCHING THIS AREA
DEVELOP FOR THE LAST 30 YEARS,
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN DONE RIGHT BY
THOSE VERY PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING
CRITICIZED AS HAVING NOT NOT
BEEN DOING THINGS RIGHT. NO,
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING THINGS
RIGHT. THEY'VE BEEN GROWING
THEIR ECONOMY. THEY'VE BEEN
PROVIDING JOBS, AND THEY'VE BEEN
ENABLING DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING
AWAY FROM OUR FREEWAY CORRIDORS.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE DOING. SO I WOULD URGE
EVERYONE TO CONSIDER THIS VERY
CAREFULLY IF THIS WAS YOUR
REGION, WOULD YOU WANT THIS TO
BE IMPOSED ON YOUR AREA? I URGE
A NO VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
CIERTO SEEING NO FURTHER
MICROPHONES UP. SENATOR LIMÓN,
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU MEMBERS
I APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. AND I DO THINK THAT THE
MAGNITUDE OF DISCUSSION IS
REFLECTIVE OF THIS ISSUE IN
PARTICULAR. AND THE IMPACTS IT
HAS FROM ALL OVER THE STATE,
BECAUSE WE'VE HEARD FROM MEMBERS
REPRESENTING VERY DIFFERENT
PARTS OF OUR STATE. THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF TALK ABOUT THE PROCESS
OF GIVING INPUT. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I REFLECT ON IS THAT
AS LEGISLATORS, THE NUMBER ONE
WAY THAT WE CAN GIVE INPUT OR
CREATE A PUBLIC PROCESS IS BY
CARRYING A BILL. WHEN I GOT HERE
IN 2016, I LOOKED AT WHAT SOME
OF THE ISSUES WERE THAT WERE
IMPORTANT. TODAY, I REFLECT ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE AND I FIND
THAT 15 BILLS WERE INTRODUCED IN
THIS SPACE. RELATED TO HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES, LAND USE IMPACTED
BY WAREHOUSES. VERY FEW. AS A
MATTER OF FACT, ONLY ONE OF
THOSE BECAME LAW. SO AT LEAST IN
THE EIGHT YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE,
15 BILLS IN, WE HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO GET PAST THE STATUS QUO.
THE STATUS QUO IS NOTHING RIGHT
NOW. THERE IS NO FLOOR ON WHAT
THE BASIC REQUIREMENTS SHOULD BE,
AND BOTH SIDES THAT OPPOSE THIS
THAT COME FROM VERY DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES, BELIEVE THAT THE
STATUS QUO IS BETTER. THAT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT. MEMBERS
BECAUSE FOR ALL OF US THAT WANT
TO HAVE INPUT, WE'VE HAD THE
CAPACITY TO RAISE THIS ISSUE
THROUGH LEGISLATION TO WORK ON
THIS, AND WE FIND OURSELVES IN A
SPACE WHERE WE NOW HAVE A BILL
IN FRONT OF US THAT I THINK
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US CAN FIND,
SOMETHING WE DON'T LIKE.
CERTAINLY AS A MEMBER THAT HAS
CARRIED STRONG ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE LEGISLATION, THIS IS
HARD FOR ME. IT IS HARD AND
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO BE HERE. BUT
I ALSO KNOW THAT EIGHT YEARS IN
15 BILLS AND QUITE FRANKLY,
THREE AUTHORS THAT HAVE CARRIED
THOSE 15 BILLS, THIS IS WHERE WE
ARE AT. I WANT TO POINT EVERYONE
TO SECTION 65.0935, SECTIONS A
AND B OF THIS BILL THAT STATE
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
EXCEED THE EXPECTATIONS OF THIS
BILL. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS STILL
HAVE TO APPROVE WAREHOUSES. IT
DOESN'T TAKE AWAY THEIR
AUTHORITY TO DECIDE. I AGREE
THAT THERE ARE AREAS
COMMUNITIES, CITIES, COUNTIES
THAT HAVE A GREAT MAJORITY OF
WAREHOUSES BETWEEN NOW AND THE
NEXT EIGHT YEARS WHEN WE MIGHT
GET SOMETHING ON THE TABLE. I
CAN ALSO GUARANTEE THAT WE WILL
HAVE MORE WAREHOUSES. THIS
ALLOWS FOR A FLOOR. IT DOES NOT
SET THE CEILING. WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT JOBS AND THE WAY THAT JOBS
ARE IMPACTED. THIS IS ALSO ABOUT
ENSURING THAT THOSE WHO DO THE
JOBS THAT CARE ABOUT ALL OF THIS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO KNOW WHAT'S
AHEAD OF THEM, AND THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE SUCH STRONG LABOR SUPPORT
FOR THIS. WE'VE TALKED AGAIN
ABOUT THE PLANS AND HOW LONG
IT'S GOING TO TAKE CITIES TO
COME UP WITH TRANSPORTATION
CORRIDORS. WE'VE ALIGNED THIS
BILL WITH WHAT THEY'RE ALREADY
EXPECTED REQUIREMENT IS FOR
2028. I KNOW THAT THIS IS A
DIFFICULT VOTE. I KNOW THAT THIS
IS NOT EASY BECAUSE I STAND HERE
BEFORE YOU TELLING YOU IT IS A
DIFFICULT VOTE AND IT IS NOT
EASY. BUT I ALSO STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT OVER THE EIGHT
YEARS THAT I'VE SERVED IN THIS
LEGISLATURE, THE NUMBER OF BILLS
THAT HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED, THAT
HAVE GONE THROUGH COMMITTEES AND
NOT MADE THEM OUT OR NOT MADE IT
TO THE FINISH LINE AND GOTTEN A
SIGNATURE, HAVE ALL BEEN PART OF
A DISCUSSION. THEY'VE ALL BEEN
PART OF A PUBLIC POLICY
RECOGNITION THAT SAYS WE HAVE
ISSUES. SO I STAND HERE BEFORE
YOU, AND I KNOW WE'RE ALL GOING
TO HAVE TO MAKE A DIFFICULT
DECISION, BUT I STAND HERE
BEFORE YOU ASKING FOR AN I VOTE
BECAUSE I TRULY BELIEVE THAT THE
EVIDENCE WE HAVE OVER THE LAST
EIGHT YEARS THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS POLICY ISSUE IS
THAT THIS IS WHERE WE ARE AT.
THE AUTHORS HAVE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO THINK ABOUT THIS
LEGISLATION PASSED TODAY. WE
DON'T HAVE THE EVIDENCE THAT THE
STATUS QUO OF NOTHING, OF NO
FLOOR, NO STANDARDS, NO
REGULATION IS BETTER THAN WHAT
WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US MEMBERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OAN. ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. NØ ATKINS I. BECKER. AYE
BLAKE. SPEER. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. I. CORTEZ I. DALLEY.
NÓ DODD. DURAZO I EGGMAN. NO.
GLASER NO. GONZALEZ GROVE. NO
DOTTO. NO. JONES NO. NO. LAIRD I
LIMON I MCGUIRE. I MENGIBAR. NO
MIN. NEWMAN NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO.
BOGUE. NO PADILLA I PORTANTINO I
ROTH. RUBIO NO SATO. NO. SKINNER
I CUEVAS, I STERN. UMBERG I
WAHAB. WIENER I WILK. NO. CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS, PLEASE.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA I
BLAKE SPEAR. BRADFORD. DODD
GONZALEZ. I MIN I NEWMAN. NO
ROTH. STERN WAHAB. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL
BLAKE. SPEAR. I BRADFORD. DODD
NO. ROTH STERN. WAHAB. SEN.
LEMON MOVES A CALL. LET'S SEE.
HOW DO WE DO? FIRST VOTE. YOU.
YOU WON! YOU WON. OKAY, NOW.
MEMBERS SH, FOLKS, WE'RE GOING
TO. WE'D LIKE TO ASK ALL
SENATORS TO REMAIN HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO DO A
FEW MECHANICAL PAPERWORK ISSUES.
JUST TAKE US JUST A MINUTE OR
TWO. SO PLEASE REMAIN HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'D LIKE TO
ASK MEMBERS TO RETURN TO THEIR
SEATS. PLEASE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NOW TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
THIS IS OUR FAVORITE PART OF THE
CALENDAR BECAUSE IT'S SENATE
BILLS THAT HAVE COME BACK FOR
FINAL REVIEW. MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER
FOUR. THIS IS SENATE BILL 268. I
DON'T SEE. ALL RIGHT. NO RUNNING
IN THE CHAMBER. ALL RIGHT. LET'S
CALL UP FILE ITEM FOR SB 268.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 268 BY SENATOR ALVARADO
GILL. AN ACT RELATING TO CRIMES.
SENATOR ALVARADO GILL, THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL 268. WE WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT RAPE, A SERIOUS
AND VIOLENT FELONY. I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE
SENSITIVE TO THIS TOPIC HAVE THE
ABILITY TO STEP OUT IF NEEDED.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL,
AND IT IS BACK TO US ON
CONCURRENCE. SENATE BILL 268
WILL MAKE ALL FORMS OF RAPE,
INCLUDING THAT OF AN UNCONSCIOUS
PERSON, A VIOLENT FELONY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, RAPE IS ALREADY A
VIOLENT FELONY. WHEN
ACCOMPLISHED BY FORCE. THIS BILL
WOULD MEMORIALIZE IN LAW THAT
DRUGGING SOMEONE AND TAKING AWAY
THEIR ABILITY TO CONSENT IS, IN
FACT, A FORM OF FORCE. I WOULD
LIKE TO POINT YOU TO PEOPLE
VERSUS LEWIS, WHICH WAS DECIDED
IN JUNE OF 2023 BY A70 VOTE.
THIS IS A I WANT TO SPEAK TO THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY.
OKAY. CORRECT. OKAY CORRECT, IN
THIS CASE, IT'S CENTERED AROUND
A WOMAN WHO WAS DRUGGED IN A
BAR. SHE WAS KIDNAPED AND SHE
WAS RAPED. THE VICTIM WAS
DRUGGED, SO HER COGNITIVE
ABILITIES WERE IMPAIRED. SHE
WALKED OUT OF THAT BAR WITH THE
DEFENDANT INSTEAD OF PHYSICALLY
BEING FORCED OUT OF THAT BAR.
SHE WALKED. THE DEFENDANT ARGUED
THAT IF HE DID NOT USE PHYSICAL
FORCE TO KIDNAP THE VICTIM, BUT
INSTEAD USED DECEPTION, AND IN
THIS RULING, THE COURT RULED
THAT USING DECEPTION TO KIDNAP
SOMEONE WHO WAS MENTALLY
INCAPACITATED IS THE SAME AS
USING FORCE. SENATOR, I JUST
WANT TO ASK YOU AGAIN TO PLEASE
SPEAK TO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. YES, MADAM. MR.
PRESIDENT, THANK YOU. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS DO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES AND ADD
SEVERAL COAUTHORS TO THIS BILL.
THIS COURT CASE HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN UNDERSTANDING
WHY THIS BILL IS SO IMPORTANT.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON IT FOR TWO
YEARS. WE'VE GOTTEN QUITE A BIT
OF SUPPORT WITHOUT A SPONSOR AND
WITHOUT THE ENDORSEMENTS OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS OR ANY OF THE
AFFINITY CAUCUSES. I DO WANT TO
THANK THE PROBLEM SOLVERS CAUCUS
FOR SPONSORING THIS BILL, AND
URGE AN AYE VOTE MEMBERS, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE. IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 40. NØ ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. THIS IS SENATE BILL 892
BY SENATOR PADILLA. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. THE.
SENATE BILL 892 BY SENATOR
PADILLA. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC CONTRACTS SWIMMING
UPSTREAM. SENATOR PADILLA. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, SB 892 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY ADDED THE
REQUIREMENT FOR A DETAILED
EQUITY ASSESSMENT AT THE REQUEST
OF THE CITY OF SAN JOSE
APPROPRIATIONS GAVE THE
DEPARTMENT UNTIL JANUARY 1ST,
2027, TO DEVELOP THE REGULATIONS
AND REQUIRES ANY PROCUREMENT
AFTER THAT TO INCLUDE THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL. IT
REQUIRES THAT PROCUREMENT
STANDARD DOES NOT AFFECT NOT
CONFLICT WITH REGULATIONS
ADOPTED BY THE PRIVACY AGENCY.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO NO
VOTES. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. MEMBERS. ANYONE WANT
TO BE HEARD ON THIS MEASURE? IT
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES
40. NØ ZERO. THE MEASURE. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
ALL RIGHT. LET ME CORRECT THAT
ON THE LAST ITEM. FILE ITEM
SEVEN. THAT'S A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL OF 38 TO 0. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM EIGHT.
THIS IS SB 1450. HOLD ON. WE ARE
ONCE AGAIN WE'RE FASTER THAN OUR
COMPUTERS. SO JUST A MOMENT.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE UP WITH FILE
ITEM EIGHT. THIS IS SB 1456.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1456 BY SENATOR ASHBY AND
ACT RELATING TO PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION. THEREFORE,
SENATOR ASHBY. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SB 1456 IS BACK
BEFORE US TO CONSIDER ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. THE MEASURE NOW
INCLUDES ADDITIONAL PROVISIONS
THAT STEM FROM OUR DISCUSSIONS
EARLIER THIS YEAR AND THROUGHOUT
THE PAST MANY MONTHS AS PART OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION, SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT, IT NOW ENSURES THAT
FIGHTER SAFETY BY REQUIRING ON
SITE AMBULANCES TO TRANSPORT
INJURED BOXERS, IS INCLUDED IN
THE BILL. THE COMMISSION'S WORK
IS TRULY MISSION CRITICAL.
WITHOUT THIS BILL, THE
COMMISSION WOULD EXPIRE ON
JANUARY 1ST. I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS. ANYBODY WANT TO BE
HEARD? ANY SENATOR WANT TO BE
HEARD ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OAN. AYE, GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DAWLEY AYE. DODD AYE. DARAZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN MILO. AYE TRUMBO. AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE SATO. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AL-WAHHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MIN AYE. NGUYEN. AYES 39. NO.
ZERO. THE MEASURE THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM NINE. SENATOR UMBERG. THIS
IS A SENATE BILL 42. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 42 BY
SENATOR UMBERG. AN ACT RELATING
TO COURTS AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. THIS IS A CLEANUP
BILL TO THE CARE COURT, THE CARE
COURT BILL, WHICH WAS AUTHORED
BY MY COLLEAGUES, SENATOR EGGMAN
AND MYSELF. IT'S AN URGENCY
MEASURE. IT ENSURES THAT HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS CONSIDER OTHER
ALTERNATIVES BEFORE RECOMMENDING
THE PATIENTS. CONSERVATORSHIP
UPDATES THE PROCESS BY ALLOWING
UTILIZATION OF DOCUMENTS FROM
PAST TREATMENTS, UPDATE UPDATES
THE RIGHTS ADVISEMENT PROCESS,
PROCESS, AND REQUIRES
INVESTIGATORY REPORT BY THE
COUNTY AGENCY REGARDING THE CARE
COURT PETITION TO COMPLETE IT AS
SOON AS PRACTICABLE. ALLOWS
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO
TESTIFY AS EXPERTS AND ALSO
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL NOTICE TO
PETITIONERS URGE. AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR EISENBERG.
SENATOR DURAZO. THANK YOU. IF I
MAY ASK A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
SENATOR UMBERG, WILL YOU TAKE A
QUESTION? SURE. SENATOR DURAZO.
THANK YOU. COULD YOU EXPLAIN
ABOUT THE REQUIREMENT THAT A
COURT, IF ADVISE THE RESPONDENT,
ELIMINATES THE REQUIREMENT THAT
A COURT ADVISE THE RESPONDENT OF
THEIR RIGHTS IF THE COURT FINDS
THE RESPONDENT UNDERSTANDS AND
WAIVES THAT, COULD YOU EXPLAIN
THE IMPACT THAT IT COULD HAVE ON
OR DOESN'T HAVE ON DUE PROCESS?
RIGHT. SO IF I UNDERSTAND THAT
PROVISION CORRECTLY, THAT
RELATES TO THE PETITIONER. THE
PETITIONER IS THE PERSON WHO
SUBMITS THE APPLICATION TO THE
COURT SO THAT THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS SCHIZOPHRENIC, IN MOST CASES,
IS IN ESSENCE ENROLLED IN THE
CARE COURT, AND IF THE
RESPONDENT BELIEVES THAT THAT BY
INFORMING THE PETITIONER AS TO
THE CASE STATUS, THAT THAT MAY
DO HARM. SO FOR EXAMPLE, IF THE
RESPONDENT IS, IS CONCERNED THAT
THE PETITIONER MAY DO SOMETHING
THAT MAY BE HARMFUL TO THAT
PERSON, THEN THEY CAN WAIVE ANY
SORT OF, NOTICE TO THE
PETITIONER. OKAY, AND JUST IF I
CAN ONE MORE QUESTION. THERE
WERE SOME CONCERNS RAISED TO ME
ABOUT, SAFEGUARDS, THAT COULD NØ
SAFEGUARDS THAT COULD PREVENT
PATIENTS FROM BEING
INVOLUNTARILY DETAINED. COULD
YOU RESPOND TO THAT ISSUE? I'M
NOT SURE WHAT THE GENESIS OF
THAT CONCERN IS, THIS CARE COURT
IS AN ALTERNATIVE, TYPICALLY TO
A CRIMINAL PROCESS. IT'S A CIVIL
PROCESS. AND THERE ARE
SAFEGUARDS BUILT IN TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL BASICALLY
DOESN'T, ONE GETS TREATMENT AND
TWO DOESN'T END UP BACK IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. SO I'M
NOT SURE WHAT WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO. OKAY. THAT'S FINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THAT
OBJECTION AYES 38. NÓ ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THAT'S THAT'S 38
ZERO. ON THE URGENCY, 38 ZERO.
AND THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP, FILE ITEM
TEN. THIS IS SENATE BILL 59 BY
SENATOR SKINNER. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 59 BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND ACT TO
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION.
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU,
MEMBERS AND MISTER PRESIDENT,
PLEASE TAKE UP SB 59 FOR
CONCURRENCE. THE AMENDMENTS USE
THE LANGUAGE FROM THE PREVIOUS
VERSION OF THIS BILL, SB 233,
WHICH PASSED THROUGH THIS
CHAMBER WITH STRONG SUPPORT.
FURTHER AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY MADE UPDATES TO
TECHNICAL DEFINITIONS AND
CRITERIA, AND UPDATED THE LEAD
AGENCY TO BE THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SKINNER, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON A BILL. NØ ARCHULETA. Ã
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLEY NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ GROVE. NO HURTADO. AYE.
JONES LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. NGUYEN. NO. NINO NO.
COBO NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO
NO. SKINNER A SMALL CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GONZALEZ. AYE. JONES. MCGUIRE
NEWMAN. ON A VOTE OF 29 TO 8,
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. ALL RIGHT.
MEMBERS. AN UPDATE ON OUR WORK
TONIGHT, TODAY AND TONIGHT,
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A 30 MINUTE
BREAK AT 5 P.M. WE'VE COMPLETED
OVER 30 BILLS SO FAR THIS
EVENING. WE'RE ASKING MEMBERS TO
PLEASE STAY IN THE BUILDING SO
WE MAY RESUME OUR WORK RIGHT
AFTER OUR BREAK. OKAY. THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR COOPERATION THIS
AFTERNOON AND THIS EVENING. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 11. THIS IS SB
399. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 399 BY SENATOR
WAHAB. AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR WAHAB. THANK
YOU. SB 399 IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION, ANY DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. NOT SEEING ANY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OAN I'LL GO. NØ ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. DALLEY NØ.
DODD DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE. WAYNE
NO. NILO. NO. TRUMBO. NO.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER
AYE. CUEVAS EYES TURN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. NO. SENATOR WAHAB
MOVES A CALL. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 13. THIS
IS SB 552. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 552 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO PRESENT SB 552, WHICH IS BACK
FROM THE ASSEMBLY ON CONCURRENCE
AND WHICH PROVIDES TECHNICAL
CLEANUP TO A BILL I AUTHORED IN
2017, THE CALIFORNIA SWIMMING
POOL SAFETY ACT AMENDMENTS TAKEN
IN THE ASSEMBLY WERE
NON-SUBSTANTIVE AND ADDRESSED
CHAPTER OUT CONFLICTS. FOR THESE
REASONS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DISCUSSION.
ALL RIGHT. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. OAN ALVARADO.
GILL AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR BRADFORD. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY AYE. DODD
AYE. TERRAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE.
AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. YILO. KROBO.
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO
AYE. SKINNER EYES. MOORLACH.
RIVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ASHBY. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. ON A VOTE OF 40 TO 0, THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 14. THIS
IS S. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A MOMENT. PAUSE.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM 14. THIS IS SENATE
BILL 819 BY SENATOR EGGMAN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 819 BY SENATOR EGGMAN AND
AQUILINA. MEDI-CAL SENATOR
EGGMAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. SENATORS, THE TIME
HAS ARRIVED. THIS WILL BE THE
LAST TIME I WILL RAISE THIS MIC
ON THE SENATE FLOOR. WELL, TO
PRESENT MY OWN BILL, I CAN'T
MAKE ANY PROMISES ABOUT ANYTHING
ELSE. THIS IS MY LAST BILL, SB
819. HAVING TO DO WITH MOBILE
CLINICS FOR MEDI-CAL. WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT ON THIS. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS GOT SOME
MORE TECHNICAL, AND MAYBE WE ALL
DO BILLS LIKE THIS, RIGHT? I
MEAN, THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE
FOR, TO HELP FOLKS TO MAKE
GOVERNMENT WORK AND TO SERVE OUR
CONSTITUENTS. ON THIS FINAL
BILL, I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? IT
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION. SENATOR
EGGMAN. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED. AND CONGRATULATIONS
TO YOU. ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE A TEN MINUTE
BREAK. WE ARE ASKING ALL MEMBERS
TO REMAIN HERE IN THE CHAMBERS.
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE RESTROOMS
THAT ARE CONSIDERED PART OF THE
CHAMBERS BUT REMAIN HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS. WE'LL BE BACK HERE IN
TEN MINUTES. OKAY, SO AT THE
HOUR OF 451, WE'LL BE BACK IN
SESSION. THANK YOU.
OKAY, MEMBERS, THANK YOU ALL FOR
COMING BACK TO YOUR DESKS SO WE
CAN CONTINUE WITH OUR WORK. WE
ARE. WE ARE ON UNFINISHED
BUSINESS, AND WE ARE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH IS SENATOR MENGIBAR
ON THE FLOOR? THERE SHE IS.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH ITEM
15. SB 1103. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1103 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. AN ACT
RELATING TO INTENDANCY. SENATOR
MENGIBAR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SB 1103 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AND HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY NARROWED. I TOOK
TEN SEPARATE AMENDMENTS OVER ON
THE ASSEMBLY. WE REMOVED THE
ADVANCE NOTICE PERIODS FOR
INCREASING BUILDING OPERATING
COSTS. WE REDEFINED WHAT
BUILDING OPERATING COSTS ARE. WE
TRIMMED IT DOWN TO ONLY APPLY
LANGUAGE TRANSLATION PROVISION
TO QUALIFIED COMMERCIAL TENANTS.
WE MADE CLEAR WHO THIS LAW WILL
APPLY TO. WE MADE A PROVISION
THAT REQUIRES THE COMMERCIAL
QUALIFIED TENANT TO PROVIDE THE
LANDLORD ON AN ANNUAL BASIS, A
NOTICE AND SELF-ATTESTATION OF
THEIR ENTITLEMENT, AND WE ALLOW
THE LANDLORD TO GIVE WRITTEN
NOTICE OF A CHANGE IN FORMULA OR
METHOD TO BUILDING OPERATING
COSTS, GIVING THEM MORE
FLEXIBILITY. ASKING RESPECTFULLY
FOR AN I VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, IS THERE A DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO GILL NØ ARCHULETA.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS BECKER.
BLAKESBERG BRADFORD. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALLEY NÓ. DODD
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN GLAZER.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES ANYWHERE. SENATOR.
MIN IS LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN NEWMAN.
WAYNE NO. NILO NO. COBO. NO.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO.
AYE SATO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN UMBERG.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
OAN. AYE. ARCHULETA ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. BRADFORD DODD.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. JONES
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
ROTH. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE
SEN. MENGIBAR. MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 16. THIS IS
SB 1108. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1108 BY SENATOR
OKOBOJI. AN ACT RELATING TO
MOBILE HOME PARKS. SENATOR OCHOA.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. SB
1108 IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ADDRESS A
CONFLICT WITH AB 2247 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLACE AND
INCORPORATE TECHNICAL CHANGES
REQUESTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. THESE INCLUDE
MOVING THE PROVISIONS INTO A
MORE RELEVANT CODE SECTION AND
DELAYING IMPLEMENTATION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WE HAVE
MEMBERS OFF THE FLOOR. RATS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN OBERNOLTE Ã GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE. OTERO
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MIN AYE. AYE. NEUMANN AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO AYE. TROBERG
AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO AYE.
SKINNER A SMALL. STERN AYE. I'M.
BURKE AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE SEN. OCHOA MOVES
A CALL. NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 17.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1120 BY
SENATOR BECKER. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1120 BY
SENATOR BECKER. AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. SENATOR
BECKER, THANK YOU. REYES PERCENT
ON CONCURRENCE SB 1120. THIS IS
THE PHYSICIANS MAKE DECISION ACT
OVER IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE MADE
SOME TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MEMBERS, THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 40. NO. ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP IS FILED.
ITEM 18. THIS IS SENATE BILL
1155 BY SENATOR HURTADO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1155 BY SENATOR HURTADO. AN
ACT RELATING TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF 1974. SENATOR
HURTADO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SB 1155 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCY. AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY WERE TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE. THE BILL
HAS MADE IT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION?
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. 27 VOTE BILL. SEEING
NO OBJECTIONS. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 19. SB 1170 BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1170 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. AN ACT
RELATING TO THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF 1974. SENATOR MENGIBAR.
COLLEAGUES. SB 1170 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN THE ASSEMBLY FURTHER ADDED
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. WE
RECEIVED FROM FPC, RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR NO VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALL
VOTED. GILL. NØ. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY DODD. DURAZO
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE I'M GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON MY BILL.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. NO. COBO. NO.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO SEYARTO. NØ.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLEY
NO. GROVE NO. JONES. MCGUIRE.
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. RUBIO. AYE ON A
VOTE OF 31 TO 8, THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
80. 80, 80, 80. MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO LIFT A CALL YET? CAN I
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION? WE'RE GOING
TO LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
80. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. Þ I RODA-GIL
BRADFORD. BY ROTH. STERN BY
WAHAB. I.
NOW ON A VOTE OF 22 TO 16, THE
MEASURE PASSES. GOTCHA.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO GO BACK TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS. WE'RE GOING TO ON FILE
ITEM 20. WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY. SO FILE ITEM 21 IS
SB 1281. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
YES. SENATE BILL 1281 BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR. AN ACT RELATING TO
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. SENATOR
MENGIBAR. MR. PRESIDENT, THE
MEN'S TAKING IN THE ASSEMBLY FOR
SB 1281 WERE MEANT TO NARROW THE
SCOPE AND MAINTAINS THE HEART OF
THE BILL, WHICH IS TO IMPROVE
EQUITY AMONGST THE
SELF-DETERMINATION PROGRAM AND
ALL 21 REGIONAL CENTERS.
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR A VOTE.
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE, IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 40. NØ ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 22. FILE ITEM 22 IS SB
1283. SENATOR STERN. HAS PASSED
TEMPORARILY. NEXT UP IS FILED
ITEM 23. THIS IS SB 1286 BY
SENATOR MIN. SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1286 BY
SENATOR MIN. AN ACT RELATING TO
DEBT COLLECTION. SENATOR.
SENATOR. MIN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, THIS IS
THE BILL THAT DEALS WITH
PREDATORY DEBT COLLECTION
PRACTICES. AND I JUST WANT TO
ADDRESS SOME COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE BY OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
ASSEMBLY WHO CLAIMED, I THINK,
AMONG OTHER THINGS, THAT I HAD
COMMITTED OR MY STAFF HAD
COMMITTED TO TAKING ALL OF THE
AMENDMENTS FROM THE OTHER SIDE.
AND I JUST WANT TO ITERATE THAT
THAT WAS NEVER THE CASE. WE TOOK
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS FROM PROPOSED BY
OPPOSITION AND MANY STAKEHOLDERS
SINCE THE TIME THAT THIS PASSED
OUT OF THIS BODY, INCLUDING
AMENDMENTS THAT CLARIFIED THAT
THE BILL DOES NOT CREATE ANY
ADDITIONAL LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS. AMENDMENTS THAT
CHANGE THE ELIGIBILITY THRESHOLD
OF THE BILL FROM ONE TRANSACTION
OF EQUAL OR LESS THAN 500,000 TO
AN AGGREGATE OF ALL TRANSACTIONS
ADDING UP TO EQUAL OR LESS THAN
500,000. AMENDMENTS CHANGING THE
LANGUAGE AROUND THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE, AS
REQUESTED BY OPPOSITION.
AMENDMENTS. PROVIDING GUIDANCE
ON WHERE VENUE IS APPROPRIATE
FOR JUDICIAL PROCEEDINGS RELATED
TO THIS BILL AND OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES. WE WORKED A LOT WITH
STAKEHOLDERS HERE ON THIS BILL.
WE THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL. THIS
IS OBVIOUSLY, AS YOU KNOW, A
PRODUCT OF A LOT OF DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS COMING TOGETHER. SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE ON THE
MEASURE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THE MEASURE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN Ã GILL, NÓ. ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY I. ATKINS I. BECKER I.
BLAKE. SPEER, I. BRADFORD. I.
CABALLERO I. CORTEZ I. DALLEY.
NÓ. DODD I. DURAZZO. I. EGGMAN
I. GLAESER I. VÌ GONZALEZ I.
GROVE NO. DATO I. JONES NO.
LAIRD I. LEHMAN I. MCGUIRE I.
MENGIBAR I. MIN I. NEWMAN, I.
NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO. COBO NO.
PADILLA I. PORTANTINO I. ROTH
RUBIO I. SERRATO. NO. SKINNER I.
MOORLACH. RIVAS I. STERN. I.
UMBERG I. WAHAB I. WIENER I.
WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ROTH. ON A VOTE OF 30
TO 9, THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALLS ON ITEMS 78 AND 79 TO LIFT
THE CALLS ON ITEM 78. FIRST
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GONZALEZ I.
MCGUIRE I. STERN I. UMBERG. I.
ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 9, THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO LIFTING THE CALL ON
ITEM 79. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD.
POTATO JONES. JONES. NO.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MIN AYE. RUBIO AYE. UMBERG
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBER OR DATO. ON A VOTE OF 30
TO 9, THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
24. THIS IS SB 1313. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1313 BY
SENATOR ASHBY AND AQUILINA.
VEHICLES. SENATOR ASHBY. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, AND PROUD TO
PRESENT SB 1313. BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE SAFE ROADS ACT
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS REFLECT
TERMINOLOGY AND ALIGNMENT
CLARIFICATIONS. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE. ANY
DISCUSSION IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR.
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 25. THIS IS SB 1419.
SENATOR RUBIO. SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1419 BY
SENATOR RUBIO AND AQUILINA. FOOD
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFOR. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT SB 1419, WHICH IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE WITH MINOR
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS. WE WANT TO
ENSURE OUR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTHY FOOD OPTIONS, ESPECIALLY
WITHIN FOOD DESERTS, ACROSS OUR
STATE. WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION? IT IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTIONS. AYES 40.
NÓ ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM 26 SB 1451. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1451 BY
SENATOR ASHBY, AN AQUILINE
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
SENATOR ASHBY. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SB 1451 BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL IS THE
ANNUAL BUSINESS PROFESSIONS CODE
OMNIBUS VEHICLE. THE MAJORITY OF
THE PROVISIONS IN SB 1451
REFLECT RECENT DISCUSSIONS
THROUGH THE SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT PROCESS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE THE PRODUCT OF
SIGNIFICANT SOME MIGHT SAY,
NEVER ENDING STAKEHOLDER INPUT.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL,
PARTICULARLY GIVEN NEW
PROVISIONS RECENTLY ADDED THAT I
BELIEVE ARE TIMELY AND
IMPORTANT. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ASHBY. ANY DISCUSSION,
MEMBERS, ANY DEBATE ON THIS
SUNSET BILL? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. AYE EBCLC.
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALL
GRAVERT. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA AYE. GROVE
NGUYEN. UMBERG AYE. ON A VOTE OF
38 TO 0, THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT.
ALL RIGHT. NEXT UP IS FILE 27.
THIS IS SCA ONE BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
NUMBER ONE BY SENATOR NEWMAN. AN
ACT RELATING TO ELECTIONS.
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE TO
PRESENT SCA ONE BACK ON
CONCURRENCE, WHICH WHEN PASSED,
WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA VOTERS TO
AMEND OUR STATE'S CURRENT
PROCESS FOR THE RECALL OF A
STATE LEVEL OFFICER. UNDER ITS
PROVISIONS, IN THE EVENT OF A
STATE LEVEL RECALL EFFORT WHICH
QUALIFIES FOR THE BALLOT, VOTERS
WOULD ANSWER ONE SIMPLE QUESTION
SHOULD THE ELECTED OFFICIAL IN
QUESTION BE RECALLED WITH ONE
SIMPLE ANSWER EITHER YES OR NO.
SUCH A CHANGE WILL REDUCE
INCENTIVES FOR GAMING THE RECALL
PROCESS FOR PURELY PARTIZAN
GAIN, WHILE PRESERVING THE
RECALL AS ESSENTIAL ROLE AS A
VALIDATOR OF POPULAR CONSENT AND
A TOOL FOR ENFORCING ETHICAL
ACCOUNTABILITY. AMENDMENTS TAKEN
TO THE ASSEMBLY STIPULATE THAT
THE MEASURE, WHEN PASSED BY A
TWO THIRDS VOTE OF BOTH HOUSES
OF THE LEGISLATURE, WILL APPEAR
ON THE 2026 BALLOT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU. SEN. NEWMAN.
ANY DISCUSSION, ANY DEBATE ON
THE MEASURE? SEEING NONE. THIS
IS A 27 VOTE BILL. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN A
ALVARADO GIL. NO. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. NÓ. DODD AYE.
DURAZO EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO. TUTTLE
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
MIN AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO NO. COBO NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO A ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER SMALL.
CUEVAS SKINNER. AYE. SMALL
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER. DURAZO AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 32 TO 8. 32. IN FAVOR?
EIGHT AGAINST THE ASSEMBLY.
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
SEN. MENGIBAR, COULD YOU COME TO
THE FRONT?
NOW THAT I'M UP HERE, WE'LL BE
DONE IN ONE HOUR.
WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING FILE
ITEM 20. SEN. GLAZER IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1181 BY SENATOR
GLAZER. AN ACT RELATING TO THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF 1974.
SEN. GLAZER THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDING OFFICER. REMEMBER
THIS. THIS BILL IS BACK FOR A
CONCURRENCE. IT'S A CLEANUP BILL
TO THE ORIGINAL SB 1439, WHICH
EXTENDED THE LEVINE ACT TO LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ADDRESSED ISSUES WITH
THE COMPANION BILL AND ALSO
ADJUST THE CONTRIBUTION LEVEL.
THAT WOULD BE DEEMED ACCEPTABLE
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. DO WE HAVE ANY
DEBATE ON THIS? ON THIS ITEM?
SEEING NO. THIS IS A 27 VOTE
BILL. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
THIS IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 40. NO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE TAKING A
QUICK PAUSE.
OKAY, MEMBERS, I FORGOT TO
MENTION THAT WAS THE LAST BILL I
WAS PRESENTING. WAS THERE AN
APPLAUSE OR ANYTHING? THAT'S OUT
OF ORDER. THERE'S NO APPLAUSE.
ALL RIGHT. OKAY I KNOW THAT.
MEMBERS. IT'S 531. WE ARE
BREAKING FOR DINNER. WE'RE GOING
TO BE BACK HERE AT 601 ON THE
DOT. ON THE DOT. WE ASK THAT
MEMBERS DON'T LEAVE THE
BUILDING. WE'RE GOING TO BE BACK
HERE AT 601. SENATOR MENGIBAR IS
GOING TO ENSURE THAT SHE'S GOING
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE IN RECESS.
MEMBERS. THE SENATE WILL CONVENE
IN 30S MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
INVITE ALL THE SENATORS TO COME
BACK TO THE FLOOR. BACK TO THEIR
DESKS, PLEASE.
Þ. OKAY. THANK YOU. MEMBERS.
THANK YOU, SENATORS, FOR BEING
BACK AND ON TIME. WE ARE READY
TO GET GOING. SHH. LET ME GIVE
YOU THE ORDER. AT LEAST THE
LIKELY ORDER OF BILLS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR OVER THE NEXT FEW
MINUTES. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH FILE ITEM 75, FOLLOWED BY
FILE ITEM 72, 73, 74, 77 AND 84.
OKAY. ALL SUBJECT TO CHANGE, SO
KEEP PAYING ATTENTION. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. FIRST UP THEN IS FILE ITEM
70. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1252.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1252 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WIX. AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS OVER THE LAST 30 YEARS,
CALIFORNIA HAS SET THE STANDARD
AND DEMONSTRATING THAT STRONG
GUN SAFETY LAWS CAN SAVE LIVES
IN THREE DECADES. WE'VE SEEN OUR
STATE GO FROM HAVING THE THIRD
HIGHEST GUN DEATH RATE IN THE
NATION TO THE SEVENTH LOWEST.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1252 REPRESENTS
ANOTHER IMPORTANT STEP IN THIS
EFFORT. THIS BILL ENSHRINES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE OF GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION IN STATUTE,
GUARANTEEING THAT ITS CRITICAL
WORK CONTINUES BEYOND ANY SINGLE
ADMINISTRATION. VITALLY, THE
LEGISLATION ALSO REQUIRES THE
OFFICE TO RELEASE A
GROUNDBREAKING REPORT BY JULY
1ST, 2026 THAT WILL ADDRESS GAPS
IN OUR FIREARM TRACING SYSTEM,
HELP US ENHANCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF EXISTING LAWS,
AND PROVIDE ACTIONABLE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS REMAIN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF GUN SAFETY
INNOVATION. AB 1252 IS ALSO
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE. IT
CLARIFIES THAT THE OFFICE CAN
ACCESS EXISTING FUNDING STREAMS
UP TO 2.5 MILLION ALLOCATED
UNDER THE REVENUE AND TAXATION
CODE, REDUCING ANY BURDEN ON THE
STATE'S GENERAL FUND.
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS IN
PREVENTING GUN VIOLENCE IS NO
EXCUSE TO REST IN THE
SATISFACTION OF WHAT WE'VE
ACCOMPLISHED IN FACT, IT IS A
FURTHER CALL TO ACTION AND A
SIGN OF WHAT IS POSSIBLE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION? SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP. SECRETARY, CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. I ALRP GILL.
NO. ARCHULETA. I ASHBY I ATKINS,
I BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER. I
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I CORTEZ.
DALLEY. NÓ. DODD I THOUGHT ALSO
I EGGMAN I GLASER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE. NO DARROW. JONES LAIRD I
LOWMAN I MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MIN
I NEWMAN. I NGUYEN MILO. NO COBO.
NO. PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH,
I RUBIO, I SEYARTO. SKINNER
SMALL. CUEVAS STERN. I UMBERG. I
WAHAB. I WIENER. I WILK. NO.
MOVING. YEAH. WE'RE SEN. BLAKE.
SPEER MOVES A CALL. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM 72. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2471. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2471
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM
PATTERSON. AN ACT RELATING TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
SENATOR MILO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU. AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2471 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN
JIM PATTERSON. CURRENTLY
REGISTERED NURSES ARE REQUIRED
TO PAY A NONREFUNDABLE FEE FOR
THE EVALUATION OF THEIR
QUALIFICATIONS TO USE THE TITLE
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE. THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO THEIR REGULAR
REGISTERED NURSE LICENSE RENEWAL
THAT THEY ALREADY COMPLETE EVERY
TWO YEARS. SB 2471 WOULD REPEAL
THIS REQUIREMENT FOR THE
QUALIFICATIONS OF PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSE, AND IT WOULD ALSO REMOVE
A PENALTY FEE THAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS FOR NOT RENEWING THAT
CERTIFICATE. THIS IS SUPPORTED
BY THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING. IT DOES NOT HAVE ANY NÓ
VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTIONS.
AYES 39. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 73.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3024.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3024 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD. AN ACT RELATING TO CIVIL
LAW AND DECLARING THE URGENCY
THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR ALLEN, THE
FLOOR MANAGER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD TO PRESENT AB 3024, A
JEWISH CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL
ADDRESSING THE FORM OF
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
KNOWN AS HATE LITTERING. LAST
YEAR, THE ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE
RECORDED A 38% RISE IN HATE
MOTIVATED PROPAGANDA EFFORTS,
INCLUDING THE PRACTICE OF
TARGETING A VICTIM'S PERSONAL
PROPERTY WITH RACIST,
ANTI-SEMITIC OR ANTI-LGBTQ+
FLIERS THAT MAKE THEM FEAR FOR
THEIR SAFETY. THIS HAS RAPIDLY
BECAME A PREFERRED TACTIC OF
HATE GROUPS, NOT ONLY FOR ITS
PERSONAL AND EFFECTIVE NATURE,
QUITE LITERALLY HITTING CLOSE TO
HOME, BUT ALSO BECAUSE IT EXISTS
IN A LEGAL GRAY AREA, MAKING IT
EXTREMELY HARD FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO PROSECUTE. WHILE
CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE SOME OF THE
STRONGEST HATE CRIME STATUTES IN
THE COUNTRY, THESE ACTIVITIES
OFTEN DO NOT RISE TO THE
THRESHOLD OF A HATE CRIME OR
TRIGGER CALIFORNIA'S ANTI-HATE
PROHIBITIONS ON CONDUCT, SUCH AS
CROSS BURNING. AS A STATE, WE
MUST RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
MATERIALS ARE NOT JUST PIECES OF
PAPER OR EXPRESSIONS OF FREE
SPEECH. THEY ARE DIRECT THREATS
PLACED ON THE PERSONAL PROPERTY
OF TARGETED MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH THE INTENTION
TO HARASS, INTIMIDATE AND
DEHUMANIZE. THIS ACT WILL MAKE
NECESSARY IMPROVEMENTS TO
EXISTING LAW BY STRENGTHENING
THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF 1976 TO
ENSURE VICTIMS ARE PROVIDED
ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS AGAINST
HATE LITTERING, CREATING NEW
LEGAL TOOLS TO HOLD OFFENDERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ACTS OF HATE
HAVE NO PLACE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENSURE THAT
OUR NEIGHBORS AND LOVED ONES ARE
FREE FROM HATE RELATED VIOLENCE
IN ANY FORM, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ALLEN. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE. THIS
IS A 27 VOTE BILL. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN VÌ
ALVARADO TO GIL ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DALLEY DODD I DURAZO.
DURAZO EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HURTADO I
JONES. LAIRD I LEMON I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN. I
NGUYEN MILO. OKOBO I PADILLA. I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO. RUBIO
I SATO. SKINNER I SMALL. CUEVAS
I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB I
WIENER I WILK. WE HAVE A FULL
HOUSE MEMBERS SO WE'RE GOING TO
CALL THROUGH THE ROLL ONE MORE
TIME. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. I'LL GO. TALLY
TERRAZZO GROVE. JONES MCGUIRE.
NGUYEN. NILO SEYARTO. WILK AYES
30. NO. ZERO. ON THE URGENCY.
AYES 30. NO. ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
74. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2795.
SENATE FLOOR MANAGER MENGIBAR IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
THE. READ THE MEASURE. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2795 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA. AN ACT RELATING TO THE
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES. SENATOR
WIENER, CAN YOU STEP TO THE
SIDE, PLEASE? SENATOR MENGIBAR,
AS YOU KNOW, THIS IS A SUPPORT.
SUPPORT. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
ABSOLUTELY. THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT MEMBERS OF TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES RECEIVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO CALWORKS SEEKING CARE
AT THE INDIAN HEALTH CLINIC,
RESPECTFULLY ASKING, AND I VOTE.
MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 39. NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 77. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2243. THE FLOOR
MANAGER, SENATOR WIENER
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ THE READ
THE MEASURE. ASSEMBLY BILL 2243
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS. AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING. SENATOR
WIENER, THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2243 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS, THE BILL
CLARIFIES AND EXPANDS AB 2011.
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HIGH
ROADS JOBS ACT OF 2022, WHICH
ALLOWS FOR THE STREAMLINED
DEVELOPMENT OF MULTIFAMILY
INFILL HOUSING IN AREAS ZONED
FOR RETAIL, OFFICE AND PARKING
LOTS. BY RIGHT, PROVIDED THAT
DEVELOPERS PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON SITE AND PAY THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS BUILDING
THE PROJECT. THE PREVAILING
WAGE, WE KNOW THAT THIS APPROACH
WORKS IN THE 13 MONTHS SINCE AB
2011 WAS ENACTED, THOUSANDS OF
UNITS HAVE ALREADY BEEN APPROVED
AND OVER TWO THIRDS OF THEM ARE
BEING BUILT BY UNION WORKERS.
YET, SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF AB
2011, THE HOUSING CRISIS HAS
ONLY GOTTEN WORSE FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS. AND WE'VE ALSO SEEN
SOME ASPECTS OF THE LAW THAT
NEED TO BE TIGHTENED AND
CLARIFIED. SO THIS BILL WILL DO
THAT. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
WIENER. ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OAN
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA
HØI. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. AYE BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ DALLY. AYE. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. LIMÓN MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR MEN. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN
MILLER. TROBERG. AYE PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. SKINNER A SMALL.
CUEVAS STERN. AYE. UMBERG WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK WE HAVE
MEMBERS OFF THE FLOOR. SENATOR
WEINER MOVES THE CALL. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
84. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3264.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3264 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND AQUILINA.
ENERGY. SENATOR DODD. MR.
PRESIDENT, SENATORS, I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
3264 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS A BILL TO
ADDRESS ENERGY AFFORDABILITY.
THIS SUITE OF SOLUTIONS WILL SET
THE STAGE FOR US TO LOWER BILLS
FOR EVERYONE AND PUT MORE MONEY
BACK IN THE POCKETS OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. THIS BILL
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE. YEAH, WE STILL HAVE
MEMBERS OFF THE FLOOR. SO WE'RE
GOING TO CALL THE ROLL ONCE AND
PUT THE MEASURE ON CALL.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I BROUGHT A BILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. HI. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY AYE. DODD DARAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE. LEMON
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
NEELO AYE. AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. AYE SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE.
SAU. SHE WALKED OUT.
SENATOR DODD MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER
ONE. ONE SHOULD HAVE A COPY OF
THAT. WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN AT
THE TOP. THIS IS FILE ITEM 85.
SENATE BILL 219. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 219 BY
SENATOR WIENER. AN ACT RELATING
TO GREENHOUSE GASES. SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, SB 219 WHICH I AM
JOINT AUTHORING WITH THE SENATOR
FROM LOS ANGELES. SENATOR STERN
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. SB 219
MAKES A NUMBER OF TECHNICAL
CLEANUP AMENDMENTS TO SB 253.
THE CLIMATE CORPORATE DATA
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT AND SB 261,
THE CLIMATE FINANCIAL RISK ACT,
WHICH WE PASSED AND WHICH WERE
SIGNED INTO LAW LAST YEAR, IN
ADDITION TO TECHNICAL CHANGES,
SB 219 EXTENDS THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD DEADLINE TO
COMPLETE A RULEMAKING PROCESS BY
SIX MONTHS, WHILE LEAVING FULLY
LEAVING INTACT THE TIMELINES FOR
DISCLOSURES. SB 219 HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE? ANY
SENATOR WANT TO BE HEARD ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OAN AYE,
GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE LIMON. AYE MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN.
NO MILO. EBCLC. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. NO. SKINNER A SMALL
CUEVAS. AYE STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE. SEN. WIENER. MOVES A
CALL. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 86. SB 440 BY
SENATOR SKINNER. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 480 BY
SENATOR SKINNER. AND ACCORDING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS SB 440 IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE. IT ALLOWS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO SO CHOOSE
TO JOIN TOGETHER TO FORM
REGIONAL HOUSING AUTHORITIES TO
HELP FINANCE AFFORDABLE AND
MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING IN THEIR
REGIONS. THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY SUCCESSFULLY
REMOVED THE OPPOSITION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS, AND IT
ALSO ADDRESSED THE CONCERNS OF
THE COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
TREASURERS AND TAX COLLECTORS.
AND WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. MEMBERS.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE. GILL.
NO. ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLEY. NO. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE. LEMON
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. ROD
I. RUBIO AYE. SATO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. NO. SENATOR SKINNER
MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 87. THIS IS SB 695 BY
SENATOR RUBIO. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 690 BY SENATOR
RUBIO AND ACT RELATING TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE, TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
SB 690, WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AFTER TAKING
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY TO
LOWER THE YEARS FROM 15 TO 7
YEARS THAT A VICTIM CAN SEEK
JUSTICE. UNFORTUNATELY, MANY
BELIEVE THAT THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATION IS ABOUT
INCARCERATING PEOPLE OR
PERPETRATORS RATHER. BUT IN THE
END, REALLY, THIS IS ABOUT
PROTECTING VICTIMS. USUALLY WHEN
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATION.
EXPIRES, PERPETRATORS FIND WAYS
OF HARASSING VICTIMS WHERE AND
WHEN THEY ACTUALLY HAVE THE
COURAGE TO COME FORWARD. THE
TIME HAS EXPIRED AND THEY WILL
ENDURE A LIFETIME OF HARASSMENT
BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING THAT
THEY CAN DO. WE MUST ALLOW A
SUFFICIENT TIME FOR VICTIMS TO
HEAL AND RECOVER AND SEEK
JUSTICE. AND I HOPE THAT SOMEDAY
WE CAN SEE THIS IN THIS
BUILDING. THANK YOU. WITH THAT,
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. OKAY, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE? I
WANT TO REMIND MEMBERS TO SPEAK
TO THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON BY BILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE DALY.
AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE. LEMON.
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN.
AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE
MILO. AYE. DROBO. AYE. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER. AYE
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. SENATOR RUBIO MOVES A
CALL. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 88. THIS IS SENATE
BILL 954. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 954 BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR. AN ACT RELATING TO
SEXUAL HEALTH. SENATOR MENGIBAR.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. SB 954
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. AMENDMENTS
CLARIFIED THAT THERE IS FUNDING
IN THE BUDGET AND MOVE
JURISDICTION AND ALLOW
JURISDICTION UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MATTER? ANY DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN AYE. I'LL GO. NO.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. I BLAKE.
SPEAR. I BRADFORD. I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ. I DALI. NØ DODD. I
LAZO I EGGMAN, I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HURTADO I
JONES. LAIRD I LIMON I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN. I
NGUYEN. NO NILO. NO. TROBOK. NO
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO. NO. SKINNER I
SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I
WAHAB I WIENER I WILK. SENATOR
MENGIBAR MOVES A CALL. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM 90. THIS IS. YES.
YOUR NAME WAS CALLED. SO YOU'LL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. IT'S ON
CALL. WE'LL BRING IT BACK. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM 90.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1243 BY
SENATOR DODD. SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1070 BY
SENATOR PADILLA. AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS. WE'RE
SKIPPING THIS ONE. WE'RE
SKIPPING THIS ONE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM 90, SB 1243, SENATE BILL
1243 BY SENATOR DODD. AN ACT
RELATING TO THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF 1974. SENATOR DODD. MR.
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. THIS BILL
STARTED OUT THE YEAR WITH MUCH
FANFARE AND DRAMA, BUT SB 1243
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY
WERE A RESULT OF COMPROMISE
REACHED BETWEEN ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS. ALL OPPOSITION HAS REMOVED TO SUPPORT OR
NEUTRAL. RESPECTFULLY THANK YOU,
SENATOR DODD. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE MEASURE? WE HAVE A
FULL HOUSE. Dð 1638 39. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL? THERE IS AN
OBJECTION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. I'LL GO. Ã ARCHULETA.
Ã. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS BECKER.
AYE. AYE. BLAKESBERG I. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALI AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO AYE.
JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN.
AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE MIN.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO
AYE. OKOBO. AYE PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO. AYE SKINNER.
AZEMAR. CUEVAS EYES TURN. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ADKINS. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. MCGUIRE. MIN AYE.
I'M CERTAINLY GLAD WE DIDN'T USE
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. AYES
39. NOS ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM 91. THIS IS SB 1303.
SECRETARY SECRETARY. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1303 BY
SENATOR CABALLERO. AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC WORKS.
SENATOR CABALLERO. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. SB 1303 IS BACK
FROM THE ASSEMBLY ON
CONCURRENCE. THE BILL WAS
AMENDED TO MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES AND REDUCE COSTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
CABALLERO. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION? YEAH. ALL RIGHT,
SECRETARY, CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
Ã ALVARADO. GIL AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKESBURG. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY DODD. AYE.
DALLEY. NO TERRAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. NO DATO. AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO COBO.
NO. PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO.
NO SKINNER A SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER I WILL. AYE JONES.
NÓ. Tê. AYE JONES. AYE. TO. NO.
ALL RIGHT. ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 7,
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO NEXT. WE'RE GOING TO
NEXT MOVE TO FILE ITEM 92. THIS
IS SB 1323. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 12 1323 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. AN ACCURATE
RELATING TO CRIMINAL PROCEDURE.
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE DONE IN AN HOUR.
SENATOR MENGIBAR FLOOR. SENATOR.
MR. PRESIDENT, THAT WAS MY LINE.
YOU CAN'T TAKE MY LINE AWAY.
CREDIT FOR IT. SB 1323 IS BACK
IN CONCURRENCE. THE AMENDMENTS
ARE TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND ALL
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN REMOVED
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SENATORS, ANYONE WANT TO BE
HEARD ON THIS MEASURE? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SHE SAID ALL
OPPOSITION HAD BEEN REMOVED. I
THOUGHT WE WERE ALL RIGHT.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IT'S JUST TESTING THAT A LITTLE
BIT. I'M GLAD EVERYONE IS PAYING
ATTENTION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN A GILL. NO,
ARCHULETA A ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS.
AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE DALI. NÓ. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO I. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
NO. HURTADO JONES. NO. NO.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MAGUIRE
MINGYUAN. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. TRUMBO
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO NO.
SKINNER A SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO, NO, NO.
MIN. AYE TO. NO TO CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. HURTADO MAGUIRE.
OKOBO. ON A VOTE OF 28 TO 9, THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 93. THIS IS
SB 1450. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1450 BY SENATOR
ALLEN AND ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS. SENATOR ALLEN. THIS
BILL STREAMLINES ADMINISTRATION
TO REDUCE COSTS AND IMPROVES
ELECTION MANAGEMENT UNDER THE
VOTERS CHOICE ACT, WHILE
PROTECTING VITAL VOTER ACCESS
REQUIREMENTS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS REWORKED MAJOR
PROVISIONS AND SPECIFIED
ELECTION PLAN TIMELINES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ALLEN. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY DODD. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. AYE. JONES.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE
MENJIVAR. AYE MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. EBCLC PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. AYE. SATO SKINNER. AYE
MOORLACH. RIVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLEY
GROVE. JONES. MCGUIRE WAYNE.
NILO OKUBO. SATO ON A VOTE OF 32
TO 0, THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 94. THIS
IS. MR. ALL RIGHT. GIVE US A
MOMENT. TO THANK YOU.
OKAY MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM 94. THIS IS
SENATE BILL 1526. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1526 BY
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS,
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AN ACT RELATING TO
CONSUMER, CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
SENATOR JONES, CAN YOU MOVE TO
THE SIDE THERE? THANK YOU.
SENATOR ASHBY, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. I WAS WAITING FOR HIM TO
PRESENT IT. MR. PRESIDENT, SB
1526 IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE.
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY MADE
A NUMBER OF TECHNICAL CHANGES
RELATED TO THE BUREAU OF PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION ADDRESS
CHAPTER ISSUES, AND MADE SOME
OTHER MINOR CHANGES.
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON SB 1526. MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE. IT
IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL, SEEING NO OBJECTION. AYES
30 900. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. WE HAVE.
I'D LIKE TO ASK ALL THE SENATORS
TO PLEASE REMAIN IN YOUR SEATS.
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT CALLS HERE
IN JUST A MOMENT. EVERYONE,
PLEASE STAY ON THE FLOOR, AND BE
PREPARED TO CLOSE OUT THE VOTES
ON ON ALL THE MEASURES ON CALL.
SENATOR JONES, FOR WHAT REASON
DO YOU RISE? PARLIAMENTARY
INQUIRY, MR. PRESIDENT, SIR,
WHAT IS YOUR PARLIAMENTARY? I'M
JUST WONDERING BY CHANCE IF
THERE MIGHT BE A MESSAGE FROM
THE GOVERNOR ON THE DESK,
SENATOR, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CARING ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
MESSAGES. I'M SURE HE'S VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT. AND WE'LL
CHECK. AND IF THERE ARE, WE'LL
LET YOU KNOW. OKAY. MR.
PRESIDENT, I APPRECIATE THAT.
YOU KNOW, WHAT I'LL DO IS I'LL
CHECK LA TIMES AND SEE IF
THERE'S A MESSAGE FROM THE
GOVERNOR ON LA TIMES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MR. PRESIDENT.
OKAY. MEMBERS SH LIKE EVERYONE
TO RETURN TO THEIR SEATS. IT'S A
VERY HARD TO HEAR. AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE SINCE WE'RE CLOSING
THE ROLL ON THESE 15 OR 16
ITEMS, THAT EVERYONE GETS THE
CHANCE TO VOTE. SENATOR JONES,
CAN YOU FIND YOUR SEAT THERE FOR
A MOMENT?
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH ITEM 59. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 3134. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. ON A VOTE OF
40 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 60. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 863. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN, A ARCHULETA. BECKER. AYE
BRADFORD. GLASER MCGUIRE. AYE.
MIN. NEWMAN PADILLA. PORTANTINO
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS I.
STERN. AYE. WAHAB WIENER. AYE.
ON A VOTE OF 24 TO 9, THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 63 AB 2263.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD MCGUIRE.
AYE. MIN. DODD. AYE ON A VOTE OF
30. IN FAVOR, NINE AGAINST. THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 64. THIS IS
AB 2460. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE ON A VOTE OF 40 IN
FAVOR, ZERO AGAINST. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 65,
AB 2629. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE MCGUIRE. AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 39 IN FAVOR, ONE
AGAINST. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 11. THIS IS
SB 399. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ASHBY, A CORTEZ. AYE.
DODD. GLAZER. AYE. AYE. JONES
NO. MCGUIRE AYE. PADILLA AYE.
ROTH AYE. DODD. AYE ON A VOTE OF
31 IN FAVOR. NINE AGAINST. THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 15. SB
1103. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA BLAKE, SPEER.
BRADFORD DODD GLAZER. JONES. NØ
MCGUIRE. AYE. MIN NEWMAN.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH. ON
A VOTE OF 22 IN FAVOR. NINE
AGAINST THE ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM 16, SB 1108. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
HI. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE
PADILLA. AYE SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE.
ON A VOTE OF 40 IN FAVOR. NONE
AGAINST THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP, FILE ITEM 70, AB 1252.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BECKER HI, BRADFORD. CORTEZ AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES NÓ. BRADFORD.
AYE MCGUIRE. AYE WAYNE. SEYARTO.
NÓ SKINNER. AYE SMALL. CUEVAS.
AYE ON A VOTE OF 31 IN FAVOR.
EIGHT AGAINST THE ASSEMBLY.
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 77. THIS
IS AB 2243. EXCUSE ME ON THAT
LAST ONE IT WAS NOT. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THAT'S THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO AB FILE
ITEM 77. THIS IS AB 2243. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
GLAZER. GROVE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
LIMÓN. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR MAN.
WHEN MILO. PORTANTINO CIERTO.
MOORLACH. RIVAS AYE. UMBERG WILK.
GROVE. AYE ON A VOTE OF 28. IN
FAVOR. NONE AGAINST THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
84. THIS IS AB 3264. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE I
JONES. NØ MCGUIRE. AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 39 IN FAVOR, ONE AGAINST
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM 85. THIS IS SB 219.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. I'LL RODA-GIL.
DELHI NØ GROVE. NØ JONES. AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MILO COBO. ON A
VOTE OF 33 IN FAVOR. FOUR
AGAINST THE ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 86, SB 440, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GLAZER
GROVE NO. JONES NO. MCGUIRE. AYE
ON A VOTE OF 30 IN FAVOR. NINE
AGAINST THE ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MOVE TO FILE
ITEM 87. THIS IS SB 690. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE I
JONES. I MCGUIRE. AYE PADILLA.
PADILLA.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER.
PADILLA BY A VOTE OF 40. IN
FAVOR? NONE AGAINST THE ASSEMBLY.
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FINALLY. MEMBERS, FILE ITEM 88
SB 954, PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. PRESIDING OFFICER GROVE.
JONES NØ MCGUIRE. AYE. WILK WILK.
GROVE. NO NO. WILK. NÓ. ON A
VOTE OF 31 IN FAVOR. NINE
AGAINST THE ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
SEN. FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU
RISE, MR. PRESIDENT? I THINK
THAT YOU ARE DOING AN
OUTSTANDING JOB, AND I THINK
THIS IS AN OUTSTANDING TIME TO
QUIT. I MOVE TO ADJOURN. IT'S
NON-DEBATABLE MOTION. MEMBERS,
WE HAVE A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
IT'S NON-DEBATABLE. SECRETARY,
CALL THE ROLL. INVESTING IN
RENEWABLE. I THINK I'M
CHANNELING SENATOR GONZALEZ
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. SENATOR
DANILO IS ASKING FOR A YES VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN NÓ. ALL RIGHT, GO BY
ARCHULETA. NO. ASHBY. NO ATKINS.
NO. BECKER NO BLAKE. SPEAR NO.
BRADFORD NO. CABALLERO NO.
CORTEZ. NO DALLY. I DODD. NO. NO
TERRAZZO. NO. EGGMAN NO. GLAZER
NO. GONZALEZ NO. GROVE NO.
HURTADO NO. JONES. NO LAIRD. NO
LIMON. NO MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE. NO
MENGIBAR. NO MEN. NO. MEN. NO.
NEWMAN NO. NGUYEN NILO. Ã.
OCHOA B¢O. PADILLA NO.
PORTANTINO NO. ROTH I RUBIO. NO.
SATO SKINNER. NO SMALL. CUEVAS.
NO. STERN NO. NO. NO NO. WAHAB
WIENER. WILK NO. ON A VOTE IN
FOUR. IN FAVOR. 31 AGAINST. THE
MOTION TO ADJOURN. FAILS. ALL
RIGHT, HOLD ON. SH CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ONE LAST TIME.
WHEN OKOBO. SEYARTO WAHAB.
WIENER NO. ROTH, IRA. NO ALL
RIGHT. EVERYONE HAVING THE
CHANCE TO VOTE ON THAT. THREE IN
FAVOR. 33 AGAINST THE MOTION TO
ADJOURN HAS FAILED. THANK YOU
FOR THE ENTERTAINING PAUSE. ALL
RIGHT, MEMBERS, HERE'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO. WE HAVE FIVE
ITEMS NOW ON THE DOCKET. SINCE
WE'RE NOT ADJOURNING, I'LL LET
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY ARE AHEAD OF
TIME. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
FILE ITEM 53, FOLLOWED BY FILE
ITEM 56, 75, 76 AND 82. YOU'RE
FOLLOWING ALONG AT HOME. SO
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN THIS
SEGMENT WITH FILE ITEM 53. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1465.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1465 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS AN ACT RELATING TO AIR
POLLUTION. PLEASE GIVE SENATOR
SKINNER YOUR ATTENTION. MEMBERS,
PLEASE GIVE SENATOR SKINNER YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. AB 1465
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS CHANGES
THE PENALTY BASELINE FOR THE
LARGEST SOURCES OF AIR POLLUTION
IN CALIFORNIA. WHEN THEY VIOLATE
OUR AIR POLLUTION LAWS. THESE
PENALTY BASELINES WERE LAST
CHANGED IN 2001 AND HAVE HAD
ONLY MINOR INCREASES SINCE 2018.
CEILINGS ARE ROUTINELY ADJUSTED
BASED ON MITIGATING FACTORS,
SUCH AS HOW FAST THE VIOLATION
IS CORRECTED AND THE PAST
HISTORY OF VIOLATIONS. AS WE ALL
KNOW, UNHEALTHY AIR CONTINUES TO
BE A CONCERN, ESPECIALLY IN
COMMUNITIES LOCATED NEAR OUR
PORTS, NEAR OUR GOOD MOVEMENTS
CORRIDORS, AND NEAR HEAVILY
INDUSTRIALIZED AREAS. THE
EXISTING PENALTY STRUCTURE IS
NOT AN ADEQUATE DETERRENT TO
PREVENT VIOLATIONS OF AIR
POLLUTION LAWS. CONSEQUENCES FOR
AIR QUALITY VIOLATIONS MUST BE
SEVERE ENOUGH TO DETER A
VIOLATION BEFORE IT OCCURS, SO
THAT VIOLATORS DON'T SIMPLY
TREAT FINES AS AN ACCEPTABLE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS. AB 1465
RESETS THOSE PENALTY CEILINGS TO
INCENTIVIZE THE LARGE SOURCES TO
OPERATE SAFELY, TO PERFORM
REQUIRED MAINTENANCE, AND TO
COMMUNICATE TO THE PUBLIC ABOUT
LOCAL HEALTH CONCERNS. IT IS A
BILL THAT PROTECTS OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ACKNOWLEDGES THAT AIR
QUALITY IS STILL A SEVERE
CHALLENGE IN CALIFORNIA, THAT WE
OWE IT TO OUR CONSTITUENTS TO
ADDRESS. AND WITH THAT, I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR SKINNER. ANY DISCUSSION
ON THE MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION
ON THE MEASURE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, CALL THE ROLL. EXCUSE
ME. PAUSE I NOW SEE A LATE
MICROPHONE UP FROM THE SENATOR
FROM BEAVER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SENATOR, I HAVE A
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR, IF I
MAY, SENATOR SKINNER, WILL YOU
TAKE A QUESTION? OKAY, SO TITLE
FIVE PERMITS IS WHAT THIS I
BELIEVE IS TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION TITLE FIVE PERMITS
ARE AUTHORIZED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND HOW WILL THIS
BILL IMPACT TITLE FIVE? IT DOES
NOT CHANGE WHO RECEIVES THE
TITLE FIVE. PERMIT THOSE, AS YOU
POINTED OUT, ARE STILL ISSUED.
IT ONLY ALLOWS OUR REGULATORS
WHO ENFORCE OUR AIR POLLUTION
LAWS THE ABILITY TO ADJUST TO
FINE FOR A VIOLATOR OF A TITLE
FIVE VIOLATOR AGAINST OUR AIR
QUALITY LAWS. SENATOR, ON YOUR
OWN TIME. EXCUSE ME? I SAID,
SENATOR DALY, ON YOUR OWN TIME.
WELL, I BELIEVE THAT THE TITLE
FIVE PERMITS THAT ARE ISSUED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE BASED
OFF OF CREDITS PER COUNTY. IF MY
MEMORY SERVES ME CORRECT, AND
THIS BILL IS GOING TO DRIVE UP
THE COST, AND IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE WHERE THE
AIR IS ACTUALLY BEING, WHERE THE
BAD AIR QUALITY IS COMING FROM.
IF YOU HAVE MORE THAN ONE TITLE
FIVE PERMITS IN YOUR COUNTY,
WHICH MOST COUNTIES DO. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS, I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. I BELIEVE
THIS IS A VIOLATION OF THE
FEDERAL LAW THAT IS IN PLACE,
DIDN'T HAVE A QUITE GREAT
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BILL, BUT
THAT'S MY TAKE ON IT. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS, I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING IT ANY ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION, MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? SENATOR SKINNER, YOU
MAY CLOSE, I WOULD NOTE THAT,
YOU PROBABLY HAVE NOTICED IN THE
FILE THERE ARE LETTERS FROM
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. AND THERE'S ALSO
NOTATIONS THAT ANALYSIS SHOWS
THAT IT IS NOT IN VIOLATION OF
FEDERAL LAW. AND IN FACT, OUR
CONGRESSIONAL REPRESENTATIVES
WANT US TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE ENOUGH TEETH IN OUR
ENFORCEMENT IN ORDER TO HELP
PREVENT THESE, SEVERE EMISSIONS
AIR POLLUTION EMISSIONS. AND
WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON. I'LL GO. NO. ARCHULETA HØI
ASHBY. Ã ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. I BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE.
DAWLEY NO. DODD DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO AYE.
JONES NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMON AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO.
JABO NO. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROD RUBIO
SEYARTO. NO. SKINNER A SMALL
CUEVAS. AYE STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB WIENER. AYE. WILK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN. AYE. CABALLERO NO. DODD
NO. GLAZER. AYE. AYE NEWMAN.
ROTH. RUBIO AYE. WAHAB AYE. WILK
ON A VOTE OF 27 IN FAVOR, TEN
AGAINST. THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 56. THIS IS AB 2561.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2561 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKENNA. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. MR. PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES, ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA, I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2561. THIS
BILL REQUIRES LOCAL AGENCIES TO
ANNUALLY REPORT ON THE STATUS OF
STAFF VACANCIES, RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION EFFORTS DURING A
PUBLIC HEARING. CALIFORNIA'S
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS CURRENTLY
DEALING WITH SIGNIFICANT
STAFFING CRISES THAT HAS
AFFECTED PUBLIC SERVICE,
EMPLOYMENT AND THE OVERALL
ECONOMY. AB 2561 IS A CRITICAL
STEP FORWARD TO ENSURING GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND LOCAL AGENCY
STAFFING PRACTICES AND TO
EMPOWER WORKERS, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO,
GIL. NO. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. NÓ. DODD NO. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. BY GLAZER. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO NO.
TROBERG. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH RUBIO.
SEYARTO NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALL.
GIVE US A STERN. AYE UMBERG.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK NO. HE'S CALLED THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. OH, AND GLAZER.
MIN ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 27 IN FAVOR. TEN
AGAINST. THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 75. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
3261. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
THAT THIS IS A 75. ASSEMBLY BILL
3261 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE
FONG AND ACT RELATING TO HORSE
RACING. SENATOR RUBIO, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE, I RISE TO PRESENT
AB 3261 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MIKE FONG. AB 3261
SUPPORTS OUR HORSE RACING
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA AND
THOUSANDS OF JOBS LINKED IN THAT
INDUSTRY. IT WILL GIVE WAGERING
CUSTOMERS IN CALIFORNIA GREATER
OPTIONS BY INCREASING THE CAP ON
THE NUMBER OF RACES THEY CAN
WAGER ON. THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY IN THE ASSEMBLY. I
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE?
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI, GIL. HI, ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY AYE. DODD. AYE
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. AYE HURTADO. AYE. JONES
AYE. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. AYE
MILO. AYE TROBERG AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER A
SMALL CUEVAS. AYE STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER. BECKER. AYE, AYE.
ON A VOTE OF 40 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILED
ITEM 76. THIS IS ASSEMBLY.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3129. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3129
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WOULD AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH FACILITIES.
SENATOR HURTADO THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
3129 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOCTOR,
WOULD THE CRISIS FACING
DEMOCRACY BOTH IN OUR COUNTRY
AND AROUND THE WORLD, STEMS FROM
THE RISE OF MONOPOLIES AND
CONCENTRATED POWER? THESE FORCES
WIELD SIGNIFICANT POLITICAL
INFLUENCE, ECHOING THE
CHALLENGES FACED IN THE 19TH
CENTURY, AN ERA MARKED BY
INTENSE CONFLICTS, CULTURAL
TENSIONS AND WIDESPREAD FEAR.
THE FIGHT AGAINST UNCHECKED
CORPORATE POWER IS A BIPARTISAN
ISSUE, SPANNING GENERATIONS OF
LEADERS. REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT
THEODORE ROOSEVELT ROOSEVELT, IN
HIS 1901 ADDRESS TO CONGRESS,
EMPHASIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF
USING OUR POWER TO PROTECT OUR
PEOPLE, INSTITUTIONS, AND
INDUSTRIAL LIBERTY. SIMILARLY,
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT WOODROW
WILSON WARNED IN 1914 THAT THE
CONCENTRATION OF WEALTH, MONEY,
AND PROPERTY IN THE UNITED
STATES UNDER THE CONTROL AND IN
THE HANDS OF A FEW INDIVIDUALS
OR GREAT CORPORATIONS, HAS GROWN
TO SUCH AN ENORMOUS EXTENT THAT,
UNLESS CHECKED, IT WILL
ULTIMATELY THREATEN THE
PERPETUITY OF OUR INSTITUTIONS,
THE PERPETUITY, I'M SORRY,
PERPETUITY. MOST OF US, WHETHER
DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY, HAVE
WORKED ON TACKLING ANTITRUST
ISSUES, WHETHER IT'S STRIVING TO
CREATE BALANCE IN OUR NEWSROOMS,
ENSURING RESIDENTIAL CARE
PATIENTS ARE NOT PUSHED OUT OF
CARE. ADDRESSING ROLL UP
PURCHASES IN AGRICULTURE OR
ADVOCATING FOR THE RIGHT TO
REPAIR OR PREVENTING OUR
HOSPITALS FROM CLOSING. THESE
EFFORTS ARE ALL PART OF A
BROADER STRUGGLE TO PROTECT OUR
PEOPLE, INSTITUTIONS AND
ECONOMIC FREEDOMS FROM CORPORATE
DOMINANCE, A RESPONSIBILITY THAT
TRANSCENDS POLITICAL LINES. THE
TRENDS BY SOME PRIVATE EQUITY
FIRMS IN THE HEALTH CARE ARE
ESPECIALLY ALARMING. IN JULY,
LINA KHAN, THE CHAIR OF THE
FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION,
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF SUPPORT
FOR THIS LEGISLATION. DURING HER
TIME AS CHAIR OF THE FTC, SHE
HAS HIGHLIGHTED SEVERAL
CONCERNING PRACTICES RELATING TO
PRIVATE EQUITY FIRMS. FIRST,
PRIVATE EQUITY OFTEN LOADS
COMPANIES WITH DEBT, STRIP
STRIPS, ASSETS AND PURSUES
FINANCIAL TACTICS THAT WEAKEN
THE FIRMS THEY ACQUIRE WITH
SHORT TIMELINES OF 3 TO 7 YEARS,
THEY USE HIGH LEVELS OF DEBT 60
TO 80%, BURDENING THE ACQUIRED
ENTITIES. THIS CAN LEAD TO
REDUCED STAFF AND SERVICES UNDER
THE UNDER THE GUISE OF
EFFICIENCY. TRAGICALLY, PRIVATE
EQUITY TAKEOVERS OF NURSING
HOMES HAVE LED TO AN ESTIMATED
20,000 EXCESS DEATHS, 20,000
EXCESS DEATHS OVER 12 YEARS.
SECOND, PRIVATE EQUITY
CONSOLIDATES MARKET POWER
THROUGH SERIAL ACQUISITIONS AND
A BUY AND BUILD MODEL, GRADUALLY
SIDESTEPPING ANTITRUST REVIEW.
THESE ROLL UP STRATEGIES CAN
ELIMINATE COMPETITION, ALLOWING
NEW OWNERS TO RAISE PRICES TO
CREATE QUALITY AND NEUTRALIZE
RIVALS. WITHOUT COMPETITIVE
CHECKS. AND THIRD, SOME PRIVATE
EQUITY FIRMS BUY STAKES IN RIVAL
FIRMS, REDUCING THE INCENTIVE.
THE INCENTIVES TO COMPETE, WHICH
HARMS BOTH THE INDUSTRY AND
CONSUMERS. THIS PRACTICE IS NOT
LIMITED TO PRIVATE EQUITY,
INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS AND
PUBLIC EQUITY MARKETS ALSO RAISE
SUCH CONCERNS. PRIVATE EQUITY
INVESTMENT IN THE HEALTH CARE
HAS INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY OVER
THE PAST TWO DECADES.
TRANSACTIONS IN HEALTH CARE
ALONE IN 2021 TOTALED $83
BILLION. 20 BILLION OF THAT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. THESE PRACTICES
AND THE LEVEL OF MONEY INVOLVED
DEMONSTRATE THE NEED FOR
STRONGER OVERSIGHT TO PROTECT
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM AND ENSURE THAT PATIENT
CARE REMAINS TOP PRIORITY.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3129 SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES BY ENSURING
THE ATTORNEY, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL CAN REVIEW PRIVATE
EQUITY ACQUISITIONS. THE BILL
INCLUDES PROVISIONS FOR
EXPEDITED REVIEW WHEN ENTITIES
ARE IN FINANCIAL DISTRESS AND
THE CONCERNS ABOUT INCREASED
SCRUTINY. SCRUTINY ARE
UNFOUNDED. THE BILL DOES NOT
PREVENT PRIVATE EQUITY
ACQUISITIONS, BUT ENSURES
APPROPRIATE SCRUTINY TO
SAFEGUARD OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOCTOR WOULD THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND I SHARE THE
SAME GOAL TO PROTECT ACCESS TO
CARE? WE CANNOT AFFORD TO DELAY
THIS PROCESS BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
THERE IS NO REVIEW MECHANISM AT
ALL. AND AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
MADE TO ADDRESS èC CONCERNS
THAT WE ADDRESSED THROUGHOUT
THIS CHAMBER. AND I'D LIKE TO
END WITH THE WARNINGS OF PAST
LEADERS LIKE PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT
AND WILSON ARE AS RELEVANT TODAY
AS EVER. THE UNCHECKED
CONCENTRATION OF ECONOMIC POWER
CONTINUES TO POSE A SIGNIFICANT
THREAT TO OUR DEMOCRACY. AB 3129
REPRESENTS A CRUCIAL STEP IN
PROTECTING OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM FROM THE CORROSIVE
EFFECTS OF UNFETTERED PRIVATE
EQUITY PRACTICES, ENSURING THAT
QUALITY CARE REMAINS A TOP
PRIORITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
HURTADO. TO BEGIN THE DEBATE,
SENATOR ASHBY. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MY SECOND SON WAS
LITTLE ABOUT FOUR. WE LEARNED
THAT HE HAD A PROBLEM WITH THE
ENAMEL ON HIS TEETH. IF WE
DIDN'T ADDRESS IT, HE WOULD HAVE
TROUBLE EATING. WHICH OF COURSE
BE A REAL PROBLEM FOR US. LUCKY
FOR ME, RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO, THERE WAS AN AMAZING
PEDIATRIC DENTIST NAMED DOCTOR
SALADIN. HE PERFORMED HEROIC
SURGERY ON MY SON. IT TOOK ALL
DAY. I WAS SCARED TO DEATH.
SITTING OUTSIDE OF THAT DENTAL
OFFICE WAITING FOR MY LITTLE
BABY WHO WAS UNDER AND RECEIVING
THAT CARE THAT ORGANIZATION,
CALLED CHILDREN'S CHOICE DENTAL,
STARTED IN NATOMAS, A COUPLE
BLOCKS FROM MY HOUSE. THEY'VE
GROWN. THEY NOW TREAT OVER
130,000 YOUNG PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE, 86% OF THE
KIDDOS THAT THEY HELP, LIKE MY
SON, RECEIVED MEDI-CAL. THE CEO
OF THAT COMPANY SENT ME A NOTE
AND TOLD ME THAT THIS BILL
ALONE, JUST THIS BILL, WOULD
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO
CONTINUE TO GROW IN CALIFORNIA.
HE SAID TO ME THAT THE LOSS OF
PRIVATE EQUITY INVESTMENT WOULD
ABSOLUTELY KILL BUSINESSES LIKE
HIS. I KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
UCS, AND I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
LARGE ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
COME ON BOARD, BUT I AM ASKING
YOU COLLEAGUES, TO THINK ABOUT
THE BUSINESS OWNERS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO COULD NEVER GROW
WITHOUT THAT KIND OF PRIVATE
INVESTMENT. THEY'RE THE SAME
BUSINESSES THAT SHOW UP IN THE
AREAS WHERE NO ONE ELSE WILL GO.
IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE ALL
KNOW, WHERE KIDS AND FAMILIES
HAVE THE HARDEST TIME GETTING
SERVICES. WHY? WHY WOULD WE MAKE
IT HARDER? WHY WOULD WE MAKE IT
HARDER FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING THE HARDEST TO FIND
EQUITY TO SERVE OUR FAMILIES? I
URGE A NO VOTE. NEXT UP IS
SENATOR LAIRD, FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR MILO AND JONES. SENATOR
LAIRD, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
LET ME SPEAK TO THE IMMEDIATE
POINT THAT WAS JUST MADE BECAUSE
MANY OF YOU ARE TIRED OF HEARING
ME SAY IT, BUT IT APPLIES TO
THIS SITUATION. WHEN THE
WATSONVILLE HOSPITAL WENT UNDER,
IT WAS BECAUSE A PRIVATE EQUITY
FIRM WITH LIMITED EXPERIENCE IN
RUNNING HOSPITALS TOOK IT OVER.
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS ABOUT
BUSINESS PRACTICE. THEY THOUGHT
THEY DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
RUNNING THE HOSPITAL COMPARED TO
AN ACTUAL HOSPITAL OPERATOR.
THIS WAS 82% MEDI-CAL OR 82%
PUBLIC PAYS. AND IT IS GOING ON
IN HOLLISTER, RIGHT NOW WHERE
THERE IS AN OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS THAT IS
GOING TO PARTNER WITH THIS
HOSPITAL THAT HAS A SIMILAR
AMOUNT OF PUBLIC PAY. PATIENTS
AND IT IS NOT THE GOOD ACTORS
THAT THIS BILL GETS AFTER. IT'S
IF PEOPLE WANT TO INVEST IN A
WAY THAT IS SUCCESSFUL AND IT IS
REALLY PROVIDING SERVICES, IT IS
THE PLACES WHERE IT DOESN'T
WORK. AND THERE IS A VERY UNIQUE
COALITION BEHIND THIS BILL THAT
PROVES THE POINT. IT IS RARE
THAT THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION JOIN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
A BILL ON THIS SUBJECT. AND SO
WHAT THIS DOES IS RIGHT NOW,
THOSE 86% MEDI-CAL PEOPLE, OR
THOSE 82% MEDI-CAL PEOPLE IN THE
BUSINESS HAVE NO VOICE. THERE IS
NO ABILITY THAT IF THERE IS A
PRIVATE EQUITY INVESTMENT THAT
IS NOT FOR THE LONG TERM
BUSINESS HEALTH OF THAT HEALTH
INSTITUTION, THERE'S NOBODY TO
TALK ABOUT THAT QUESTION. THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. AND I DO
NOT THINK THAT THE GOOD ACTORS
HAVE THINGS TO FEAR. BUT I DO
THINK THE BAD ACTORS DO. AND THE
REAL ISSUE HERE IS THE BECAUSE
IN TALKING TO THE PAST PRESIDENT
OF THE MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA, WHO IS A PHYSICIAN
IN MY DISTRICT, HIS CONCERN IS
THE PRIVATE EQUITY PURCHASE OF
MEDICAL PRACTICES ACROSS THE
STATE. AND IF THAT IS THE WAY
OUR MEDICAL SYSTEM IS GOING FROM
DOCTORS OWNING THEIR PRACTICES
TO THEM BEING PURCHASED, THEN WE
SHOULD HAVE A PROCESS FOR
TALKING ABOUT THAT. AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. AND WHEN
THIS BILL CAME IN FRONT OF US IN
COMMITTEE, I SORT OF
UNFORTUNATELY PUT THE AUTHOR ON
THE SPOT BECAUSE I THINK THIS
BILL HAS BEEN NARROWED TOO MUCH.
I THINK THIS BILL SHOULD HAVE
STILL BEEN CLOSER TO THE
ORIGINAL FORM TO ADDRESS THE
GENUINE QUESTIONS THAT ARE
BEHIND THIS. SO, IRONICALLY,
THIS BILL HAS BEEN NARROWED.
THAT IS IN FRONT OF US TODAY.
AND YET IT STILL GETS AT THIS.
AND I THINK THAT IF WE ARE
REALLY LOOKING AT THAT 86%
MEDI-CAL OR THAT 82% MEDI-CAL OR
THE PHYSICIANS THAT HAVE OWNED
THEIR OWN PRACTICE, AND IT'S
GOING TO BE OWNED OUTSIDE THE
AREA BY A PRIVATE EQUITY FIRM.
IT IS A VERY APPROPRIATE THING
FOR CONVERSATION. AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. NEXT UP, SENATOR
NIELLO, FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
JONES AND SENATOR MIN. SENATOR
NIELLO, A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR
OR FLOOR JOCKEY FOR MANAGER
HURTADO. WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE
A QUESTION? ABSOLUTELY SENATOR
NIELLO, GIVEN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S ROLE IN A SIMILAR
SITUATION WITH REGARD TO THE
PROPOSED SALE OF THE MADERA
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL AND THE
ENTIRELY UNREASONABLE CONDITIONS
THAT HE PUT ON THAT SALE, THAT
ACTUALLY ENDED UP FORCING THE
HOSPITAL INTO BANKRUPTCY. WHY
WOULD WE WANT TO DELEGATE THIS
AUTHORITY TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL? SENATOR HURTADO, YOU
CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION NOW OR
IN YOUR CLOSE YOUR CHOICE. I CAN
DO IT IN MY CLOSE. THANK YOU.
ANYTHING ELSE? SENATOR NIELLO?
BEG YOUR PARDON? ANYTHING ELSE
ON YOUR TIME? OH, SHE WILL TAKE
IT. OR CLOSE WHAT SHE SAID. THE
ONLY OTHER THING THAT I WOULD
SAY IS STATE POLICY PUTS
HOSPITALS INTO DISTRUSTFUL
SITUATION, BECAUSE WE SO UNDER
REIMBURSE MEDI-CAL AND MEDICARE
SERVICES. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, WHILE I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE THE UC
SYSTEM FROM THE BILL, THERE'S
STILL PLENTY OF HOSPITAL SYSTEMS
THAT ARE STILL AFFECTED BY THIS
BILL THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO
JUST IN MY AREA IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IS SHARP. AND SCRIPPS,
BUT NORTH OF US IN UP IN
RIVERSIDE IS RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL. ACROSS THE STATE,
CEDARS-SINAI UNITED HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IS OPPOSED.
ADVENTIST HEALTH ONE THAT'S
PERSONALLY IMPORTANT TO ME IS
KECK MEDICINE OF USC IN LA, WHO
JUST, A YEAR AND A HALF AGO
SAVED MY MOTHER IN LAW'S LIFE.
AND. YOU KNOW, I WAS ASKED TO
SPEAK ON THIS, AND I DIDN'T
REALLY REALIZE THAT'S WHERE I
WAS GOING TO GO. CALIFORNIA HAS
THE BEST HEALTH CARE IN THE
WORLD, AND WE CAN CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE BEST HEALTH CARE IN THE
WORLD. OR WE CAN CONTINUE TO
OVERREGULATE WE CONTINUE TO PUT
WE CAN'T WE CAN CONTINUE TO PUT
UP HURDLES. WE CAN CONTINUE TO
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
HOSPITALS TO DO BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. OR WE CAN CHOOSE
TODAY TO STAY OUT OF THE WAY AND
MAYBE COME BACK NEXT YEAR. AND
LET'S DO A ROBUST DISCUSSION ON
THE REGULATIONS AND THE POLICIES
AND THE LAWS THAT WE'VE PASSED
OUT OF THIS BUILDING THAT HAVE
PUT THE HOSPITALS IN THE
SITUATION THAT THEY'RE IN. I ASK
FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR JONES, SENATOR MIN,
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR GROVE. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES, I APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST DIALOG. I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD
FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL AND TO
THE AUTHOR, LOOK, I AGREE WITH
SOME OF THE POINTS RAISED BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO. WE DO
WANT ROBUST FINANCING OF HEALTH
CARE PRACTICES AND INSTITUTIONS,
BUT I WOULD JUST SUBMIT TO YOU
THAT PRIVATE EQUITY IS UNIQUE
BECAUSE PRIVATE EQUITY IS NOT
PATIENT CAPITAL. THEY'RE NOT
TRYING TO MAKE LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS AND WAIT TO SEE HOW
THIS TURNS OUT. TYPICALLY,
PRIVATE EQUITY FIRMS HAVE 3 TO 7
YEAR TIMELINES FOR THEIR RETURNS
ON HEALTH CARE. THERE'S REALLY
ONLY ONE WAY TO GET THAT. IT IS
BY CUTTING COSTS. IT IS BY
INCREASING REVENUES. AND THIS IS
BAD FOR PATIENTS, IT'S BAD FOR
DOCTORS, IT'S BAD FOR HEALTH
CARE WORKERS. MY OWN SISTER IN
LAW, MY BROTHER'S WIFE WAS AN
ANESTHESIOLOGIST. I SAY WAS
BECAUSE SHE'S NOW RETIRED. AND
THE REASON SHE'S RETIRED IS
BECAUSE HER FIRM, A LEADING FIRM
IN THE BAY AREA, WAS BOUGHT OUT
BY A PRIVATE EQUITY GROUP AND
THAT PRIVATE EQUITY GROUP SHE
HAD JUST VESTED AND MADE
PARTNER. SHE HAD TO STAY UNTIL
THAT VESTED. SO SHE STAYED. I
THINK, FOR THREE AND A HALF
YEARS. IT WAS MISERABLE FOR HER.
SHE FELT LIKE SHE WAS DOING HER
PATIENTS A DISSERVICE BECAUSE
THEY MADE HER HAVE A MINIMUM
NUMBER OF PATIENTS. SHE HAD TO
SEE EACH DAY. SHE WAS REQUIRED
TO TAKE ON MORE PATIENTS THAN
SHE FELT COMFORTABLE WITH. THIS
MADE HER MORE STRESSED OUT.
ANESTHESIOLOGY IS A VERY
STRESSFUL FIELD. IT WAS BAD.
ACCORDING TO HER. FOR HER
PATIENTS EXPERIENCES, AND I
THINK THERE'S A REASON THAT ALL
OF THE DOCTORS, NURSES AND
HEALTH CARE WORKER GROUPS ARE
AGAINST THIS AND IMPORTANTLY,
WHY THE PATIENTS GROUPS ARE
AGAINST THIS BILL. AS WELL. I
MEAN, I'M SORRY FOR THIS BILL
AND WHY ONLY THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES ARE AGAINST THIS. SO
YES, WE DO WANT TO HAVE MORE
FINANCING. THIS IS A ROBUST
PROBLEM. AND I HAD VERY DEEP
CONCERNS ABOUT THE EARLIER
ITERATION OF THIS BILL. IT WAS
NARROWED. AND I REALIZE THAT
SOME PEOPLE HERE STILL FEEL LIKE
THIS REVISED BILL IS OVERBROAD.
BUT I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU THAT
PRIVATE EQUITY IS RUINING HEALTH
CARE RIGHT NOW IN THIS COUNTRY,
IN CALIFORNIA. WE NEED TO DEAL
WITH THIS PROBLEM. AND I THINK
THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE FIRST
STEP, ALLOWING FOR REVIEW. IT IS
NOT A BAN ON PRIVATE EQUITY. IT
IS JUST SIMPLY A REVIEW. SO I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR GROVE.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THE
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR, YOU TAKE
A QUESTION. SENATOR HURTADO.
ABSOLUTELY. I MEAN, YOUR
STATEMENT THAT YOU OPENED WITH
YOU SAID THAT YOU ADDRESSED THE
UK'S CONCERNS BECAUSE THEY WERE
CONCERNED THAT THEY WOULD BE
WRAPPED UP INTO THIS. THE UC
MEDICAL CENTERS AND HOSPITALS.
DID YOU ADDRESS THE DERMATOLOGY
CONCERNS? SENATOR HURTADO, YOU
CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION OR DO IT
IN YOUR CLOTHES. CAN SHE PROVIDE
CLARIFICATION ON THE QUESTION?
SURE. DERMATOLOGY. THE
DERMATOLOGISTS WERE CARVED OUT
AND HOW DID THEY GET THAT CARVE
OUT? MR. PRESIDENT, I CAN ANSWER
THAT IN MY CLOSING, IF THAT'S
OKAY. SENATOR GROVE, ON YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. I HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR. ALL
RIGHT, YOU TAKE ANOTHER
QUESTION. SENATOR HURTADO.
ABSOLUTELY, HAS CHÁVEZ A
CONCERNS WITH HOSPITALS. THE
HOSPITALS HAS THEIR CONCERNS
BEEN ADDRESSED BECAUSE THEY'RE
STILL OPPOSED? SENATOR HURTADO,
DO YOU WANT TO ANSWER IT NOW OR
IN YOUR CLOTHES? CAN YOU REPEAT
THE QUESTION? SORRY, I DIDN'T
HEAR IT. CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS
ASSOCIATIONS. YOU ADDRESSED THE
èC CONCERNS FOR THEIR
HOSPITALS. HAVE YOU ADDRESSED
THE CONCERNS FOR ALL OF OUR
HOSPITALS IN OUR DISTRICTS
BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL OPPOSED?
THE PRESIDENT I DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER TO THAT SPECIFIC QUESTION
AT THE MOMENT. I MY LAST
UNDERSTANDING WAS THAT THE, THE
OPPOSITION FROM THE HOSPITALS
WAS REMOVED. IF THEY JUMPED BACK
ON AN OPPOSITION. THAT'S NEWS TO
ME. I THINK THE CONCERNS ARE THE
DEFINITION IN THE BILL IS A
HEALTH CARE FACILITY, WHAT
WHAT'S THE DEFINITION OF A
HEALTH CARE FACILITY THROUGH THE
CHAIR, THROUGH THE PRESIDENT?
YOU'RE ASKING ONE MORE QUESTION,
SENATOR GROVE. YES. RESTATE IT.
PLEASE YES, PLEASE. SIR JUST PUT
MY. CAN YOU RESTATE THE QUESTION?
SENATOR GROVE Þ. SO THERE'S A
DEFINITION AS A HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IN THE BILL. LANGUAGE
IS THAT BILL LANGUAGE FOR A
HEALTH CARE FACILITY CONSIDERED
TO BE A HOSPITAL. AGAIN, YOU CAN
ANSWER IT NOW OR IN YOUR CLOSE.
I WILL DO THE BEST TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION IN MY CLOSING.
THANK YOU. OKAY. ANYTHING ELSE
ON MY OWN TIME? NO THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. A FEW YEARS AGO CAME
OUT WITH A REAL CATCHY PHRASE
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL, AND A LOT
OF IT IS A MEDI-CAL. MEDI-CAL
FOR ALL HEALTH CARE FOR ALL. DO
I BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE AND WE SHOULD HAVE
HEALTHY CONSTITUENTS?
ABSOLUTELY. BUT IF WE DON'T DO A
PROVIDER REIMBURSEMENT RATE THAT
IS SIGNIFICANT, THAT COVERS THE
COST. IT'S A PATHWAY TO
BANKRUPTCY FOR THESE FACILITIES,
THEY HAVE LIKE SEVERAL OF OUR
HOSPITALS, AND I HAVE A HOSPITAL
IN RIDGECREST AND THEN THE
TULARE, THE HOSPITAL IN, TULARE,
KAWEAH, THEY'RE GRASPING AT
STRAWS TRYING TO FIND ANYTHING
TO BE ABLE TO STAY OPEN, TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
LOW SOCIOECONOMIC DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. I DON'T RECALL THE
NUMBER COMPLETELY, BUT I BELIEVE
IT WAS. OVER 70% OF MEDI-CAL
PATIENTS ARE SERVED IN THE
KAWEAH HOSPITAL IN RIDGECREST.
IT'S MEDI-CAL AND MEDICARE
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE BASE OVER
THERE. AND THEN A LOT OF THE
POPULATION WE HAVE IN
RIDGECREST, THE BASE IS VERY
YOUNG. AND ON MEDICARE, THE
COMMUNITY IS IN OLDER AND MOSTLY
ON MEDI-CAL, SOME SOCIAL
SECURITY AND MEDICARE, THEY'RE
IN A POSITION WHERE THEY DON'T
GET ENOUGH REIMBURSEMENTS FOR
EITHER THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR
THE STATE GOVERNMENT TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE.
THEY RECENTLY SHUT DOWN THEIR
LABOR AND DELIVERY, AND THEY'RE
GOING TO STAND BY, EMERGENCY
ROOM SITUATION. NOW, PICTURE
THAT 170 MILES OR WHATEVER, AN
HOUR AND A HALF AWAY FROM, OTHER
LOCATIONS DOWN A MOUNTAIN WITH A
RIVER ON ONE SIDE AND A ROCK
WALL ON THE OTHER. WE, MY
COLLEAGUE FROM, MY COLLEAGUE, MY
FORMER MARINE OR THE MARINE?
FORMER MARINE ON THE BUDGET
CHAIR OR EXCUSE ME, BUDGET SUB
THREE CHAIR DROVE THAT CANYON
ROAD, IT'S A VERY WINDY ROAD, SO
IT'S NOT GOING TO TRAVEL AT 65
TO 70 MILES AN HOUR. IT'S MORE
OF A 35, 40 MILE AN HOUR ROAD.
IT TAKES A LONG TIME TO GET FROM
ONE PLACE TO THE OTHER. THEY'RE
GRASPING AT STRAWS. THEY'RE
TRYING TO RENEGOTIATE A PLAN.
THINGS LIKE THEIR PLAN BENEFITS
SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE HIGHER
RATES FROM PLANS THEY ARE TRYING
TO NEGOTIATE. WE WERE TRYING TO
GET THEM MORE MONEY THROUGH THE
MCO TAX. WE WERE TRYING TO GET
THEM FINANCIALLY DISTRESSED
HOSPITAL LOAN PROGRAMS, BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS, IS THEY DON'T
GET ENOUGH REIMBURSEMENT. SO
THEY ARE TURNING TO PRIVATE
EQUITY. THEY'RE LIKE, YOU WANT
TO INVEST IN THIS HOSPITAL. WE
NEED TO SERVE THIS COMMUNITY.
AND SOMETHING LIKE THIS TO STOP.
THIS WOULD BE JUST, I THINK THE
NAIL THAT PUTS THE COFFIN IN A
LOT OF OUR FINANCIALLY
DISTRESSED HOSPITALS, I WOULD
LOVE FOR A PRIVATE EQUITY GROUP
TO COME IN AND TAKE OVER MY
RIDGECREST HOSPITAL SO THAT WE
COULD PROVIDE MEDICAL SERVICES
TO OUR COMMUNITY, I JUST I THINK
THAT IF WE DON'T REALLY LOOK AT
AND REIMAGINE RURAL HEALTHCARE,
WE'RE GOING TO BE IN A LOT OF
TROUBLE. I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE IN
BEAVER HASN'T HAD A HOSPITAL IN
CERTAIN AREAS. I KNOW MORE RURAL
FACILITIES. WHEN MADERA CLOSED,
IT, OVERBURDENED FRESNO, WHEN
FRESNO WAS OVERBURDENED AND
OVERBURDENED TULARE. AND SO
THERE'S A RIPPLE EFFECT. AND SO
I WOULD JUST ASK FOR YOU TO VOTE
NO ON THIS BILL, AND LET'S
ADDRESS THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
AND STOP TAKING IT FROM THE MCO
TAX THAT WE ALL VOTED FOR IN
GOOD FAITH. AND THEN IT WAS
TAKEN TO BACKFILL THE GENERAL
FUND BUDGET. AND LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT OUR HOSPITALS ARE
SUSTAINABLE AND THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE HEALTH
CARE THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS NEED.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR GROVE, NEXT
UP IS SENATOR ROTH. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. YOU KNOW, I THINK
IT WAS A LITTLE BIT UNFAIR TO BE
ASKING THE FLOOR MANAGER SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS SINCE I THINK
ALL OF YOU KNOW, THAT PROBABLY I
SPENT MORE TIME WORKING ON THIS
BILL, TO SOME EXTENT WITH
SENATOR UMBERG THAN ANYBODY IN
THIS ROOM. SO I THINK I'LL TRY
TO TAKE A SWING AT SOME OF YOUR
QUESTIONS. THIS WHOLE BUSINESS
ABOUT UC BEING EXEMPT FROM THE
BILL IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
MISSTATEMENT. èC, FRANKLY,
BECAUSE I DRAFTED THE AMENDMENT,
UC IS SUBJECT TO ATTORNEY
GENERAL REVIEW UNDER THIS BILL.
WHEN YOU SEE ENGAGES IN
TRANSACTIONS WITH PRIVATE EQUITY
ENTITIES, WHERE THE PRIVATE
EQUITY ENTITY RETAINS CONTROL,
AS CONTROL IS DEFINED IN THE
BILL. SO IF YOU SEE ENGAGES IN A
TRANSACTION WITH A PRIVATE
EQUITY ENTITY AND THE PRIVATE
EQUITY ENTITY DOES NOT EXERCISE
CONTROL AS IT'S DEFINED IN THE
BILL, THEN IT SHOULD NOT BE
SUBJECT TO REVIEW BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. NOW, MY
COLLEAGUE ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, THE SENATOR FROM
WHEREVER HE'S FROM, ORANGE
COUNTY, SOMEWHERE HE HE ACTED TO
AND HIS STAFF ACTED TO EXEMPT
HOSPITALS FROM THIS PRIVATE
EQUITY BILL. THAT WAS CERTAINLY
HIS INTENT. NOW SOMEWHERE ALONG
THE LINE WITHIN THE LAST WEEK OR
SO, AS WE WERE TRYING TO DRAFT
THIS AMENDMENT TO DEAL WITH UC'S
CONCERNS ABOUT SITUATIONS WHERE
THEY PARTNER WITH AN ENTITY TO
OPERATE A THIRD ENTITY IN THE
MIDDLE, WHETHER IT'S A REHAB
HOSPITAL OR A SURGERY CENTER OR
SOMEWHERE ELSE. AND WE TRIED TO
DEAL WITH THAT EITHER WITH
PRIVATE EQUITY CONTROL OR NOT.
THE HOSPITALS DECIDED THAT THERE
WAS A THE USE OF A TERM
SOMEWHERE IN THIS BILL. HEALTH
FACILITY OR HEALTH CARE FACILITY.
WELL, HEALTH CARE FACILITIES,
HOSPITALS ARE LICENSED
FACILITIES UNDER HCA. AND
THERE'S A WORD THEY USE, WHETHER
IT'S HEALTH CARE OR HEALTH
FACILITY. AND SOME LAWYERS
SOMEWHERE I AM ONE DECIDED THERE
WAS A BIT OF AMBIGUITY IN THIS
PROCESS. UNFORTUNATELY. THEY
CAME TO THE PARTY A LITTLE TOO
LATE TO GET THIS ISSUE
ADDRESSED. CLEARLY, WE LIKE
EVERY SENTENCE ENDING WITH A
PERIOD COMMA IS USED IN THE
MIDDLE, AND PERFECTION. IF WE
CAN POSSIBLY GET IT. IN THIS
HOUSE OF IMPERFECTION. SO THERE
MAY BE SOME PIECE OF AMBIGUITY
IN THIS BILL HAVING TO DO WITH
HEALTH CARE FACILITY VERSUS
HEALTH FACILITY THAT ULTIMATELY
MAY NEED TO BE CLEANED UP. BUT
THE INTENT, I THINK EVERYONE
WILL AGREE AND THEY REALLY AGREE
IS THAT HOSPITALS ARE NOT
COVERED BY THE REVIEW PORTION OF
THIS PRIVATE EQUITY BILL. I
CAN'T ADDRESS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO'S CONCERNS, BUT I'M
TRYING TO ADDRESS THOSE. SO IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT IF THERE'S ANY
AMBIGUITY, I WON'T BE HERE. MY
COLLEAGUE, THE REAL CHAIR OF THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE FROM STOCKTON,
WON'T BE HERE, BUT THE REST OF
YOU CAN CLEAN THIS UP NEXT YEAR.
AND I HOPEFULLY WILL, ALLOW THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SOMEWHERE TO CLOSE OUT
THIS MEASURE WITHOUT FURTHER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. MR.
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ROSS. SENATOR. SENATOR DALY.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I JUST WANT TO WEIGH IN
ON SOME REALLY THINGS THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN TALKED ABOUT, BEEN
WORKING ON HEALTH CARE FOR THE
LAST 12 YEARS, AND THIS IS A
VERY DIFFICULT ISSUE. PRIVATE
EQUITY IS OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING I
THINK WE SHOULD BE CONCERNED
ABOUT. ABSOLUTELY, BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY, THE WAY I LOOK
AT THIS BILL, FIRST OF ALL, I
THINK YOU CAN TELL BY THE
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION AND, AND
QUITE FRANKLY, A LACK OF, OF, OF
INFORMATION ON THIS SUBJECT TO
MOVE FORWARD, I THINK IS A
MISTAKE, NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO,
WHY WOULD THE LEGISLATURE TURN
OUR POWER OVER TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL? WE ARE. WE ARE IN THE
SPACE. AND WE SAW LAST YEAR WHEN
WE HAD THE HOSPITAL IN THE
VALLEY THAT WAS CLOSED DOWN, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL CAME IN AND HE
HAD SOLE POWER OVER HOW THAT
HOSPITAL WAS GOING TO GO FORWARD.
THIS NOW LIES WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. IF WE WANT TO IN
THE FUTURE, I SHOULD SAY IF YOU
WANT TO, SINCE I WON'T BE HERE,
I WANT TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
I THINK THAT'S THE PROPER BODY
TO DO IT IN, BECAUSE AS WE'VE
HEARD EARLIER TODAY, THIS IS A
VERY UNIQUE LARGE STATE. AND ALL
HEALTH CARE ISN'T DISTRIBUTED
EQUALLY IN CALIFORNIA. SO I'M
GOING TO BE VOTING NO ON THIS
BILL. I THINK IT NEEDS A LOT
MORE WORK. AND I THINK OBVIOUSLY
YOU CAN TELL BY THE TESTIMONY
TODAY THAT IT NEEDS SOME WORK.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I
THINK YOU SHOULD WE SHOULD STOP
THIS BILL AND COME BACK NEXT
YEAR. AND GIVE THE BODY ANOTHER
CHANCE. AND FOR ALL FOR ALL MY
PURPOSES, I'D RATHER SEE IT IN
THIS BODY. I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD GIVE THE POWER TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO WEIGH IN ON
THOSE SITUATIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DARLING. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION, ANY FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING.
NO MICROPHONE'S UP. SENATOR
HURTADO, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I'LL TRY TO ADDRESS AS MANY
QUESTIONS AS POSSIBLE. IN MY
CLOSING, I'LL BEGIN WITH SAYING
THAT GIVEN THAT I ALSO REPRESENT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY, I, I CARE I
DEEPLY CARE ABOUT OUR HEALTH
CARE, NOT JUST FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY, BUT ACROSS THE ACROSS
THE STATE. AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IS WE'RE SEEING PRIVATE EQUITY
ENGAGED IN WAYS THAT WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THEM BEFORE OVER THE LAST
DECADE, AND THEY'RE IMPACTING
OUR COMMUNITIES IN HARMFUL WAYS,
YOU KNOW. THE GOAL OF THIS BILL
IS NOT TO CLOSE HOSPITALS. IT'S
NOT TO REDUCE PATIENT CARE. THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO ENSURE
THAT WHEN THERE ARE INVESTMENTS
MADE IN OUR COMMUNITIES, IN OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM, THAT WE
PROTECT PATIENTS, THAT IS WHAT
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS. AND I
DON'T I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE
IS ANY INTENTION TO SAY, HEY, WE
DON'T WANT PRIVATE EQUITY MONEY
IN OUR INVESTMENTS, IN OUR
COMMUNITIES, THIS, THAT. THIS
BILL IS NOT ABOUT THAT. IT IS TO
HAVE PRIVATE EQUITY INVESTMENTS.
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
KEEP AND SCRUTINIZE ANY BAD
ACTORS. AND SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
VOTING ALLEN. ALVARADO. GIL
ARCHULETA. ASHBY. NØ. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLY. NÓ. DODD DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN GLASER. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE NÓ. HURTADO AYE.
JONES NØ. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN NGUYEN. NÓ NILO. NØ JOBO.
NØ. AYE PORTANTINO. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO SATO. NO. SKINNER. AYE A
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN UMBERG
AL-WAHHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. NÓ IS CALLED THE ABSENT.
MEMBERS. ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL NO. ARCHULETA BECKER. NO
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD DODD.
EGGMAN GLASER. LIMON MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. NEWMAN PORTANTINO
RUBIO. STERN AYE. SEN HURTADO
MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS. WE'RE
NEXT. MOVING TO FILE ITEM 82.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2348.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2348 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS. AN ACT RELATING TO THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY SERVICES
ACT. SENATOR DODD.
MIC DROP. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS. AB 2348
IS A BILL THAT FOLLOWS UP ON
LEGISLATION PASSED EARLIER THIS
SESSION, WHICH DEALS WITH THE
FEATHER ALERT AND ALERT SYSTEM
FOR MISSING INDIGENOUS PERSONS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
FEATHER ALERT IS A TOP
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TRIBES IN COMBATING
THE MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS PERSONS EPIDEMIC.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE MEMBERS. DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE.
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE. SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALVARADO GILL. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DAWLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. OKOBO. AYE.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. AYE
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE
STERN. AYE. UMBERG WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MEMBERS? WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
FULL HOUSE. SO WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE THE ROLL OVER TO GO.
DALLI. AYE MCGUIRE. AYE. PERDUE
AYE. UMBERG. AYE ON A VOTE OF
37. IN FAVOR? NONE AGAINST THE
MEASURE PASSES 38. EXCUSE ME.
38. IN FAVOR? 38. ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW
TO FILE ITEM 12. THIS IS SENATE
BILL 549 BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 549 BY SENATOR NEWMAN AND
AQUILINA GAMING. SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO PRESENT SB 549 THE TRIBAL
NATIONS ACCESS TO JUSTICE ACT,
WHICH IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE AND
WHICH WILL PROVIDE CALIFORNIA'S
INDIAN TRIBES A LIMITED AVENUE
TO SEEK IN STATE COURT A
DECLARATION ON THE LEGALITY OF
SPECIFIC GAMES OPERATED BY
CALIFORNIA'S LICENSED CARDROOMS
PRIOR TO THE YEAR 2000.
CALIFORNIA LAW, AS ARTICULATED
IN THE STATE CONSTITUTION,
EXPLICITLY PROHIBITED THE
OPERATION OF NEVADA AND NEW
JERSEY TYPE CASINOS WITH REGARD
TO CARD GAMES. STATE LAW
PROHIBITED THE FOLLOWING. FIRST,
SEVERAL SPECIFIC CARD GAMES,
SUCH AS 21, ALSO KNOWN AS
BLACKJACK. TWO SO-CALLED BANKED
GAMES WHERE THE HOUSE HAS A
STAKE IN THE OUTCOME OF THE
GAME, AND THREE PERCENTAGE GAMES
WHERE THE HOUSE ENJOYS BETTER
ODDS THAN THE OTHER PLAYERS AT A
TABLE. IN THE YEAR 2000, THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA WERE
EXPLICITLY ASKED UNDER
PROPOSITION ONE A ON THE BALLOT.
THAT YEAR WHETHER CALIFORNIANS,
WHETHER CALIFORNIA'S INDIAN
TRIBES SHOULD BE GRANTED AN
EXCEPTION TO THOSE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROHIBITIONS WITH
THEIR VOTE. A CONVINCING
MAJORITY OF 64% OF CALIFORNIA
VOTERS CHOSE TO GRANT TO THE
TRIBES THE EXCLUSIVE RIGHT TO
OFFER SLOT MACHINES, LOTTERY
GAMES, AND BANC AND PERCENTAGE
CARD GAMES LIKE BLACKJACK AND
BACCARAT. OVER THE COURSE OF
VIRTUALLY ITS ENTIRE HISTORY AS
A STATE, CALIFORNIA LAW HAS
ALLOWED LICENSED CARDROOMS TO
OPERATE ANY CARD GAME NOT
OTHERWISE PROHIBITED. TYPICALLY,
CARDROOM PLAYERS PAY A FEE ON A
PER HAND OR PER HOUR BASIS TO
PLAY THESE GAMES OVER THE COURSE
OF THE MORE THAN TWO DECADES
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF PROP ONE
Ã, HOWEVER, CALIFORNIA'S
CARDROOMS HAVE STEADILY ADDED TO
THEIR OFFERINGS A NUMBER OF
GAMES WHICH ARE FOR ALL INTENTS
AND PURPOSES, INDISTINGUISHABLE
FROM THE CARD GAMES OFFERED AT
LAS VEGAS AND TRIBAL CASINOS. IT
HAS LONG BEEN THE TRIBE'S
CONTENTION THAT THE OFFERING OF
SUCH GAMES IS IN DIRECT CONFLICT
WITH THE PROVISIONS OF PROP ONE
A, BUT BECAUSE OF THE TRIBE'S
LACK OF STANDING IN CALIFORNIA
COURTS, NO COURT HAS BEEN ABLE
TO RULE ON THE EXTENT OR
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL GRANT. THIS LACK
OF CLARITY HAS FORMED THE BASIS
FOR THE LONG STANDING DISPUTE
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA'S INDIAN
TRIBES AND CALIFORNIA'S LICENSED
CARDROOMS. PRIOR ATTEMPTS TO
RESOLVE THIS DISPUTE THROUGH THE
REGULATORY AND LEGISLATIVE
PROCESSES, OR BY ELECTORAL
INITIATIVE, HAVE FAILED. SB 549
SEEKS TO DEFINITIVELY RESOLVE
THIS DISPUTE BY GRANTING
CALIFORNIA'S INDIAN TRIBES
CIRCUMSCRIBED, TIME DELIMITED
LEGAL STANDING, TO SEEK A
DECLARATORY JUDGMENT ON WHETHER
CERTAIN CARD GAMES OFFERED BY
CARDROOMS CARDROOMS ARE IN
VIOLATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. THE CENTRAL
QUESTION OF THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY NOT ABOUT WHICH GAMES
CARDROOMS ARE ALLOWED TO OFFER.
RATHER, THE CENTRAL QUESTION OF
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY WHETHER TO
ALLOW THE OPPORTUNITY FOR A
COURT OF LAW TO ADDRESS THIS NOW
DECADES OLD QUESTION PURELY ON
ITS LEGAL MERITS AND PURSUANT TO
THE VOTER APPROVED PROVISIONS OF
PROP ONE A, THE ASSERTION HAS
BEEN MADE THAT THIS BILL IS AN
EFFORT TO PUT THE CARDROOMS OUT
OF BUSINESS. THIS IS MANIFESTLY
UNTRUE. EVEN IF A COURT, UPON
THE GRANTING OF STANDING UNDER
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL, WERE
TO RULE IN THE TRIBE'S FAVOR,
SOMETHING WHICH IS BY NO MEANS
ASSURED, THE CARDROOMS WOULD
STILL BE FREE TO CONTINUE
OFFERING THOSE GAMES TO WHICH
THEY ARE EXPLICITLY AUTHORIZED.
THERE HAS ALSO BEEN A GOOD DEAL
OF DISCUSSION ABOUT THE SECOND
ORDER IMPACTS. IN THE EVENT THAT
A COURT RULING WERE TO LIMIT THE
TYPES OF GAMES OFFERED BY
CARDROOMS, SPECIFICALLY, THE
PROSPECTIVE ADVERSE IMPACTS ON
JOBS, AS WELL AS THE REVENUES
FOR CITIES IN WHICH CARDROOMS
ARE LOCATED. I'M AMONG THOSE WHO
ARE QUITE SYMPATHETIC TO THOSE
POSSIBILITIES, ESPECIALLY THEIR
EFFECT UPON WORKERS. BUT AGAIN,
AT ITS ESSENCE, THIS BILL IS NOT
A MATTER OF OUR PREFERENCE. IT
IS A MATTER OF LAW. AGAIN, AND
TO BE CLEAR, SB 549 DOES NOT
TAKE A SIDE IN THIS REGARD. IT
NEITHER VINDICATES NOR CODIFIES
THE ARGUMENTS OF THE TRIBES, NOR
DOES IT DECLARE CARDROOMS IN
VIOLATION OF THE LAW. IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THERE IS
NO GUARANTEE AS TO HOW A COURT
MIGHT RULE IN THIS MATTER, BUT
IF THE LEGISLATURE REFUSES TO
GRANT THE LEGAL STANDING NEEDED
FOR THE COURTS TO WEIGH IN, WE
REMAIN NO CLOSER TO A RESOLUTION
ON THIS LONG DISPUTE. THE
CALIFORNIA TRIBES DO DESERVE
THEIR DAY IN COURT. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. SEN.
NEWMAN. I HAVE MICROPHONES UP
FROM SENATOR UMBERG AND SENATOR
MIN. SENATOR UMBERG THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. THE QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR. SEN. NEWMAN, WILL
YOU TAKE A QUESTION? IT DOES
STRIKE ME AS ODD. IT'S ODD. I'VE
BEEN SITTING NEXT TO THIS MAN
FOR ABOUT A WEEK, AND HE'S HAD
AMPLE TIME TO ASK ME ALL MANNER
OF QUESTIONS, BUT. BUT I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE THAT QUESTION NOW. WELL,
MR. PRESIDENT, SENATOR, I WOULD
HAVE ASKED THE QUESTION. BUT YOU
SEE, MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY IS SO INTENT ON READING
EVERY WORD OF EVERY BILL THAT IT
WAS VERY DIFFICULT TO INTERRUPT
HIM DURING THAT WEEK LONG
PERIOD. SENATOR UMBERG, WHAT'S
YOUR QUESTION? WHAT IS YOUR
QUESTION? SO I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS. FIRST, WE ACTUALLY
DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE TO FURTHER
REFINE AND DEFINE CERTAIN TERMS
IN JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. AND JUST
SO WE HAVE CLARIFICATION, AS YOU
MENTIONED A MOMENT AGO, THE TERM
DE NOVO IS USED IN SB 549. AND
AS I UNDERSTAND DE NOVO MEANS
THAT THE COURT IS NOT BOUND BY
FACTUAL FINDINGS OF OTHER
TRIBUNALS OR OTHER FINDERS OF
FACT, I'M CURIOUS IF THAT'S IF
THAT'S WHAT IT MEANS, IS THAT
WHAT IT MEANS? IT JUST THAT,
SENATOR NEWMAN, YOU CAN ANSWER
IT NOW. OR ARE YOU HAPPY? HAPPY
TO ANSWER IT, SIR. THAT IS, IN
FACT, WHAT IT MEANS. SO THE
ADDITION OF THE DE NOVO STANDARD
WAS ADDED BY ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY.
AND IT WAS, FOR THE AVOIDANCE OF
DOUBT. AND SO TO PREEMPT ANY
CONCERN THAT, EXECUTIVE AGENCIES
PRIOR DECISIONS MIGHT INFLUENCE
THE OUTCOME OR CONDUCT OF A
COURT CASE. SO THE ADDITION OF
THE STANDARD WAS SIMPLY TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT, AS WITH ALL SUPERIOR
COURT CASES, THEY THEY THEY
WOULD BE TAKEN ON A DE NOVO
BASIS. OKAY. SO THAT IN TERMS OF
PRIOR CASE LAW, OTHER LEGAL
AUTHORITIES, IT DOESN'T OVERRIDE
OTHER LEGAL AUTHORITIES OR IT
DOESN'T PROVIDE OR EMPOWER THE
TRIAL COURT JUDGE TO DISREGARD
CASE LAW AND OTHER LEGAL
AUTHORITIES. THAT IS CORRECT.
AND IT WAS SIMPLY TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR AS A MATTER OF RECORD.
OKAY AND MR. PRESIDENT, A SECOND
QUESTION CONCERNING
CONSOLIDATION OF ACTIONS. THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF PARTIES THAT ARE
LOCATED THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I
READ IN THE BILL THAT THE
ACTIONS THAT ARE BEING
CONSOLIDATED IN SACRAMENTO. IS
IT YOUR INTENT THAT THERE BE ONE
TRIAL THAT RESOLVES THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED BY. AND SO
THAT IS THE INTENT OF THE BILL
TO HAVE A, A LIMITED WINDOW FOR
ANY PROCEEDING AND ONE SINGLE
ACTION. AND THAT WAS, THAT WAS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GOT AN
ANSWER FROM A COURT WITHOUT
EXPOSING ANY OF THE PARTIES,
ESPECIALLY THE CARDROOMS, TO
ADVERSE EFFECTS FROM COST OF
LITIGATION. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR UMBERG. I SEE
MICROPHONES UP FROM SENATOR MIN.
SENATOR ATKINS, SENATOR ALLEN,
SENATOR AND SENATOR GROVE,
SENATOR MIN. THANK YOU. MR.
PRESIDENT. EARLIER TODAY AT
DINNER, I WAS AWARDED THE MEDAL
FOR THE. I WASN'T PLANNING ON
SPEAKING AWARD BECAUSE I SAY
APPARENTLY THE MOST I WASN'T
PLANNING ON SPEAKING, BUT I
WASN'T PLANNING ON SPEAKING ON
THIS BILL, MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FULLERTON ASKED ME GRACIOUSLY,
AND PERSISTENTLY TO SPEAK ON
THIS BILL, BUT I WILL JUST SAY
THIS I DON'T HAVE A DOG IN THIS
PARTICULAR FIGHT. I DON'T HAVE
ANY TRIBAL CASINOS OR CARDROOMS
IN MY DISTRICT. FOR ME, THIS
BILL IS ABOUT A SIMPLE
PRINCIPLE, WHICH IS THAT
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE THE CHANCE
TO HAVE THEIR DAY IN COURT TO
LITIGATE THEIR RIGHTS. CURRENT
LOOPHOLES WITH THE WAY THAT WE
TREAT TRIBES IN THIS STATE HAVE
PREVENTED THE TRIBES FROM BEING
ABLE TO EXERCISE AND TRY TO
LITIGATE THEIR RIGHTS. SO THAT
IS WHY I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL, AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO DO THE SAME. ALL
RIGHT. I HAVE MICROPHONES UP
FROM SENATOR ATKINS GROVE,
CORTESE, AND LEMON. SENATOR
ATKINS, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL, AND I
FULLY INTENDED TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL. I WANT TO START BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THE HARD WORK OF
THE AUTHOR, WHO PUT IN MORE THAN
TWO YEARS OF WORK ON SB 549.
IT'S NOT EASY AUTHORING
LEGISLATION THAT INVOLVES A
DISPUTE, ESPECIALLY ONE AS LONG
STANDING AS A SUBJECT ADDRESSED
IN THIS BILL. AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FULLERTON NOTED, THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL IS TO
PROVIDE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
LIMITED LEGAL STANDING TO SEEK
JUDICIAL REVIEW ON WHETHER
CERTAIN GAMES OPERATED BY THE
STATE'S CARD CLUBS ARE
CONSTITUTIONAL AND THUS LEGAL OR
NOT. THEY TAKE A HUGE RISK IN
BRINGING THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION FORWARD. BUT I WOULD
SAY THIS LEGAL QUESTION NEEDS TO
BE SETTLED ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
STATE GAMING REGULATORS HAVE
STRUGGLED TO SETTLE THIS MATTER
FOR OVER 20 YEARS, AND HAVE
FAILED TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY
EITHER REGULATION OR
ENFORCEMENT. I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES ALREADY HAVE PRETTY
MUCH SPOKEN ON THE LEGAL ASPECT
OF THIS. BUT, YOU KNOW, AGAIN, I
WANT TO SAY THIS HAS BEEN IN
PROCESS FOR MORE THAN TWO YEARS.
THIS PARTICULAR BILL, THE ISSUE
FOR QUITE A LONG TIME. I WANT TO
ADD MY THANKS TO THE PRO TEM FOR
ALLOWING THIS TO THIS PROCESS TO
HAPPEN. I WANT TO THANK THE
SPEAKER, WE'RE ABLE TO BE IN
THIS MOMENT BECAUSE THE LEADERS
ALLOWED THIS TO MOVE FORWARD,
AND I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEM.
BUT TONIGHT I WANT TO ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SOVEREIGN
NATIONS AND THE TRIBES. TOO MANY
TO ACTUALLY NAME. BUT I
ABSOLUTELY MUST THANK ONE OF MY
LOCAL SOVEREIGN NATIONS. AND
THAT IS VÀ ALEJO'S AND CHAIRMAN
CHRISMAN, AND CERTAINLY AND IN
PARTICULAR TO HARRY BIGKNIFE, IT
WAS THEIR DILIGENCE AND THEIR
DRIVE AND DEDICATION TO REALLY
PUSH THIS ISSUE FORWARD AND NOT
ONLY HAVE DISCUSSIONS WITH US IN
THE LEGISLATURE, BUT THEIR OWN
FELLOW TRIBE MEMBERS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE TO MAKE THE CASE TO
TAKE THIS CHANCE, TAKE THIS RISK
TO SETTLE A LEGAL QUESTION. YOU
KNOW, I KNOW THAT THE VOTERS
DECIDED THE ISSUE OF GAMING
QUITE A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO, AND
I THINK IT IS REALLY OUR
RESPONSIBILITY, GIVEN THAT IT
HAS NOT BEEN RESOLVED BY
PREVIOUS ATTORNEY GENERALS, THAT
WE STEP FORWARD AND PUT THIS
LEGISLATION FORWARD AND GIVE
THEM THEIR DAY IN COURT. THAT IS
FAIR. THAT IS JUST THAT IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. AGAIN, I
REALLY WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FULLERTON FOR
BEING THE LEAD ON THIS, AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT AND
YOUR AYE VOTE TONIGHT. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. NEXT UP, SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I'VE GIVEN THIS BILL A LOT OF
THOUGHT OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS,
ESPECIALLY THIS LAST WEEK WHEN
BOTH SIDES WERE REACHING OUT. I
SPENT NUMEROUS CONVERSATIONS AND
TEXT MESSAGES WITH BOTH OUR
SOVEREIGN NATION FRIENDS AND OUR
CARDROOMS THAT ARE BUSINESSES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
OPERATE VERY NICE BUSINESSES. I
HAVE A GREAT ONE, A COUPLE IN
FRESNO AND ONE IN BAKERSFIELD
THAT ARE VERY GOOD TO OUR
COMMUNITY, MOST OF US ON THIS
FLOOR RECOGNIZE, THAT TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE COMPLETELY AND
SEPARATE SOVEREIGN NATIONS
INSIDE THE STATE BORDERS OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT THEY ARE VERY
THEIR SOVEREIGNTY HAS LIMITS AND
THEIR ABILITY TO ACCESS
INSTRUMENTS LIKE THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT. I WAS SURPRISED
WHEN WE WENT TO A EVENT THAT THE
TRIBAL COMMUNITY PUT ON WHERE IF
THERE IS A MISSING INDIGENOUS
PERSON, THAT THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITY CANNOT CROSS THOSE
LINES AND GO TO RESCUE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE MISSING,
AND THE VICE VERSA, OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, REGARDLESS OF WHAT
IT IS, CAN'T GO AND CROSS THE
TRIBE LINES. I THINK THESE ARE
ALL THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT, BECAUSE SOVEREIGNTY
IS SO IMPORTANT. BUT THINGS LIKE
THIS NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
KELLER CALIFORNIA VOTERS, HAVE
CONFIRMED THAT TRIBES HAVE
EXCLUSIVE RIGHTS TO OPERATE SLOT
MACHINES AND BANKED CARD GAMES
ON INDIAN LANDS UNDER THE
COMPACTS NEGOTIATED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND RATIFIED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE. THE FIGHT OVER THE
SCOPE OF THE CARD ROOM GAMING
AUTHORITY HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
20 YEARS, WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE UNWILLING OR UNABLE TO
EXPLICITLY DEFINE WHAT
CONSTITUTES A BANKED CARD GAME,
ON NON-TRIBAL LANDS, TRIBES HAVE
ATTEMPTED TO SUE IN COURT, BUT
HAVE BEEN DENIED LEGAL STANDING
BECAUSE OF THEIR SOVEREIGN
STATUS, A GENERAL RULE, I'M NOT
IN FAVOR OF EXPANDING
LITIGATION. YOU KNOW, I SPEAK
AGAINST PAGA, AND I SPEAK
AGAINST LITIGATION ALL THE TIME.
BUT THIS IS A BUSINESS TO
BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP. THE TRIBE
ALSO HAS A BUSINESS THAT, OTHER
BUSINESSES WOULD SUE OVER FOR
COPYRIGHT ISSUES OR INFRINGEMENT
RIGHTS OR COMPETITIVE ISSUES,
FROM A BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIP, THE PROPER VENUE
TO SETTLE IS ARE THESE
DISAGREEMENTS THAT WE HAVE ON A
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIP IS IN COURT, BUT
ONE OF THE INDIVIDUALS OR ONE OF
THE ENTITIES THAT IS INVOLVED IN
THIS SITUATION FOR OVER 20 YEARS
DOES NOT HAVE THE STANDING TO GO
TO COURT AND CONTRARY TO THE
SOVEREIGNTY THAT THEY HAVE, THEY
DON'T HAVE THEIR OWN JUDICIAL
SYSTEM. SB 4549 SEEKS TO ADDRESS
WHAT IS AT HEART IS A
DISAGREEMENT BETWEEN BUSINESSES
THAT WOULD ALLOW A NARROW
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS LAWSUIT TO
LET THE COURT DECIDE THE STATUS
OF EXCLUSIVITY WITH CARD GAMES.
THE CARD CLUBS HAVE SPOKEN, THAT
I'VE SPOKEN TO ARE WELL RUN CARD
ROOMS. THEY HAVE GAMES THAT ARE
APPROVED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, BUREAU OF GAMBLING
CONTROL. THEY HAVE A LOT OF GUYS
AND PEOPLE THAT COME IN AND JUST
RENT TABLES AND HAVE FUN AND EAT
DINNER AND EAT FOOD, AND THEY'RE
JUST INCREDIBLE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS, TO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
IN OUR AREAS OR MY DISTRICT, I'M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH ALL THE CARD
ROOMS IN THE STATE. IF THERE'S
SOMETHING GOING ON THAT SHOULD
BE ADDRESSED BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE TRIBAL COMMUNITIES ARE OUR
TRIBAL PARTNERS, ARE OUR TRIBAL
NATIONS ARE, HAVE EXCLUSIVITY
BECAUSE THE VOTERS, VOTERS
ALLOWED THAT TO HAPPEN. SO THE
QUESTION FOR ME IS, SHOULD
TRIBES BE GIVEN STANDING IN THIS
VERY NARROW WINDOW, SHOULD
TRIBES BE GIVEN STANDING TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO COURT
COLLECTIVELY? NOT ALL OF THEM
FILING LAWSUITS, DIFFERENT ONES.
AND THIS IS GOING TO GO ON FOR
ANOTHER 20 YEARS. I APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR NARROWLY WRITING
THIS. BILL SO THAT THERE'S LIKE
A ONE AND DONE IS WHAT I'M
CALLING IT, LIKE A ONE AND DONE.
AND THIS DECISION THAT HAS BEEN
GRAPPLED WITH BETWEEN OUR
SOVEREIGN NATION, PARTNERS OR
COMMUNITIES AND THE CARD ROOM
SITUATION, BECAUSE THE CARD
ROOMS HAVE JUST AS MUCH
AUTHORITY TO OPERATE WHEN
THEY'VE GIVEN CONTROL BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE,
THEY'VE ALSO GOT APPROVAL FOR
EVERY GAME THAT THEY HAVE AT THE
TABLE. THEY ALSO GET LOCAL
ORDINANCE CONTROL WHERE THEY
SAY, HEY, YOU CAN OPERATE IN
THIS AREA AND YOU CAN HAVE SO
MANY TABLES, SOME OF THAT IS
LEGISLATED HERE IN THE BUILDING
AS WELL. BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU
THAT, THESE SOVEREIGN ENTITIES
ALSO HAVE A BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITY. AND THESE WHAT THE
VOTERS HAVE ALLOWED THESE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES TO DO IS TO BECOME
SELF-SUFFICIENT, BUY BACK LAND.
I JUST SHARED AND GOT THE
COMPACT FOR TABLE MOUNTAIN, AND
I READ THE CHAIRWOMAN STATEMENT
WHERE THEY BOUGHT BACK THEIR
LOCAL CEMETERIES. SO THEY'VE
GIVEN THIS OPPORTUNITY, IS GIVEN
TO THEM FOR SELF-SUFFICIENCY AND
RESTORING THEIR CULTURAL
HERITAGE. AND LIKE I SAID, I
THINK THEIR SOVEREIGNTY NEEDS TO
BE RESPECTED. BUT I ALSO KNOW
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
EXCEPTIONS IN SOME CASES TO
WHERE THEY CAN HAVE ACCESS TO
BASICALLY THE THREE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT THAT WE HAVE, AND ONE
OF THEM IS A JUDICIAL BRANCH
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE. I'VE
THOUGHT LONG AND HARD ABOUT
THIS. I'M NOT IN FAVOR OF BIG
LAWSUITS, BUT I BELIEVE THAT
THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION, I
WILL BE LETTING YOU ALL KNOW
THAT I'M VOTING AYE ON THIS TO
GIVE THESE TRIBES STANDING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO THAT
WE CAN ADDRESS THIS ISSUE ONCE
AND FOR ALL. THANK YOU, SENATOR
GROVE. SENATOR CORTESE. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, IT IT DOES
PAY ME TODAY TO HAVE TO RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO A BILL, FROM AN
AUTHOR I RESPECT GREATLY. AND
SEEM TO HAVE BEEN AT ODDS WITH A
COUPLE OF TIMES ON ON BILLS THE
LAST COUPLE OF DAYS. BUT MY
CITY, THE CITY OF SAN JOSE,
GENERATES CURRENTLY ABOUT $32
MILLION A YEAR FROM CARD ROOM
TAXES. THE DEVELOPMENT OF THOSE
CARD ROOMS, AFTER HAVING HAD
THEM GRANDFATHERED IN FOR
DECADES AND DECADES, WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS PUT TO VOTER
APPROVAL ABOUT THE TIME THAT I
BECAME VICE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
SAN JOSE. THE ELECTED OFFICIALS
IN THAT CITY, ME AMONG THEM,
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
VOTERS WANTED US TO ALLOW A
STEADY EXPANSION OF THE CARD
ROOMS IN ORDER TO USE THOSE
DOLLARS FOR POLICE SERVICES AND
FIREFIGHTERS. THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE IS CURRENTLY UNDERSTAFFED
BY ABOUT 500 POLICE OFFICERS IN
A NUMBER OF FIREFIGHTERS. THE
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE AND I DO
ASSOCIATE THESE COMMENTS WITH
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD,
IS THERE'S AN UNLEVEL PLAYING
FIELD SET UP HERE WITH ONE PARTY
WHICH HAS SOVEREIGN IMMUNITY,
THAT IS ALLOWED TO GO INTO COURT
AND GET DECLARATORY DECLARATORY
RELIEF. EXCUSE ME, AND AT LEAST,
AT LEAST PETITION FOR IT WHERE
THE OTHER PARTY, THE CARD ROOMS
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
THE TRIBE. THE GAMING TRIBES,
THE CASINOS, AS AS A PARTY TO
ANY SUIT BECAUSE OF SOVEREIGN
IMMUNITY. AND I'M NOT SURE IF
THAT ARRANGEMENT STATUTORILY
WILL HOLD UP IN COURT LATER ON.
PERHAPS IF THIS STATUTE GETS
PASSED INTO LAW, SIGNED INTO
LAW, I'M SURE IT'LL BE LITIGATED
AND MAYBE THAT WILL BE SORTED
OUT AT THAT TIME. BUT IN THE
MEANWHILE, IF THERE'S ANY KIND
OF A STAY ON THE CURRENT GROWTH
OF CARD ROOM SERVICES, OF CARD
ROOM GAMING IN THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE, IT'S GOING TO BE A
TREMENDOUS HIT TO THE CITY. IT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BE DEVASTATING FOR CITY
GOVERNMENT THAT'S ALREADY
DEALING WITH DEFICITS AND WITH
THAT I WOULD I WOULD URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. OKAY, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, I KNOW THIS IS A
GOOD, ROBUST DEBATE. WE HAVE A
LONG NIGHT AHEAD OF US. STILL, I
HAVE MICROPHONES UP FROM SENATOR
LIMÓN HURTADO WILK. SO WE'LL GO
TO SENATOR LEMON NEXT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MEMBERS, TODAY I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB 549, AND I
DO SO AS A MEMBER WHO HAS BOTH A
TRIBAL CASINO AND A CARD ROOM IN
THE DISTRICT. AND MY PERSPECTIVE
ON WHY I AM HERE TODAY AND
SUPPORTING THIS BILL IS ONE THAT
LOOKS AT PAST HISTORY AND LOOKS
AT TIMES WHERE OUR LAWS HAVE NOT
ALLOWED FOR COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED AND COMMUNITIES
WHO HAVE HISTORICALLY HAD
CHALLENGES TO HAVE CLARITY. AND
WHEN I THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE IN A DISTRICT THAT
REPRESENTS BOTH CARDROOMS AND,
THAT HAS A TRIBE IN OUR DISTRICT,
I WENT BACK TO A FEW TIMES WHERE
OUR STATE HAS HAD TO WEIGH IN TO
PROVIDE THAT LEGAL CLARITY FOR
SOME OF THESE ISSUES. SO, FOR
EXAMPLE, IN 1946, OUR STATE
WEIGHED IN FOR MENDEZ VERSUS
WESTMINSTER, WHEN WHICH FOUND
SEGREGATED SCHOOLS TO BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. THAT WAS A
DECISION AND CLARITY THAT CAME
FROM OUR COURTS. THEN IN 1948,
PEREZ VERSUS SHARPE DECIDED,
WHICH WAS DECIDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT TO
OVERTURN THE STATE'S BAN ON
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE. BECAUSE
OUR LAWS WERE NOT CLEAR. IN
1954, HERNANDEZ VERSUS TEXAS WAS
THE FIRST CASE THAT RECOGNIZED
AN EXTENDED CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO MEXICAN AMERICANS. AGAIN,
BECAUSE OUR LAWS WERE ABSENT IN
1978, MADRIGAL VERSUS QUILLIGAN,
WHICH WAS A LANDMARK CASE
AGAINST THE UNAUTHORIZED
STERILIZATION OF MEXICAN WOMEN
IN CALIFORNIA, AND THAT WAS
DECIDED THROUGH THE COURTS. AND
MOST RECENTLY, IN 2017, WE HAD
THE COURTS DECIDE ON WHETHER OR
NOT DACA STUDENTS WERE ELIGIBLE
FOR LOANS IN OUR STATE. IN ALL
OF THESE CASES, WE HAVE HAD LAWS
THAT DON'T CLARIFY THAT, DON'T
PROVIDE ANSWERS FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND I THINK BACK TO
WHAT THIS MEANS JUST FOR ME
PERSONALLY, TO KNOW THAT THESE
LAWS ARE PART OF A HISTORY FOR
OUR STATE, FOR OUR COMMUNITIES,
BUT ALSO FOR ME IN MANY WAYS.
AND I THINK BACK TO THE FIRST
PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY, OF OUR
STATE, OF OUR COMMUNITY WHO
UNFORTUNATELY DON'T HAVE THE
LEGAL STANDING TO BRING A CASE
BEFORE OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM. THE
INABILITY TO ACCESS OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS INJUSTICE. IT'S
UNJUST. AND SO FOR ME, I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS WITH THIS
PERSPECTIVE. AND IT'S A
DIFFICULT DECISION. BUT I THINK
A REALLY IMPORTANT ONE, BECAUSE
WE ARE AT THE POINT OVER DECADES
OF THIS CONVERSATION WHERE IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE A
DETERMINATION ON THIS ONGOING
POLICY ISSUE, THAT WE'VE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO SOLVE, AND WE'VE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO LEGISLATE. I
THINK THAT THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
A JUDGE TO HEAR BOTH SIDES AND
MAKE A DECISION AND SOLVE FOR A
PROBLEM THAT CONTINUES IN OUR
COMMUNITY. I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT MANY COMMUNITIES RELY ON
THE SUPPORT FROM BOTH
COMMUNITIES, FROM BOTH ENTITIES
AND THAT THIS IS DIFFICULT, BUT
WE HAVE TO TURN TO THE COURTS
AND THIS IS THE TIME TO TURN TO
THE COURTS, BECAUSE OUR LEGAL
SYSTEM EXISTS FOR THIS VERY
REASON TO INTERPRET AND DECIDE
IF A LAW IS BEING FOLLOWED OR
BROKEN. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. NEXT UP IS SENATOR WILK.
WOW, THAT WAS LOUD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I WANT
TO I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR COMING FORWARD WITH THIS
MEASURE AND ALL OF HIS WORK ON
THIS AS THE BRONZE, BRONZE MEDAL
AWARD WINNER, AS MOST
BIPARTISAN. I'M HAPPY TO
ANNOUNCE THAT I'M A COAUTHOR OF
THIS BILL, AND I DON'T THINK
I'LL BE BREAKING ANY NEW GROUND
HERE. AND I'M GOING TO KEEP MY
COMMENTS WAY SHORTER THAN I
ORIGINALLY INTENDED, BECAUSE I
THINK WE'VE COVERED A LOT OF IT.
BUT TONIGHT'S MY LAST NIGHT. I
GUESS WE MAYBE HAVE A SPECIAL
SESSION, BUT IT'S MY LAST NIGHT.
I'VE BEEN HERE 12 YEARS NOW, AND
DURING THAT TIME WE'VE HAD THREE
ATTORNEY GENERALS HARRIS IN
2017, BECERRA IN 2020 AND NOW
BONTA IN 2023, WHO HAD ISSUED
GUIDELINES ON THIS TOPIC. BUT
THOSE EFFORTS WERE DERAILED BY
THE CARDROOMS, WHO PREFER TO
OPERATE UNDER THE AMBIGUITY OF
THE STATUS QUO. SB FOUR 549 DOES
NOT PICK WINNERS OR LOSERS. IT
DOES NOT DOES NOT DEBATE THE
MERITS OF EITHER SIDE. IT SIMPLY
ALLOWS THE SUPERIOR COURT OF
CALIFORNIA TO DETERMINE ONE
THING WHETHER A CERTAIN
CONTROLLED GAMES OPERATED BY
CALIFORNIA CARD CLUBS, OR
BANKING GAMES, OR BANKING GAMES
THAT VIOLATE CALIFORNIA LAW. THE
CURRENT SYSTEM THAT WE THE
CURRENT SYSTEM, HAS FAILED US
AND THE STATUS QUO THAT BENEFITS
ONE SIDE WILL DISADVANTAGE. THE
OTHER IS INHERENTLY UNFAIR. SO
SB 549, ALL IT IS ABOUT IT'S
ABOUT FAIRNESS. AND THIS BILL
WILL BRING OBJECTIVITY AND
FAIRNESS TO THE PROCESS THAT
CLEARLY IS BROKEN. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE ANY FURTHER? SENATOR
ALLEN, JUST A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR. WILL YOU TAKE A
QUESTION? SENATOR NEWMAN, SO
GIVEN THE SOME OF THE
SUBSTANTIAL JUDICIARY QUESTIONS
THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
JUDICIARY CHAIR, DO YOU HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING, SENATOR, AS TO
WHY THIS DIDN'T GO THROUGH
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE? SENATOR
NEWMAN, GO AHEAD. YEAH, SO I DO.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S IN THE
NATURE OF THIS HOUSE. SO TO BE
CLEAR, THIS BILL WAS AMENDED
LAST YEAR. IT WAS HEARD JULY 5TH
OF LAST YEAR IN THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY. IT
THEN SAT IN THE ASSEMBLY FOR A
YEAR. IT WAS IT WAS HEARD AGAIN
ON JULY 2ND BY ASSEMBLY GO. AND
THEN IT HAD TO WAIT FOR ANOTHER
MONTH TO GO THROUGH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS. AND SO THIS IS
IN THE NATURE OF, OF THINGS
HERE. AND SO IT'S UNFORTUNATE,
BUT IT WOULD BE MORE UNFORTUNATE
IF WE DIDN'T TAKE THIS UP FOR
ANOTHER TWO YEAR SESSION. AND SO
ABOUT THAT, I MAKE NO APOLOGIES.
SENATOR ALLEN, ON YOUR OWN TIME.
WELL, IT IS STRANGE THAT THAT
BECAUSE THE BILL WAS SO
CONTROVERSIAL, WE'RE HEARING IT
AT 830 AT NIGHT ON THE FINAL
DAY. BY THE WAY, THE BILL HAS A
LOT OF MERITS, AND MANY OF THEM
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED TODAY ON THE
FLOOR. BUT I DO THINK THAT THIS
WOULD HAVE BENEFITED A GREAT
DEAL FROM HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HEARD IN JUDICIARY,
PREFERABLY BEFORE THE AMENDMENT
DEADLINE. AND I JUST IT IS SUCH
A YOU'RE RIGHT, SENATOR. WHAT A
STRANGE PHENOMENON THAT THAT
THAT THE CONTROVERSY OF THIS
BILL LED TO IT BEING TAKEN UP SO
LATE WITH SO LITTLE REVIEW WHEN
I THINK THAT THE CIRCUMSTANCES
CALLED FOR JUST THE OPPOSITE.
SENATOR HURTADO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE 4549 AS A PROUD COAUTHOR
OF SB 49 WOULD PROVIDE A MEASURE
OF EQUITY TO TRIBAL NATIONS BY
PERMITTING CALIFORNIA'S TRIBES
TO FINALLY HAVE ACCESS TO THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM, TO DEFEND THE
ECONOMIC SOVEREIGNTY THAT THEY
FOUGHT SO HARD TO ACHIEVE.
COLLEAGUES, I URGE A VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE. ALL RIGHT. ANYBODY
ELSE WANT TO BE HEARD ON THIS?
ANY OTHER SENATOR WANT TO BE
HEARD SEEING NONE. SENATOR
NEWMAN, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU. SO I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES, MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD. I MEAN, FROM
MERCED. I'M LIKE, WHAT?
BAKERSFIELD, MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA CLARITA WHO WAS THE PROUD
WINNER OF THE MOST THE BRONZE
MEDAL FOR MOST BIPARTISAN. AND
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
WHO WILL SOMEDAY WIN THE GOLD
MEDAL FOR THE I'M NOT PLANNING
TO ASK TO SPEAK AGAIN AWARD. SO
YOU KNOW, THIS HAS BEEN A ROBUST
DEBATE AND TO BE CLEAR, THIS
MEASURE DOES NOT SEEK TO RESOLVE
THIS ISSUE VIA THE STATUTE
ITSELF. ALL IT SIMPLY DOES IS
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
COURT TO RULE ON THIS MATTER
DEFINITIVELY. AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE, OTHER COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD SAID, THE INTENT
HERE IS TO HAVE A ONE AND DONE
SITUATION WHERE WE GET
RESOLUTION FROM A COURT OF LAW
AND PUT THIS MATTER BEHIND US TO
THE BENEFIT OF THE STATE AS A
WHOLE. AND AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA BARBARA POINTED OUT, ONE
OF OUR MOST BASIC RIGHTS AND
FUNDAMENTAL EXPECTATIONS AS
CITIZENS IS THE ASSURANCE IN THE
EVENT OF INJURY OR INJUSTICE, TO
HAVE OUR DAY IN COURT. THIS IS
EXACTLY AND NOTHING MORE AND
NOTHING LESS, WHAT THIS MEASURE
DOES. AND FOR THAT REASON I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE THIS EVENING, ALL
DEBATE HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
ALVARADO. GILL. Ã. ARCHULETA
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE BECKER.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. NO.
DAWLEY AYE. DODD. NO DURAZO.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ GROVE. AYE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. AYE LAIRD. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE MENGIBAR. I
MEAN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
AYE. NILO OKOBO AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL CUEVAS. STERN AYE. UMBERG
WAHAB. WIENER. I WILL. AYE. WE
HAVE A FULL HOUSE, SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL ONE
LAST TIME. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE.
ARCHULETA BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD
DURAZO. GONZALEZ AYE. LAIRD. AYE
MILO. RUBIO AYE. CUEVAS UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. ON A VOTE OF 32 IN
FAVOR. TWO AGAINST THE MEASURE.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
89, FILE ITEM 89 IS SB 1070 BY
SENATOR PADILLA. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ HOLD ON, HOLD ON
MOMENTS I WENT. NAZARIAN SENATOR
PADILLA. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1070 BY SENATOR
PADILLA. AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS. SENATOR
PADILLA, HOLD ON. SENATOR
PADILLA, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
APOLOGIES FOR THE DELAY. 1070 IS
BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY. THIS
BILL AUTHORIZES IMPERIAL VALLEY
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT TO PLACE A
PERMANENT FUNDING SOURCE
MECHANISM ON THE BALLOT ON OR
BEFORE NOVEMBER 2026 ELECTION,
INSTEAD OF THE MARCH 2024 OR
NOVEMBER 24TH ELECTION IN 23.
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED AB 908
TO FORM THE IMPERIAL VALLEY
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT, A COUNTY
WIDE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM TO
STABILIZE HEALTH CARE. ONE OF
THE STATE'S MOST UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. PARTIES INVOLVED
HERE HAVE NOT PROVIDED CRUCIAL
INFORMATION NEEDED TO RECOMMEND
A FUNDING SOURCE AS REQUIRED BY
STATUTE, IN TIME TO HAVE
SUCCESSFUL STAND UP. MORE TIME
IS THEREFORE NEEDED. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY SENATOR WANT
TO BE HEARD ON IT. SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALVARADO, GO. NØ. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. I BECKER.
AYE. BLAKESBURG. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALI NØ. DODD DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN I GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ.
GROVE NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES NO.
LAIRD. AYE LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO COBO.
NO. PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. NO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GONZALEZ AYE. MIN ON A VOTE OF
31. IN FAVOR. AYE AGAINST THE
ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS ARE ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NOW TO FILE ITEM 22. THIS
IS SB 1283. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1283 BY
SENATOR STERN. AN ACT RELATING
TO PUPILS. SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS IT IS VERY HEALTHY
AND I WOULD SAY ACTUALLY CAN BE
LIFE SAVING TO JUST DISCONNECT
FOR A BIT. I KNOW I JUST DID IT
FOR A DAY. I WAS NOT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA UNTIL ABOUT 20S AGO, WHEN
OUR STUDENTS ARE IN SCHOOL ON
SNAPCHAT OR ON THEIR INSTAGRAM
PAGE, OR ON FACEBOOK, CHECKING
THE STATUS OF THEIR LIKES OR IN
FACT, SOMETIMES USING THAT
SOCIAL MEDIA TO SHAME OR BULLY
OTHER STUDENTS, IT'S NOT ONLY A
DISTRACTION, IT'S A HARM. THIS
IS WHY THE U.S. SURGEON GENERAL
WARNED THAT THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO ARE SPENDING MORE THAN THREE
HOURS A DAY ON SOCIAL MEDIA FACE
TWO TIMES THE MENTAL HEALTH
RISKS THAT THOSE WHO DON'T
DEPRESSION, ANXIETY AND WORSE,
SUICIDE IS ON THE RISE AMONG
TEENS. AND THERE'S A PROVEN
CORRESPONDENCE. THIS BILL WILL
FINALLY GIVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THE CLARIFICATION AND LAW THAT
THEY DO. IN FACT, HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO NOT ONLY LIMIT BUT
BAN SOCIAL MEDIA ON THEIR
CAMPUSES ALTOGETHER. BUT THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY
ALSO IMPORTANTLY, CLARIFY THAT
THE BILL DOES NOT AUTHORIZE SOME
KIND OF SURVEILLANCE OF STUDENTS
TO ENFORCE THIS POLICY.
SPECIFICALLY, THE BILL DOES NOT
AUTHORIZE MONITORING, COLLECTING
OR OTHERWISE ACCESSING STUDENTS
ONLINE ACTIVITIES. SO WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS, BOTH THE ACLU,
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
AND THE LGBTQ CAUCUS THAT HAD
CONCERNS THAT SCHOOLS COULD BE
USING THIS LEGISLATION, IN OTHER
WORDS, TO SURVEIL STUDENTS,
SOCIAL MEDIA ACTIVITIES, THEY'VE
ALL GONE NEUTRAL. SO I THINK WE
HAVE A REALLY IMPORTANT WORK
PRODUCT HERE, AND WE HOPE THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HEAR OUR CALL
AND STEP UP TO THE PLATE,
BECAUSE OUR KIDS ARE HURTING
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE IT IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES
40. NÓ ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
SENATE. THIRD READING.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO
SENATE. THIRD READING FILE ITEM
28 SCA TWO BY SENATORS. TO PASS
ON FILE.
MEMBERS, I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR ATTENTION AND PATIENCE
TODAY. I KNOW YOU'RE ALL EXCITED
ABOUT FINISHING UP OUR WORK. WE
ARE DOING A LITTLE MORE
ORGANIZING. THAT'S GOING TO
REQUIRE A TEN MINUTE BREAK.
WE'RE GOING TO BE BACK HERE
SHARP AT 850. SO YOU GET STAY IN
THE BUILDING, STAY IN THE SENATE
FLOOR OR THE RESTROOMS, ASK YOU
TO BE BACK HERE AT 850 SHARP.
THANK YOU.
OF THE SENATE WILL COME BACK TO
ORDER. MEMBERS. MEMBERS, IF YOU
CAN RETURN TO YOUR DESKS, WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE OUR PROGRAM
THIS EVENING WITH FILE ITEM 83.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
OUR EVENING SESSION BY ITEM 83.
THIS IS HCR TWO TRÊN. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TO TÍNH BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT RELATIVE TO
COASTAL WATERS. SENATOR LEMON,
THANK YOU, MEMBERS, ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT, I RISE
TO PRESENT ACR 120, WHICH
DECLARES THE LEGISLATURE'S
SUPPORT FOR NEW AND EXISTING
MARINE PROTECTED MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS AND URGES STATE
AGENCIES, COUNCILS AND
COMMISSIONS TO PRIORITIZE THESE
AREAS. THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
THE MARINE LIFE PROTECTION ACT
IN 1999, WHICH SET UP A PROCESS
TO ESTABLISH MPAS USING
SCIENTIFIC DATA. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
MANAGES THE PROGRAM, AND EVERY
TEN YEARS SOLICITS INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS TO UPDATE THE ACT.
CURRENTLY, CALIFORNIA HAS 124
PROTECTED AREAS WHICH COVER
APPROXIMATELY 852MI² OF STATE
WATERS, WHICH EQUATE TO ABOUT
16% OF ALL COASTAL WATERS ARE
COVERED BY MPAS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR LIMON. ANY DISCUSSION,
ANY DEBATE ON THIS RESOLUTION?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE. I'LL
VOTE NO. ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. NO. DODD. AYE. DURAZO
AYE. EGGMAN GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN.
AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN.
AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO. NO. JOBO. NO PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO.
AYE. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER SMALL.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
SENATOR LIMON MOVES A CALL. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
THIS IS XJR 16. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION 16 BY SENATOR
PADILLA. RELATIVE TO THE
CHUCKWALLA NATIONAL MONUMENT,
THE JOSHUA TREE NATIONAL
MONUMENT, AND THE CARSON
NATIONAL MONUMENT. SENATOR
PADILLA. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. XJR 16
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THIS
RESOLUTION URGES THE UNITED
STATES PRESIDENT TO USE THE
ANTIQUITIES ACT OF 1906 TO
ESTABLISH THE CHUCKWALLA
NATIONAL MONUMENT. THE WATSON
NATIONAL MONUMENT AND THE
NATIONAL PARK SERVICE MANAGED
JOSHUA TREE NATIONAL MONUMENT
ADJACENT TO THE NATIONAL PARK.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ADDED THE
WATSON MONUMENT TO THE
RESOLUTION. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS RESOLUTION?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON A BILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKESBERG.
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. DODD
AYE. DARAZO AYE. EGGMAN GLAZER.
AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ GROVE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE MENJIVAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. AYE AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROD. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK. WE HAVE MEMBERS OFF
THE FLOOR. SENATOR PADILLA MOVES
A CALL. NEXT UP, SJ ARE NUMBER.
THIS IS FILED. ITEM SIX. SJ R
17. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION BY
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION 17 BY
SENATOR ALLEN. RELATIVE TO THE
DELYLAH NATIONAL MONUMENT.
SENATOR ALLEN. MEMBERS. THIS
BILL URGES THE PRESIDENT, UNITED
STATES, TO ESTABLISH THE
NATIONAL MONUMENT IN THE NORTH.
SACRED LANDS OF THE PIT RIVER
TRIBE AND THE SHASTA AREA. ITS
BEAUTIFUL LAND. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THE RESOLUTION? ANY DISCUSSION
ON THE RESOLUTION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLY. DODD. AYE. DARAZO
AYE. EGGMAN. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE.
NILO. AYE. CHOBOT. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH RUBIO.
ACIERTO AYE. SKINNER SMALL.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK.
SEN. ALLEN MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
RECOGNIZE THE MAJORITY LEADER,
SENATOR GONZALEZ. MOTION. I HOPE.
OKAY THANK YOU, MISTER PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, THERE IS A RESOLUTION
AT THE DESK REQUESTING
PERMISSION TO INVOKE THE
CONSTITUTION AS IT RELATES TO
ASSEMBLY BILL 2032. MISTER
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION. JUST A MOMENT.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
RESOLVED. THAT ASSEMBLY BILL
2032 PRESENTS A CASE OF URGENCY,
AS THAT TERM IS USED IN ARTICLE
FOUR, SECTION EIGHT B OF THE
CONSTITUTION, AND THE PROVISION
OF THAT SECTION REQUIRING THAT
THE BILL BE READ ON THREE
SEVERAL DAYS IN EACH HOUSE, IS
HEREBY DISPENSED WITH, AND IT IS
ORDERED THAT SAID BILL BE READ
THE SECOND AND THIRD TIMES
CONSIDERED ENGROSSED AND PLACED
UPON ITS PASSAGE. SENATOR JONES,
FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE? I
SUPPORT THE MOTION. ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. COWAN AYE. I'LL GO.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLEY AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN NEUMANN. AYE NGUYEN.
AYE MILO. AYE. JOBO AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. I
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB WIENER. AYE.
WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE MIN.
AYE SKINNER. WAHAB AYE. WILK ON
A VOTE OF 37 TO 0. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THE BILL AND TITLE.
THE SECOND AND THIRD TIME. THIS
IS AB 2032. ASSEMBLY BILL 2032
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM
PATTERSON. AN ACT RELATING TO
TRIBAL GAMING AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. AN ACT RELATING TO
TRIBAL GAMING AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. ALL RIGHT. THE BILL
HAVING BEEN READ A SECOND AND
THIRD TIME, WILL NOW MOVE TO
FILE ITEM ONE. FILE ITEM ONE IS
AB 2032. FOR THE SENATOR GROVE.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, THANK YOU FOR THAT
RULE WAIVER VOTE TODAY. I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2032. ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER JIM PATTERSON,
WHICH RATIFIES THE TRIBAL STATE
GAMING COMPACT BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND BIG SANDY
RANCHERIA OF WESTERN MONO
INDIANS IN FRESNO COUNTY, THE
BIG SANDY RANCHERIA OF WESTERN
MONO INDIANS IS A FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBE WITH A RICH
HISTORY IN CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL
VALLEY. THE TRIBE IS LOCATED ON
A TRUST KNOWN AS THE BIG SANDY
RANCHERIA IN AUBERRY. BIG SANDY
ENJOYS STRONG SUPPORT FROM ALL
OF ITS LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEADERS,
AND BIG SANDY RANCHERIA HAS ALSO
BEEN A STRONG SUPPORTER AND A
GOOD NEIGHBOR IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. INVESTING IN FIRE
DEPARTMENTS, LAW ENFORCEMENT,
VETERANS, CRIME, VICTIMS,
PROTECTIONS AND GROUPS,
LIBRARIES, HISTORICAL,
HISTORICAL MONUMENTS, AND
SUPPORTING OTHER TRIBES AS WELL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO RATIFY
THE COMPACT BEFORE YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATOR GROVE, ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI.
I'LL GO BY ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLY. AYE. DODD. AYE.
DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER.
AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
IGHODARO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE. CHOBOQ.
ABADIA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO
AYE. SKINNER SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AL-WAHHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. ASSEMBLY
SENATOR GROVE MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS THE HOUR IS LATE, BUT WE
ARE MAKING GREAT PROGRESS. BUT
WE DO NEED A FEW MINUTES TO GET
A FEW THINGS ORGANIZED. SO WE
ARE GOING TO INVITE YOU ALL TO
TAKE A 15 MINUTE BREAK THAT WE
WILL RESUME AT 948. 948 PLEASE
BE BACK HERE IN THE CHAMBERS,
AND WE'D LIKE TO ASK YOU TO STAY
HERE IN THE SENATE FACILITY
UNTIL WE CAN RECONVENE. SO WE'LL
BE IN RECESS.
WHO ARE HERE WITH US IN THE
GALLERY? WE WELCOME YOU TO THE
NIGHT SHIFT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. WE HOPE YOU'RE
ENJOYING THE EVENING. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE OUR PRESIDING
OFFICER. COME ON, BACK UP. A
LITTLE BIT OF A RUN OF SHOW FOR
THE REST OF THE EVENING. IT'S
GOING TO BE A BIT OF A POKE. WE
ARE GOING TO POKE AROUND. WE
HAVE A FEW MEASURES LEFT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO BE ABLE
TO COMPLETE. ON THE ASSEMBLY
BILL SIDE, WE ARE WAITING FOR
MEASURES TO BE ABLE TO ARRIVE
BACK FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY. ONCE WE HAVE THOSE,
WE'LL BE TAKING THOSE UP IN
QUICK ORDER. WE'RE GOING TO BE
HAVING A PRESIDING OFFICER COME
BACK, TAKE A COUPLE OF BILLS OFF
OF CALL. WE'RE GOING TO ASK ALL
SENATORS TO PLEASE RETURN TO
THEIR DESKS, AND WE'LL GET GOING
HERE IN APPROXIMATELY TWO
MINUTES.
MEMBERS, WE ARE COMING BACK TO
ORDER. I INVITE ALL THE SENATORS
TO COME BACK INTO THE CHAMBERS
AND FIND THEIR DESKS. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM 57.
MEMBERS THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
3233. I KNOW YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH IT. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 3233 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, ADDISON ACT RELATING TO
OIL AND GAS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM SENATOR LAIRD.
SENATOR LAIRD, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. ARE WE CONSIDERED
THIS BILL? IT GOT 20 VOTES. IT'S
ON RECONSIDERATION. WE HAD A
VERY ROBUST DEBATE. I THINK IT'S
A GOOD BILL. I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I VOTE AYE. GILL NO.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS I
BECKER. AYE. BLAKESBERG I
BRADFORD. CABALLERO CORTEZ. I
DEL. NÓ. DODD NO. DURAZO EGGMAN
I GLAZER. NO. NO. GONZALEZ I
GROVE. NO DATO. NO JONES. NO.
LAIRD I LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR I MIN. NEWMAN. NO.
NGUYEN NO. NILO NO. JOBO NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO.
SATO. NO SKINNER. SMALL. CUEVAS
I STERN I UMBERG. WAHAB. AYE
WIENER. AYE. WILK PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. DURAZO MIN. AYE.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO SKINNER.
I'M. BERG WILK. SENATOR LAIRD
MOVES THE CALL.
MEMBERS. WE ARE GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM 57. THIS
IS AB 3233. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE. THERE
IT IS. DURAZO PORTANTINO ROTH.
RUBIO SKINNER. AYE, AYE. UMBERG
WILK. AYES 21. NOES 12. THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO. MEMBERS
I WANT TO FIRST OF ALL, SAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
DURING OUR SESSION TODAY. WE AS
THE PRO TEM SAID AT THE START,
WE KNOW THESE LAST NIGHTS ARE
TYPICALLY STARTS AND STOPS AND
THAT'S JUST PART OF THE NATURE
OF IT. AND WE KNOW PEOPLE ARE
READY TO FINISH UP OUR WORK AND,
AND GET ON BACK TO OUR
DISTRICTS, BUT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A LITTLE MORE TIME AS WE
AWAIT BILLS TO COME BACK FROM
THE ASSEMBLY. IF YOU WANTED TO
PROJECT AHEAD, I THINK WE'RE
PROBABLY HERE FOR ANOTHER HOUR
OR SO. BUT I DO HAVE SOME GOOD
NEWS. I DO HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS
FOR THOSE WHO ARE BIG CALIFORNIA
FANS. CALIFORNIA BEAT UC DAVIS
31 TO 13 TODAY, AND IF YOU'RE
SAN DIEGO STATE FANS, IT'S AN
EVEN BIGGER NEWS. THEY BEAT
TEXAS, TEXAS A&M 4514. SO THAT'S
PRETTY EXCITING. AND HERE'S
ANOTHER REALLY EXCITING SCORE
FOR THOSE WHO ARE. IF YOU'RE
TAPING THIS STUFF, THEN CLOSE
YOUR EARS. THE UNIVERSITY OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA, I MEAN,
EXCUSE ME, OREGON BEAT IDAHO
2414. AND MAYBE THE MOST
EXCITING NEWS OF THE DAY WAS NOT
A WIN, BUT A GOOD LOSS. AND
THAT'S FRESNO STATE TAKING ON
MICHIGAN AT MICHIGAN AND
MICHIGAN 30, FRESNO STATE TEN.
BUT PRETTY DARN IMPRESSIVE TO
THE FORMER NATIONAL CHAMPIONS,
RIGHT THERE. SO WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A FEW LET'S SAY AGAIN. ALL
RIGHT. BUT WE WILL TAKE. LISTEN
EVERYBODY'S BEEN REALLY GREAT.
AND I KNOW FOR SOME OF US THIS
IS LIKE OUR FINAL FINAL NIGHT
LOOKS LIKE IT. BUT I KNOW THAT
WE'RE TAKING IT ALL IN AND
ENJOYING THIS MOMENT. SENATOR
PORTANTINO, WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU
RISE? WHAT'S YOUR POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE? I WAS
FIGURING SINCE YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT SPORTS SCORES, I MIGHT ASK
A SPORTS TRIVIA QUESTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WHO WAS THE
FIRST PRESIDENT TO THROW A PITCH
OUT AT A MAJOR LEAGUE GAME? WHO
WAS THE FIRST PRESIDENT? SPORTS
TRIVIA. WHO KNOWS? THERE'S A
ROOSEVELT SUGGESTION FROM
SENATOR LAIRD. MR. ALLEN GOT IT
RIGHT. TAFT IN 1910 THREW IT OUT
TO WALTER JOHNSON OF THE
WASHINGTON SENATORS. ALL RIGHT.
AND WITH THAT, WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK INTO RECESS FOR JUST A FEW
MINUTES. AND I HAVE ONE MORE. I
MAY HAVE LOST MY JOB, SIR, I WE
SO APPRECIATE YOU. AND IN
RECESS, YOU CAN JUST USE YOUR
YOUR LOUD VOICE AND PEOPLE. CAN
I HAVE ONE MORE? HOLD ON. WE'RE
BACK IN RECESS. OH OH, YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO LET ME ASK ONE MORE
QUESTION? TURN THE MIC OFF. SO
NOT ON THE MIC. ALL RIGHT.
YEP. OKAY, MEMBERS, WE'RE BACK
FROM OUR RECESS. MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL AND FILE
ITEM 76. 76 IS AB 3129.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
BRADFORD DODD. AYE AYE. EGGMAN
GLASER. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE
AYE. MENGIBAR NEWMAN. PORTANTINO
RUBIO. AYES 21. NOS 11. THE
MEASURE PASSES. OKAY WE'RE BACK
IN RECESS FOR A MOMENT. MEMBERS,
PLEASE STAY AT YOUR DESKS. STAY.
STAY IN THE. STAY IN THE ROOM.
CAN I GET EVERYONE'S ATTENTION,
PLEASE? SHH OBVIOUSLY, WE HAVE A
FEW THINGS TO DO BEFORE THE
EVENING IS DONE. SO WE WANT
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE AND
ATTENTION AND QUIET SO THAT THE
CLERK CAN HEAR THE ROLL. THAT
WOULD ALWAYS BE HELPFUL. AND FOR
MEMBERS THAT LET THEIR VOICES BE
HEARD. SO WE CAN HEAR THEM WHEN
THE VOTE IS CAST. OKAY. WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
95. THIS IS SENATE BILL 422.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 422 BY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
AN ACT RELATING TO UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. SENATOR PORTANTINO
S.B. 422 WAS AMENDED IN THIS
ASSEMBLY TO CLEAR UP THE
DISCREPANCIES WITH LOAN OUT
CORPORATIONS FOR THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY. I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION
ON THE MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
ALL RIGHT, WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AYES 38, NOES ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NEXT ONE UP IS FILED. ITEM 96.
THIS IS SB 572. CLERK, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 572 BY SENATOR
SMALL CUEVAS AND AQUILINA. STATE
PROPERTY. SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT 572. THIS
BILL WOULD HELP FACILITATE THE
TRANSFER OF STATE PROPERTY FROM
STATE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT, LOCATED AT 5401
CRENSHAW BOULEVARD, TO A LOCAL
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST. THANK YOU.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION. ALL
RIGHT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON A
BILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY AYE. DODD. AYE RAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. I'M IN. I'M
IN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE
NILO. CHOBOQ. AYE. PURDUE
PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. SKINNER AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS. AYE STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. JONES NILO. Dð SATO.
WILK AYE. VOTE OF 35 TO 0. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP, FILE ITEM
97. THIS IS SB 615. CLERK,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 615 BY
SENATOR ALLEN AND ACT RELATING
TO HAZARDOUS WASTE. SENATOR
ALLEN. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
SB 615 IS BACK IN THE SENATE. IN
CONCURRENCE, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE AND MEMBERS, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NONE, PLEASE CALL THE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I VOTE AGO.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALI AYE. DODD
AYE. DARAZO. AYE. EGGMAN GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE JONES.
NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMON AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MCGRAW. I MEAN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN YILO. KROBO
PADILLA. PORTANTINO BY ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO. AYE
SKINNER. WISEMAN. CUEVAS. AYE
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. EGGMAN
AYE. GROVE HURTADO. AYE. NGUYEN
MILO. PADILLA. WILK. ON A VOTE
OF 33 TO 1, THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. THE
MEMBERS, AS WE GO THROUGH THE
REMAINING BILLS, WE'RE ONLY
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL
CALL ONCE. OKAY? JUST ONCE. SO
PLEASE PAY ATTENTION SO YOUR
VOICE CAN BE HEARD. ALL RIGHT.
NEXT ONE UP IS FILE ITEM 98.
THIS IS SB 675 BY SENATOR LEMON.
SENATOR LEMON, CLERK. PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 675 BY SENATOR
LEMON. AN ACT TO FIRE
PREVENTION. SENATOR LEMON. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS SB SIX 675 IS UP
FOR CONCURRENCE. AND IT IS
RELATED TO PRESCRIBED GRAZING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE.
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AYES 30 800. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NEXT UP IS FILED ITEM 99. THIS
IS SB 961. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 961 BY SENATOR
WIENER NH█P RELATING TO
VEHICLES. SENATOR WIENER SB 961
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE, ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE. IT'S ONLY GOING
TO BE READ ONCE. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EVERYONE PLEASE. QUIET, PLEASE.
COWAN. I'LL VOTE AGO. NO
ARCHULETA. ASHBY. ARCHULETA. AYE
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY NO. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN NO. NEWMAN
AYE. WAYNE. NO. NILO NO. JOB.
NO. PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE. ROD
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO. NO SKINNER.
AYE. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK ON A VOTE OF 26 TO 9, THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS, PLEASE
RAISE YOUR VOICES SO WE CAN HEAR
THEM ON YOUR VOTES. OKAY. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM 100.
THIS IS SB 976. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 976 BY
SENATOR SKINNER. AN ACT RELATING
TO YOUTH ADDICTION. SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU. SENATE.
SENATORS. MY COLLEAGUES, THIS IS
MY LAST BILL AS A SENATOR. SB
976 IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. IT
IS A BILL THAT WILL PROTECT OUR
KIDS FROM SOCIAL MEDIA ADDICTION
WITHOUT IMPEDING ON ANY CONTENT
AND ALLOWING KIDS TO SEARCH FOR
WHATEVER CONTENT THEY CHOOSE.
AND WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. MEMBERS.
ANY DISCUSSION, ANY DEBATE ON
THE MATTER? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AYE. I'LL RODA-GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBURG. AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALI. DODD DURAZO. AYE EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE DATO. AYE. JONES NO.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE MENGIBAR. MEN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN YILO. KROBO Dð.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO. NÓ. SKINNER. AYE.
MOORLACH. RIVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. BOB AYE. WIENER
WILK. MENGIBAR. AYE ON A VOTE OF
28 TO 2, THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM 101. THIS IS SB 1037.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1037 BY SENATOR WIENER. AN
ACT RELATING TO HOUSING. SENATOR
WIENER. 1037 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RODA-GIL NO. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
BLAKESBURG. AYE. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. NØ. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
DATO. AYE JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE
LIMON. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. I
MEAN AYE. NEWMAN. NO. NGUYEN NO.
NILO. NO JOBO. NO. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
SEYARTO. NO. SKINNER. A SMALL
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. ON
A VOTE OF 23 TO 9, THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON TO ITEM 102. THIS IS
SB 1221. SECRETARY, PLEASE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1221 BY SENATOR. MEN ENACT
RELATING TO GAS CORPORATIONS.
SENATOR. MEN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MATTER? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OAN. Ã
ALVARADO. GILL. NÓ. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKESBERG. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALI. NØ DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO NO. OJOBO. NO. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO. NO. SKINNER AYE. RIVAS.
AYE STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK ON A VOTE OF 30. IN FAVOR?
EIGHT AGAINST. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON TO FILE 103. THIS IS
SB 1223. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1223 BY SENATOR
BECKER AND ACT RELATING TO
PRIVACY. SENATOR BECKER.
MEMBERS. WHAT AM I THINKING
RIGHT NOW? THIS MINERAL RIGHTS
BILL. BACK IN CONCURRENCE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL WITHOUT
OBJECTIONS. AYES 38. NÓ ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 104. THIS IS SB 1381.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1381 BY SENATOR WAHAB. AN
ACT RELATING TO CRIMES. SENATOR
WAHAB. THANK YOU. SB 1381 IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL THAT OBJECTIONS. AYES
38. NØ ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON TO ITEM 105. THIS IS
SB 1400. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1400 BY SENATOR
STERN AND AQUILINA. CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE. SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THESE AMENDS
ALTER CONDITIONS OF DISMISSAL TO
ENSURE PEOPLE DEEMED INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL, GET THE CARE
THEY NEED. REMOVE OPPOSITION
FROM BOTH THE DA'S AND THE
PUBLIC DEFENDERS. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. MEMBERS.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
MEASURE. IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR.
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 30 800. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO ITEM
106. THIS IS SB 1394. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1394 BY
SENATOR. MEN AND AQUILINA.
VEHICLES SENATOR. MEN. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS IS MY
LAST BILL, AND IT WAS AMENDED IN
THE ASSEMBLY TO ADD SENATOR
ASHBY AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
AS COAUTHORS, AMONG OTHER
THINGS. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THAT
MEASURE? DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AYES 30 800. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON TO ITEM 107. THIS IS
SB 1414. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1414 BY SENATOR
GRUBB AND AQUILINA. CRIMES.
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS CONDITIONALLY ADDED
16 AND 17 YEAR OLDS BACK INTO
THE BILL. I WISH CHILDREN WERE
PROTECTED UNDER THE BILL
EQUALLY, BUT WE DID MOVE THE
NEEDLE FORWARD AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THAT AN
OBJECTION? NO, THAT'S JUST A
WAVE. ALL RIGHT, WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 38. NO. ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS. MOVING ON
TO ITEM 108. THIS IS SB 1420.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1420 BY SENATOR CABRERA
RELATING TO ENERGY. SENATOR
CABALLERO. THANK YOU. SB 1420 IS
BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY ON ON
CONCUR AND I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON RODA-GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD
HI. CABALLERO. HI. CORTEZ. HI
DAILY. AYE. DODD. AYE RAZO.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES AYE. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MINGYUAN. AYE.
MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
AYE. NILO. AYE. EBCLC. AYE
PADILLA. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. NGUYEN WIENER. WELL GROVE.
AYE. ON A VOTE OF 35 IN FAVOR,
ZERO AGAINST. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON TO ITEM 109. THIS IS
SB 1162. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1162 BY SENATOR
CORTEZ. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC CONTRACTS. SENATOR
CORTEZ. MR. PRESIDENT, I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB 1162, AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION?
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO FURTHER
DEBATE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. OAN I VOTE AYE. YOU
KNOW ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY. NØ. DODD. AYE. I. EGGMAN!
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO. NO NO. PADILLA. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
SEYARTO. NO. SKINNER A SMALL
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK. ALL RIGHT. ON A VOTE OF 30
TO 8, THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO
ITEM 110. THIS IS SENATE BILL
1350. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1350 BY SENATOR
DILORENZO. AN ACT RELATING TO
PRIVATE EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR
DURAZO. REGARDING SB 1350, I ASK
FOR YOUR. I VOTE IN CONCURRENCE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. NO. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKESBERG. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. NØ. DODD.
AYE. HUESO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE.
NORDAUTO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO NO. NO.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. NO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILL. BECAUSE
A VERY IMPORTANT MEMBER WASN'T
PAYING ATTENTION. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENTEES ONE MORE TIME.
GLAZER. AYE. AYE. PADILLA. WILK
ON A VOTE OF 30 IN FAVOR. EIGHT
AGAINST THE ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS. ALL
THESE SENATE BILLS HAVE COME
BACK IN. AND YOU ALL WERE JUST
FANTASTIC IN TAKING CARE OF
BUSINESS. SO. THAT'S OUT OF
ORDER. BERNIE TOLD ME TO DO
THAT. THAT'S OUT OF ORDER.
THERE'S NO APPLAUSE HERE IN THE
SENATE. OKAY. WE HAVE WE HAVE A
COUPLE BILLS ON CALLS, MEMBER
MEMBERS, AND WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO ADJUST THE
EQUIPMENT, AND WE'RE GOING TO
COME BACK AND FINISH THOSE UP SO
WE CAN COMPLETE OUR WORK
TONIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. PLEASE STAY IN YOUR
CHAIRS WHILE WE JUST FINISH THIS
LAST BIT OF WORK.
OKAY. MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO GET OUT OF HERE
EARLY, GUYS. 34 HOURS. IT'S ALL
A MATTER OF FRAMING.
MEMBERS, LET ME JUST NOTE, WE'RE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALLS HERE. I
KNOW THAT A NUMBER OF MEMBERS
HAVE SOME MOTIONS UNDER MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. I KNOW THAT A
NUMBER OF MEMBERS WANT TO BE
RECOGNIZED UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. WE WILL DO THAT
THIS EVENING. DON'T WORRY. DON'T
GO HOME. BUT WE ARE GOING TO
FINISH THOSE MOTIONS. THE
RESOLUTIONS ON CALL. SO LET'S
LET'S GO THERE. NEXT, THIS WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH PHIL ITEM
83. THIS IS A CR TWO TRÊN
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA I
EGGMAN I MCGUIRE I SKINNER I
WILK. ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 8. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. NEXT UP
IS FILE ITEM FIVE, SER 16.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA I
DOLLY. EGGMAN I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
JONES. MCGUIRE I WAYNE. SKINNER
I WILK. ON A VOTE OF 35 TO 0.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVING ON TO ITEM SIX. THIS IS
SJ R 17. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA. I
DALLY. EGGMAN I GROVE. JONES
MCGUIRE. I SKINNER I WILK ON A
VOTE OF 36 TO 0. THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. OUR LAST ITEM ON
CALL IS FILE ITEM ONE. THIS IS
AB 2032. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE OPPOSITE MEMBERS. MCGUIRE I
SKINNER I WILK. THAT'S A VOTE OF
39 TO 0 ON THE URGENCY 39 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES. YEAH GOT A
LOT. THAT'S WHY I VOTED FOR.
UNLESS CLEARLY ANY MEMBERS. IF I
CAN GET YOUR ATTENTION, SH.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS, AND
WE'RE GOING TO ASK EVERYBODY TO
BE QUIET SO WE CAN HEAR THEM,
AND THE DESK CAN HEAR THEM, AND
WE CAN MAKE SURE THEY'RE
RECORDED CORRECTLY AND PROPERLY.
SO IF I COULD ASK MEMBERS TO
RETURN TO THEIR DESKS, PLEASE,
AND TO CURB THE CONVERSATION ON
THE FLOOR. VERY GOOD. WE'LL
BEGIN WITH SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I
RISE TO SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE
SENATE DAILY JOURNAL. THIS
LETTER IS SUBMITTED TO CLARIFY
THE INTENT OF SB 1423, WHICH
REQUIRES DHS TO CONVENE A RURAL
HOSPITALS TECHNICAL ADVISORY
GROUP TO ANALYZE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF ALL EXISTING
MEDI-CAL REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGIES EMPLOYED BY
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS, INCLUDING,
BUT NOT LIMITED TO, SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS, FEE FOR SERVICE
REIMBURSEMENT, AND MANAGED CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS. THE LETTER HAS
BEEN CLEARED BY BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DALY. THE DESK WILL
NOTE, LET'S GO TO SENATOR.
SENATOR ROTH. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. REQUEST WE MOVE AB
382, FILE ITEM NUMBER 35 TO THE
ENACTED FILE AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR. THE DESK WILL NOTE
SENATOR UMBERG. MR. PRESIDENT,
PLEASE MOVE. BAUER KHN AB 2930,
FILE NUMBER 69, TO THE INACTIVE
FILE AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR. THE DESK WILL NOTE.
SENATOR LIMÓN. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS, I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUBMIT A LETTER TO
THE JOURNAL REGARDING THE INTENT
OF SB 675. THIS REQUEST HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY BOTH SIDES. DESK
WILL NOTE SENATOR WAHAB, THANK
YOU. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY, PLEASE MOVE FILE
ITEM 34 AB 2593 TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. THANK YOU. DESK WILL NOTE
SENATOR BECKER TO THE JOURNAL
FOR SB 942 TO CLARIFY THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT. LETTER
CLARIFIES THAT BY USING THE
TERMS USER AND PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE IN THE DEFINITION OF
PROVIDER, IT IS NOT MY INTENT TO
CAPTURE TOOLS USED EXCLUSIVELY
FOR BUSINESS BUSINESS PURPOSES,
BUT HAS BEEN APPROVED BY BOTH
SIDES, DESK WILL NOTE SENATOR
WIENER, I THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE SENATE DAILY
JOURNAL CLARIFYING MY INTENT
REGARDING SB 937 AS IT RELATES
TO 100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE
LETTER HAS BEEN CLEARED BY BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE, THE DESK
WILL NOTE, AND WE GO TO OUR
OUTSTANDING MAJORITY LEADER,
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO ADD FILE
ITEMS 39 AB, 3021 TO THE
INACTIVE FILE FILE ITEM 41 AB
3172 TO THE INACTIVE FILE FILE
ITEM 50 AB 1082 TO THE INACTIVE
FILE FILE. ITEM 51 AB 2441 TO
THE INACTIVE FILE FILE. ITEM 54
AB 3211 TO THE INACTIVE FILE
FILE. ITEM 55 AB 2416 TO THE
INACTIVE FILE AND IN FILE ITEM
49 AB 2996 TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
THE DESK WILL NOTE ANY OTHER
MATTERS UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. MEMBERS SENATOR
CABALLERO, GENTLEMAN. MR. NÓ,
I'LL DO THIS ONE. I'LL SEE YOU
DOWN IN OUR DISTRICT. YEAH. MR.
PRESIDENT, I RISE TO ENTER A
LETTER INTO THE JOURNAL IN
REGARDS TO SB 366 THAT HAS BEEN
REVIEWED AND APPROVED. I ASK FOR
UNANIMOUS CONSENT WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE WANT TO
RECONCILE THE FILES TO MAKE SURE
WE'VE COVERED ALL THE MEASURES
THAT ARE BEFORE US THIS EVENING.
SO ASK MEMBERS TO STAY, REMAIN
IN THE CHAMBERS AT YOUR DESKS
WHILE WE JUST DO THIS PAPERWORK.
FOR MEMBERS. WE STILL HAVE SOME
BUSINESS MEMBERS ASK YOU TO
RETURN TO YOUR DESK. WE STILL
HAVE A COUPLE OF THINGS OF
BUSINESS TO DO. MEMBERS
SENATORS, IF YOU CAN RETURN TO
YOUR DESKS, PLEASE. SENATOR
NILO, SENATOR WIENER, SENATOR
ROTH, MEMBERS, IF YOU COULD
RETURN TO YOUR DESKS, PLEASE.
WE'RE GOING TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR
CABALLERO UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. WE'RE GOING TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR CABALLERO.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
FOR SB 768. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SENATOR NEWMAN, IS THAT A
MICROPHONE UP?
MEMBERS. WE STILL HAVE WORK TO
DO. MEMBERS, IF YOU CAN RETURN
TO YOUR DESKS. SH BOY, AM I
GOING TO MISS THIS. MEMBERS, WE
HAVE A FEW THINGS TO DO. STILL
WE'RE GOING TO RECOGNIZE
EVERYBODY. YOU CAN JUST GRAB A
SEAT. GRAB A SEAT. WE'RE GOING
TO RECOGNIZE OUR MAJORITY LEADER,
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
ARE ORDERED TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. FILE ITEMS 28, 29, 30, 31,
32, 33, 38 AND 42. THANK YOU.
THE DESK WILL NOTE ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
FINISH UP OUR CEREMONY, OUR
SESSION TODAY WITH A COUPLE OF
REMARKS. WE WANT TO TURN FIRST
TO OUR LEADER OF THE REPUBLICANS
SENATOR JONES. PLEASE GIVE HIM
YOUR ATTENTION. MEMBERS. THANK
YOU. MR. PRESIDENT. THANK YOU,
MAJORITY LEADER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRO TEM, I WANT TO START WITH A
VERY IMPORTANT STATEMENT I THINK
IS THE PRO TEM MADE A PROMISE
AND THE PRO TEM KEPT A PROMISE.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH.
LOOK, IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE
ON THE LAST NIGHT OF SESSION AND
BE INVITED TO GIVE SOME CLOSING
REMARKS ON OUR PERSPECTIVE OF
SERVING IN THE SENATE. AND FOR
ME, IT IS A BIG DEAL, AND IT'S
AN HONOR TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND I KNOW THAT IN HIS CLOSING
REMARKS, THE PRO TEM IS GOING TO
RECOGNIZE THE COMBINED STAFF.
I'LL CALL THE BIPARTISAN,
NONPARTISAN STAFF THAT WE ALL
GET TO WORK FOR AND WITH. BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE JUST A COUPLE
OF MINUTES IF I MAY, AND TALK
ABOUT THE REPUBLICAN STAFF AND
THE WORK THAT THEY DO EVERY
SINGLE DAY. IT'S EASY AND IT'S
PROBABLY EASY FOR DEMOCRATS TO
GET BURNED OUT, TOO. BUT IT'S
EASY FOR REPUBLICANS TO GET
BURNED OUT HERE AND THIS
SUPERMAJORITY BUILDING AND TO BE
THE LOYAL OPPOSITION AND I HOPE
YOU ALL ARE OKAY WITH THAT
SELF-IMPOSED TITLE THAT WE'VE
PUT ON OURSELVES. BECAUSE IF YOU
WATCH PARLIAMENT, EITHER IN
CANADA OR IN UNITED KINGDOM, THE
LOYAL OPPOSITION, YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE REALLY THE ONES THAT
HELP THE GOVERNMENT RUN WELL.
AND I'M HOPING THAT THAT'S OUR
ROLE HERE AS WELL IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. EACH
ONE OF US ALTOGETHER, THE NINE
OF US, REPRESENT ABOUT 9 MILLION
CONSTITUENTS. AND IN OUR
DISTRICTS, WE REPRESENT
EVERYBODY. AND I KNOW YOU ALL DO
AS WELL. EACH ONE OF OUR
DISTRICT AND CAPITAL STAFFS DO
THAT EVERY SINGLE DAY. AND THEIR
UNWAVERING DEDICATION AND
PASSION DOES NOT GO UNNOTICED.
OUR WONDERFUL PERSONAL STAFFS
ARE AIDED EVERY DAY BY OUR
FANTASTIC CAUCUS STAFF AND OUR
RULES COMMITTEE. JULIE AND
CHRIS, OUR COMMUNICATIONS AND
DISTRICT SERVICES TEAM, LED BY
MAX HOLMBERG. DOUGLAS, OUR
FISCAL STAFF, LED BY KIRK
FEELEY, OUR POLICY STAFF LED BY
GREG MÀ AND ALL OF OUR STAFF LED
BY OUR STAFF DIRECTOR KIM JIM
CAJOLE. AND NO MATTER YOUR PARTY
AFFILIATION, THE STAFF ON OUR
SIDE MAKE HELP. MAKE THIS
BUILDING GO AROUND. IF YOU
WOULD, PLEASE JOIN ME IN A ROUND
OF APPLAUSE FOR THE REPUBLICAN
STAFF THAT HELPED KEEP THIS
PLACE RUNNING.
I'LL CLOSE WITH SOME PERSONAL
THOUGHTS ON SERVING IN THE
SENATE. MEMBERS ABOVE THE
ROSTRUM AND THE PRESIDENT PRO
TEM ARE THE WORDS SENT. IT'S THE
SENATOR'S DUTY TO PROTECT THE
LIBERTY OF THE PEOPLE. AND I
THINK EACH, EVERY SINGLE, EVERY
ONE OF US, WHEN WE WALK IN THIS
ROOM, HAVE THAT ON OUR MIND.
WHETHER YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT,
REPUBLICAN OR NO PARTY
PREFERENCE, IT'S AN HONOR TO
SERVE IN THIS BODY. EACH ONE OF
US REPRESENTS 931,000
CONSTITUENTS. THAT'S MORE THAN A
CONGRESS MEMBER REPRESENTS IN
CALIFORNIA OR ANY OTHER STATE.
SOME STATES, BUT IT'S MORE THAN
FIVE STATES, ENTIRE POPULATION.
FIVE STATES HAVE LESS POPULATION
THAN EACH ONE OF US HAVE AS
SENATORS, I'M TOLD THAT 199
PEOPLE HAVE HAD THE HONOR OF
BEING CALLED CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATOR. I WILL SAY THAT THIS IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE SMOOTHEST,
SMOOTHEST ENDINGS OF A SESSION
SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE. NOW LOOK. AND THE
PRO TEM DOESN'T GET ALL THE
CREDIT FOR THAT. BY THE WAY,
THERE HAS BEEN SOME EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCES IN PREVIOUS ENDING
SESSIONS THAT HE DIDN'T HAVE TO
PUT UP WITH THIS YEAR, THAT THE
PREVIOUS PRO TEM DID, AND WE
TALKED ABOUT THAT LAST TIME THE
REPUBLICANS WERE ABLE TO HOLD
THE GROUND ON A COUPLE OF BILLS,
AND WE SUPPORT THE PRO TEM
STATEMENT ON THE SPECIAL
SESSION. WE'VE HAD PLENTY OF
TIME TO GET THE WORK DONE. WE
DON'T NEED A SPECIAL SESSION.
ONE OF THE THINGS I WOULD LIKE
TO ENCOURAGE EACH AND EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF US, BUT ESPECIALLY
THE SENATORS THAT ARE LEAVING AS
YOU WALK OUT THE BUILDING
TONIGHT AND YOU WALK ACROSS THE
STREET TO GO BACK TO THE SWING
SPACE AND POTENTIALLY LEAVE FOR
THE LAST TIME ON THIS EVENING,
TAKE A MOMENT, TURN AROUND, LOOK
AT THIS BUILDING. WHEN IT'S LIT
UP AT NIGHT, AND RECOGNIZE HOW
SPECIAL OF A PLACE THIS IS TO BE
IN SACRAMENTO, CALIFORNIA ON THE
ENDING SESSION OF 2024. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE AND YOUR
FRIENDSHIP. GODSPEED. GOD BLESS.
MEMBERS. WE'RE NOW GOING TO TURN
TO OUR PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE,
THE DISTINGUISHED SENATOR MIKE
MCGUIRE. MAGUIRE. MR. PRESIDENT,
THANK YOU. I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT JUST TO SAY THANK YOU TO
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU FOR AN
INCREDIBLE YEAR, MAKING A
DIFFERENCE FOR COMMUNITIES UP
AND DOWN THIS GREAT STATE. YOU
KNOW, WHEN WE FIRST GOT BACK
INTO SESSION HERE THIS YEAR, WE
WERE FACING ONE HELL OF A STORM,
A MEGA BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT
THAT THREATENED THE PROGRESS
THAT THIS BODY, THE ASSEMBLY THE
GOVERNOR HAD MADE OVER THE PAST
DECADE. AS I'VE LEARNED FROM
DRIVING MY BIG AND BEAUTIFUL
DISTRICT UP AND DOWN THE NORTH
COAST, WHEN THINGS LOOK DARK,
YOU TURN ON THE BRIGHT LIGHTS
AND IT'S THE SAME THING HERE AT
THE CAPITOL. WHEN THINGS LOOK
DARK IN CALIFORNIA, THOSE OF US
WHO HAVE THE ABSOLUTE PRIVILEGE
AND I GET EMOTIONAL TALKING
ABOUT IT, WHO HAVE THE ABSOLUTE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING IN THIS
HISTORIC CHAMBER, HAVE TO TURN
THE BRIGHT LIGHTS ON, AND WE
HAVE TO WORK EVEN HARDER, THINK
EVEN SMARTER, AND DO EVEN
BETTER. AND THAT'S WHAT WE DID
THIS YEAR. AND I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU. NO MATTER IF YOU'RE A
REPUBLICAN OR A DEMOCRAT. WE
SECURED RECORD FUNDING FOR OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOL KIDS, RECORD
FUNDING, RECORD FUNDING FOR OUR
FIREFIGHTERS AND BEST
FIREFIGHTING FORCE IN AMERICA
WITH CAL FIRE, $1 BILLION FOR
HOMELESSNESS. WE WORKED TOGETHER
TO BE ABLE TO PASS A RETAIL
THEFT PACKAGE TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER. AND WE
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THE RISING
COSTS OF ELECTRICITY AND GAS
RATES. I WANT TO SAY A FEW THANK
YOUS BECAUSE I KNOW THAT WE'RE
LATE, AND I KNOW FOLKS WANT TO
GET HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES. I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO MY
FAMILY FIRST AND FOREMOST. AND
SO MANY OF OUR FAMILIES. I'M
GOING TO LOOK AT SENATOR OKOBOJI
AND START TO GET BLUBBERY. THEY
MAKE INCREDIBLE SACRIFICES FOR
WHAT WE DO EVERY DAY. AND I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO ERICA AND TO
OUR SON, CORNDOG, FOR THE
INCREDIBLE WORK THAT THEY DO
EACH AND EVERY DAY AND KEEP IT
ALL TOGETHER. I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO ERICA
CONTRERAS. YOU KNOW, SHE IS THE
GLUE THAT KEEPS THIS PLACE
TOGETHER. AND I THINK WE OWE HER
A ROUND OF APPLAUSE. AND I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
SECRETARY ERICA CONTRERAS. LET'S
GIVE IT UP. FOR MORNING. NOON.
NIGHT. WEEKENDS. SHE IS THERE
FOR US. SHE'S KEEPING US MOVING
FORWARD. AND WE'RE GRATEFUL.
BERNIE, WE LOVE YOU. WE ARE
GOING TO MISS YOU. IT WILL NEVER
BE THE SAME WITHOUT YOU. WE ARE
SO GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK, FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT, YOUR
FRIENDSHIP, YOUR PARTNERSHIP,
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE
LEADERSHIP THAT YOU SHOW US EACH
AND EVERY DAY. I THINK WE NEED
TO GET UP ON OUR FEET AND LET'S
GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE TO THE
ONE, THE ONLY BERNIE MCNULTY.
CAN WE ALSO GIVE IT UP TO THE
AMAZING DESK STAFF AS WELL? FOR
ALL OF THEIR HARD WORK? LET ME
HEAR YOU LOUD AND PROUD. WHETHER
IT'S THE DESK STAFF, ENGROSSING
AND ROLLING SENATE-TV STAFF, WE
ARE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL. ONE
MORE TIME, PLEASE LET ME HEAR
YOU LOUD. LET'S GIVE IT UP FOR
BERNIE MCNULTY. WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO CARA JENKINS AND
GABE PATEK. WE ARE SO GRATEFUL
TO OUR SERGEANTS. LED BY
SERGEANT CHIEF SERGEANT
RODRIGUEZ AND TO ALL OF THE
SENATE SERGEANTS. THEY WORK WITH
US EACH AND EVERY DAY. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THE SERGEANTS WHO
ARE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS STEP
FORWARD. WE NEED TO GIVE THEM A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE. WE COULDN'T
DO WHAT WE DO WITHOUT THEM, CAN
WE PLEASE GIVE A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE? LEROY IS ALL OVER IT.
CAN WE SAY THANK YOU TO THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL? CAN
WE SAY THANK YOU TO THE PARKING
ATTENDANTS? CAPITOL SECURITY
STAFF? LET'S GIVE THEM A ROUND
OF APPLAUSE. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. WE ARE SO GRATEFUL TO
JENNIFER HATFIELD AND THE
CAPITOL HEALTH SERVICES TEAM.
THEY HAVE BEEN GROUND ZERO,
GROUND ZERO SINCE THE PANDEMIC
FOR ALL OF US. WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL TO THEM. WE WANT TO SAY
SUSAN DE LA FUENTE, WHO IS
PHENOMENAL FOR KEEPING US SAFE
AND ALWAYS GIVING US A NOTICE.
LET'S GIVE HER A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE. MY GOODNESS, THANK
YOU. WE LOVE YOU, SUSAN. TO THE
DGS AND HOUSEKEEPING STAFF, THE
GROUND STAFF HERE, CAN WE PLEASE
GIVE THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE TO
OUR LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER, TO
THE LEGISLATIVE TRAVEL OFFICE
THAT KEEPS US MOVING UP AND DOWN
THIS STATE. LET'S GIVE THEM A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN, WE NEED TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF
HERE IN THE SENATE. SOME OF THE
BEST AND BRIGHTEST IN THE UNITED
STATES, RIGHT HERE, WORKING WITH
ALL OF US. LET'S GIVE IT UP FOR
OUR COMMITTEE STAFF. WE WOULDN'T
BE WHO WE ARE EACH AND EVERY DAY
WITHOUT THE SENATE STAFF TEAM
AND EACH OF THE 40 OFFICES. WE
OWE THEM A DEBT OF GRATITUDE FOR
CHOOSING A LIFE OF SERVICE,
CHOOSING A LIFE OF WORKING FOR
THE PEOPLE. CAN WE PLEASE STAND
UP? I WANT TO HEAR YOU LOUD AND
PROUD. ONE MORE TIME. CAN WE
GIVE IT UP TO THE SENATE STAFF
WHO MAKE THIS PLACE GO AROUND
EACH AND EVERY DAY? THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE MADAM PRO
TEM EMERITUS FOR HER AMAZING
WORK THAT SHE DOES FOR THIS
STATE, FOR THE LEADERSHIP THAT
SHE HAS SHOWN US AND SOME OF THE
MOST DIFFICULT TIMES THAT WE
HAVE FACED AS THE STATE. CAN WE
PLEASE GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
TO MADAM PRO TEM EMERITUS MISS
TONI ATKINS? THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. TONI. WE LOVE YOU. I'M
GOING TO WRAP IT UP. I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO MY AMAZING
STAFF TEAM AND MANY OF US HAVE
BEEN TOGETHER FOR QUITE A LONG
TIME. REBECCA WICKS BURKE, WHO
IS BACK FROM MATERNITY LEAVE AND
HAS A SIX MONTH OLD JUDE, WHO IS
HERE AND HAPPY AND EXCITED AND
THE BEST SLEEPER THAT I HAVE
EVER SEEN, MAKES ME JEALOUS. WE
ARE SO HAPPY TO HAVE REBECCA
BACK. JASON LILES HAS BEEN
AMAZING. I'VE BEEN A FRIEND OF
HIS. ONE OF MY BEST FRIENDS IN
LIFE FOR 30 YEARS. I'M GRATEFUL
THAT HE STEPPED IN. I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO CARRIE
LEYENDECKER, OUR DISTRICT
DIRECTOR, WHO HAVE BEEN WITH
NEARLY TEN YEARS. CHRIS NIELSEN,
WHO I HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
SINCE I STARTED. THANK YOU.
CHRIS BARBARA, I'M GETTING ALL
BLUBBERY. OH MAN. BARBARA
MALANDRO, WHO IS OUR SCHEDULING
MANAGER, COULDN'T DO WHAT WE DO
EVERY DAY. I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO NICOLE BAROUCH, WHO RUNS
THE FLOOR FOR THE OFFICE. AND I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE KAYLA
FROM THE MAJORITY LEADER'S
OFFICE. THEY DO PHENOMENAL WORK
KEEPING US MOVING. CAN WE GIVE
THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE?
NICOLE. KAYLA, THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. DIANE GRIFFITHS
SHE IS OUR OUR ATTORNEY IN THE
OFFICE. THANK YOU. K-ROD
KIMBERLY RODRIGUEZ. WATCH OUT.
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL. DEPUTY CHIEF
OF STAFF NISHA FRITZ WHO WE JUST
CALL FRITZ, WHO DOES ALL ISSUES
OF COMMUNICATIONS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, FRITZ, FOR EVERYTHING YOU
DO. CHRIS WOODS, WHO IS OUR
BUDGET LEAD BUDGET DIRECTOR HERE
FOR DEMOCRATS AND TO THE ENTIRE
BUDGET TEAM, CAN WE GIVE THEM A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE, REPUBLICAN
AND DEMOCRAT ALIKE, LET'S SAY
THANK YOU, KURT, AS WELL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AND I WANT TO END
IT RIGHT HERE. NONE OF THIS
WOULD HAPPEN WITHOUT A TEAM. AND
I WANT TO LOOK TO LINA GONZALEZ
TO OUR ASSISTANT MAJORITY
LEADERS, ASHBY AND WAHAB, AND TO
OUR ENTIRE FLOOR TEAM. WE
COULDN'T DO WHAT WE DO EACH AND
EVERY DAY WITHOUT YOU. AND LET'S
BE HONEST, WE GOT DONE TONIGHT
THANKS TO THE ORGANIZATION ON
THIS FLOOR, NOT JUST DELIVERING
FOR ONE POLITICAL PARTY, BUT
DELIVERING FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO OUR FLOOR TEAM,
TO OUR CAUCUS CHAIR FOR ALL THE
WORK. CAN WE PLEASE GIVE THEM A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE? THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. I ALSO
WANT TO LOOK TO SENATOR JONES.
JONES I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOU. WE
DON'T ALWAYS SEE EYE TO EYE.
YEAH, BUT HERE'S WHAT I
APPRECIATE. WE WORK IT THROUGH.
AND IN A TIME OF HYPER
PARTIZANSHIP IN THIS COUNTRY,
WE'RE ABLE TO WORK TOGETHER, PUT
DIFFERENCES ASIDE, AND FOCUS ON
WHAT'S IMPORTANT, WHAT'S
IMPORTANT, THE PEOPLE AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REPRESENT.
CAN WE PLEASE GIVE A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE TO LEADER JONES? THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AND TO OUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES, THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. 1216 IT IS NOW
SUNDAY. WE SPENT SOME QUALITY
TIME TOGETHER. THIS WEEK TO ALL
OF OUR MEMBERS WHO ARE GOING TO
BE RETIRING THIS YEAR, I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT AND END IT RIGHT
HERE AND SAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR STEPPING UP TO SERVE.
CAN WE PLEASE HAVE ALL OF OUR
RETIRING MEMBERS STAND UP? CAN
WE PLEASE GIVE THEM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE AND SAY THANK YOU?
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD LUCK WITH
THAT. THANK YOU. UNTIL NEXT
TIME. DECEMBER 2ND, 2024. MR.
PRESIDENT. THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THE SENATE, MY FRIENDS, IS
ADJOURNED.